Three two,
one.
Boom.
Eve Edwards.
Welcome to the show.
Thanks for having me man.
Finally got you in here,
man.
We've talked about this a bunch of times,
but this is the perfect time because a,
we're doing a fight.
Companion is a very first one we've ever done for glory,
kickboxing,
Joe Schilling,
world championship.
Kickboxer himself is on his way.
He's over here.
He fucking hates glory.
They talk shit about him after he left,
but uh,
I'm sure it will be good.
We're going to have a good time,
man.
So there's some good fights tonight.
Uh,
Niki,
hold skins.
Fighting Israel at the sane.
Yes.
Fighting.
He's a bad motherfucker.
That's should be interesting.
And uh,
all this is live from Denver,
Colorado right now on UFC fight pass.
If you don't have UFC fight pass,
shame on you because a,
it's a great way to waste days,
days of time,
man.
You need to sit down and watch whatever you want from anywhere in the world.
It's Netflix for fights.
This is what it is.
It's just like they have everything from way back in the pride days.
All the old fade or fights,
the Vandelay fights back in the early two thousands,
all that shit.
And it's fun to go back and watch some of those little ones too.
Especially the pride tournament's.
Yeah,
man.
The golden days.
So the first fight of the night here is Justin Holton versus Jonathan Wide
Darko.
Um,
and uh,
they're reading the glory rules.
Um,
did you do much kickboxing at all?
I had full amateur kickboxing fights,
um,
three and mature boxing matches and to pro.
So was it American rules or Muay Thai [inaudible] Muay Thai to American rules.
So it was,
it was fun.
I mean,
it was amateur,
so we were wearing headgear,
we didn't throw elbows,
but it was good.
I was undefeated,
so that's good then.
I like that.
Yeah.
It's interesting because,
um,
I,
I'm a huge fan of kickboxing and I'm just kind of surprised that kickboxing
hasn't taken off in America the way MMA has,
but I just don't think it's been promoted the right way.
And Or,
and there was a,
a Dana white had a real good point and he said that the reason why is because
people,
when you think of kickbox and they think of PKA karate from ESPN at two o'clock
in the morning from the 1980s,
you know,
you have to throw this five kicks the book and it was like Shitty,
sloppy boxing and they,
you know,
they would throw those,
they would barely throw those kicks and then the pants they were wearing like
all of that was just crap.
Silly man.
They are fighting in pajamas with the boots,
those big boots that they would wear on the back on their feet.
What it is kinda interesting the boots,
because I brought this up many times when it comes to um,
MMA.
Like why do your elbows have nothing on him?
Why do your shins and knees have nothing on him but your knuckles do,
which is like the easiest thing to break.
The hardest thing to hit somebody hard with is a fist.
Yeah.
But you use those more.
And then then because of the cuts,
I think mostly for cuts,
bone on bone and that skin getting pinched in between there.
For sure he's getting cut up.
That's true.
But isn't that the case with elbows?
Yeah,
but I mean it's harder to land an elbow ignites.
Your name is Tim means it's harder to land an elbow.
There it is.
The land punches.
There's a few guys that are real elbow specialist.
Um,
Jordan means another one.
I remember when he fought Cyborg,
the other side board,
not the female to male Cyborg and strike force.
Holy Shit.
That elbow combination,
man.
That's one thing I don't like about glory.
I really wish they would go a full Moy Tai and um,
when Joe Schilling gets here,
you know,
Joe's obviously,
uh,
he's done both and he started out in [inaudible].
He's a big Muay Thai fan and they're having a lion fight is on tonight at the
same time.
So that's on access TV right now.
While this is going on right now on um,
on UFC fight pass.
I have never been,
I mean,
outside of an MMA fight,
I've never been hit with a,
with an elbow and Emily Tye fight.
I feel like that would throw me off like it did for some reason.
I feel it's different than MMA.
Like in MMA,
I've never been hit.
I don't remember being hit with an elbow on my feet,
but on the mat,
you know.
Um,
but in kickboxing,
I mean that's where you're at and I don't know that it's kind of scary.
I've hit people with elbows on my feet and it seems you'd,
it would,
it'd be shitty to be on the receiving end,
the one that knows,
I guess.
But it's very effective and I always feel like anytime you're eliminating
effective aspects of striking,
I'll give you take moy,
Tai and you eliminate two effective aspects of it.
Elbows and the clinch.
I mean,
those are,
those are two huge factors in fights,
especially the clinch.
I mean,
you take a guy like San Chai who can dump people from anywhere.
He just flips dudes,
you know,
he's so good at the clinch and so good at throwing elbows and knees to the body
from the clinch.
Yeah,
I don't,
I would look more,
the only thing I really don't like about Gloria is they feel like they do break
you from the clinch real quick.
We don't even have time to,
to,
to work in it needs in there.
Yeah.
I just feel like you should be able a to defend yourself if you get hurt and be,
you should be able to work needs to the body and elbows in the clench.
It's a,
it's just a massive part of Muay Thai and uh,
they've,
they've just sort of eliminated it to make it more exciting.
And it all came from k one k one was like a big step up from PKA.
Karate.
It was a big step up from kickboxing,
but they develop some rules that they thought would favor action and make things
go quicker.
Yeah.
I remember the first,
uh,
k one that was,
I think it was like,
what,
92 93 maybe [inaudible] 94 here.
Um,
where they advertised it as 80% knockouts.
Do you remember that?
80% knock guys,
they had five fights in the car at four.
Four ended by knockout.
That's so crazy.
80% knockouts.
It's so fucking crazy.
But I wouldn't be surprised.
I think,
um,
I know chemo fund on that.
Um,
oh wow.
That's Rasa.
Setaki wow.
Wow.
Oh that is so old school.
Think Good Ridge may fall on that too.
I don't remember for sure.
But it's just striking becomes a completely different animal when there's no
threat of the takedown.
Yeah,
it just does.
And it also becomes a completely different animal when there's no,
the Moitai aspect is removed.
The no threat of the clinch and no threat of the elbows.
Yeah,
that changes the range a lot.
You see guy easy,
what does the name hot and just did a spin.
You don't see a whole lot of spinning in MMA.
You get guys like wonder boy,
those guys that can do it and they do it well,
but you don't see that as much in a,
if you watch the UFC card,
you want to see as many spins as you do it and in glory.
Yeah.
I think really the only way to get them all,
not the only way,
but it's,
it's so hard for guys who develop an overall MMA game to ever be like really
effective with those kinds of traditional martial arts techniques.
Because I feel like some of those taekwondo techniques and kill Christian
techniques,
you have to start out with that stuff and not worry about getting punched in the
face in order to develop them.
I,
that's a big aspect of kill Kachin and a big aspect of taekwondo is that people
aren't punching you in the face.
Yeah.
Not Getting it.
Yeah,
because you're not,
you don't have that threat.
Yeah.
So you develop those crazy kicks and the leg dexterity and then I feel like
that's a great stepping stone.
If you can go from that and then learn how to wrestle and learn Jujitsu and
learn how to box and kickboxing,
then you'll always have those techniques.
But it's,
it's so rare that you take a guy who is like a real from the beginning,
mixed martial arts fighter and then develop that kind of ability.
Yeah.
I mean they,
they're,
they're focused on every aspect of martial law.
She was almost too much to learn.
Yeah.
You have to be a Highlander to get it all down.
It's,
it's,
it's so rare that anybody has like a full game that starts out from the
beginning.
But you know,
I think we're seeing these guys today,
which is Kinda,
it's an interesting time.
There's the real specialists like Wonderboy and on the other end,
like Damien Maia,
you know,
seeing real specialists,
you don't see that as much anymore.
I mean,
guys were individual specialists back in the day,
but now you get,
yeah,
you get a guy like wanting to,
boy,
you get a guy like Stephen Thompson,
I,
me and Tyron Woodley,
great wrestler.
He started mixing the rest into his game.
Then you get these guys like Dustin pull a Messiah backtick that came up doing
MMA and they're really good at different aspects of it.
Real strong and say the wrestling and Jujitsu,
good kickboxing,
but you put them in,
in,
in a ring with,
with uh,
Joe Schilling,
Schilling Ladies Gentlemen,
as if on cue
Joe showing where there's a draw them on.
We were just talking about the difference between a real specialists,
a high level specialty,
like a Stephen Thompson in MMA versus a guy like a Dustin Poirier who's a very
good striker.
But Wonderboy is something special,
you know,
that level.
His debts,
like,
you know,
he was something ridiculous like 37 and know as a kickboxer and his UFC career,
he's only lost a matte brown and fight where he said he overtrained for that
fight.
And you know,
Matt is obviously a savage and early in his UFC career too.
Yeah,
yeah.
So there's the first fight,
Joe Schilling,
and I know you're a huge fan of glory.
The organization,
the way they treat the fighters once they leave.
Absolutely.
We already discussed that.
It's good,
it's good for the sport.
It's good that,
you know,
like Laurie has done for kickboxing.
This is awesome.
This is great.
It is good for the sport.
I love the sport.
And um,
and I think everyone here,
we want it to do better.
It's just,
it's doesn't get nearly the amount of attention or respect that it deserves.
Yeah,
it's crazy.
It should definitely,
I mean,
kickboxing is,
is a very exciting sport when you,
and you sit down,
you watch these guys and you see some of the knockouts guys pull off.
I was watching,
I'm Tyrone Spong and,
and,
and Solow Calamari.
Right.
And,
and the way he cracked him with that overhead.
I love seeing guys get hurt but survive get through that round because you get a
guy like,
like title and spawn was a killer and he's coming after you.
He's trying to finish,
but you have to be smart brains.
When you dropped Tyrone in New York,
that was a Michael Dunn.
I think Tyrone got up and they knocked them out.
Yeah.
White guy over here.
That was crazy.
That was,
that was because that whole exchange was 30 seconds.
Yeah.
He dropped,
he dropped Tyron and t and then Tyrone got back up and knocked him out.
I just flashed him.
I'm like,
oh,
one,
two down the pipe and Tom Bonds in a weird place,
right?
Yeah.
I don't know.
I don't know what these kind of halfway kickboxing,
halfway boxing is boxing now.
He has a boxing fight recently.
Man.
He's had a few,
well,
when he broke his leg,
when he fought,
go Saki.
That was another one of those Anderson Silva style.
Leg breaks is nasty.
Uh,
check leg breaks.
It was bad.
You see that one?
Oh,
I saw that disgusting.
How many times have you seen that Joe in the flesh and the flesh?
Never.
I would never see it in the flesh.
I've seen it twice.
Corey Hill,
and answer for that too.
What I hate about that is your body's still reacting.
You throw in that kick and you're putting that foot down.
You don't feel it.
Now you put that foot down,
then you see it goes rubber on you.
Kelly's touching the side of your knee.
Oh,
that's gotta be so hard to get over that.
To the point where you're capable of throwing kicks to like to the mentally
convinced mental,
uh,
yeah,
it's real tough.
Real tough to come by from.
Yeah.
And well,
uh,
blegh break in and of itself is so dangerous because first of all when it gets,
when it's a compound fracture,
it's insanely
dangerous cause there's massive risks of infection.
But when it's a,
a,
a leg break,
there's also an issue with circulation.
Like Frank Mir,
when he broke his leg,
when he got in that car accident,
he wasn't good for a year,
a year plus his leg was fucked up for like a year later and his knee was fucked
up from,
you know,
having his leg bolted together and kind of fucked up as knee.
What bothers me most about that is how much pain those dudes are in instantly.
I mean,
when you're in a fight and you get cut,
you get hit,
you get like,
you feel it,
but it's like you can deal with it like that.
Yeah.
They just look like they're in agony right away.
That adrenaline is not enough to stop that pain.
No,
nobody just sucks it up when their legs snaps in half.
That Andersen,
when Andersen fog Weidman and he's just screaming,
you know,
you never see that from Anderson ever.
There was one,
I had a fight once.
And you,
you had said something about how I'm good at throwing that inside leg kick.
And I was like,
yeah,
when I watched it later I was like yeah,
cause I don't wanna get my shit broken.
I tried to hide that as best as I can be in a south bum.
Yeah.
Cause that's the scariest thing right inside leg kick to that Shin on the
opposite side fighter.
Yeah.
That the South Palsy ruin it when it happens.
I said Tyrone was just like full power and that sockies knee like oh yeah.
Full power.
And that's Tyrone style too.
He's just such a,
uh,
explosive guy.
Like what a boss said about it made a lot of sense to me where he described it
as like a,
like a ruler,
Pencil,
ruler.
And when you hit,
you know,
the South Pole,
you ended up kind of boss explains a lot better than maybe what the,
uh,
the ruler hits the flat side of the Shin Hits like the floods out.
Why has the ability to break so easy versus going straight out of that totally
makes sense.
And then there's of course the knee and the upper air,
the need,
which is just like kicking a boulder,
you know,
it's like the top of the knee especially.
It's so hard.
Yeah.
And the top of the Shin to,
you know,
when you,
uh,
your Shin is a sharp or toward the bottom,
but it gets much thicker,
much denser.
So,
uh,
he felt like a,
a solid leg kicking you land on the upper Shin is when you really get like the
funk.
I remember there was a fight and lion fight.
I don't remember who mallet pet fought,
but uh,
he was,
uh,
he,
the dude checked his leg kick and it hurt him.
He could tell it hurt him.
So Mal pet started swinging at his shins and he just kept throwing those leg
kicks.
Adis Shins.
It was just so nasty.
It was that that was,
I don't remember who it was.
I remember it and I don't think I saw that.
It was one of it.
Was that when Cyborg flood on that car?
Uh,
I dunno,
might've been,
it might've been,
might've been.
I train them out of the pet man,
that guy,
you know,
a ballot that means no diamond and that guy,
his shins are like diamond heart.
We were drilling one day and we're going back and forth and I throw a kick and
he checked me,
he throws a kick
and I check him.
He's not kicking me hard.
I mean he's literally kicking like that hard.
And I checked it and I didn't like how it felt.
So I saw him doing a kick again and I seriously thought,
don't even block that cause where he's not kicking you hard so it's not going to
hurt.
But if you check it at will,
right.
The bad guy.
He's,
he's little,
he's tiny,
but he hits so hard,
can't clench with him.
Beats me up in the clinch.
I got like 2030 pounds on him.
It's beaten me up so much experience.
And the,
you know,
they call it old bones.
Yeah.
They start when they're babies.
Old Bones.
That's an interesting way to put it in until the ties referred to them.
Well that's the same with grappling to,
you ever wrestle with a guy like Randy coture?
He clinch up with a guy like that and there's just something about them when
they've been throwing people around their whole life,
they got this weird feel to them.
It just doesn't feel right.
Yeah.
I trained with Tyron when he,
he had a broken arm at the time,
so he's in a cast.
He's not even using it.
I can't do anything.
He's lifted me with one hand.
He's putting me on the fancy word,
straight wrestling,
but it's like he's wrestling with the child and he had shot passed on and the
cast.
That's hilarious.
And he wrestled with another guy that wrestled that at Missouri also and took
him down.
And this is a college level wrestler?
Well Woodley's so unusual in that he has unbelievable knockout power,
but he didn't start out as a striker.
You know,
he's just snap an explosion that he's got his ability to like close the distance
with one punch too.
I really noticed it.
I've been,
I've noticed that in many fights,
but the one time when he fought Carlos condit,
I remember he closed the distance and land at the right hand.
You know how your brain sees people doing stuff and things seemed normal.
Like oh that's a good punch or that's a good kick,
but it seems normal.
But every now and then someone will do something and you go,
Whoa,
what the fuck?
They just,
we just miss a couple of frames there.
Like it was like something was cut out of the fray.
He's so fast.
Yeah.
And for a guy that's that big,
to be able to close the distance so fast and punch you,
he like,
you could tell like condit was like,
oh,
okay,
okay.
And this mother fucker could punch me from over there.
Like this is,
this is a whole different kind of thing.
I think that's how a lot of people feel when they're fighting
Wonderboy now.
Oh yeah.
It's,
you know,
you're talking earlier about his,
with a high level striker,
he is,
but he's a high level striker at a style that you don't see very often.
And you're going to MMA gym anywhere across the country.
You're going to see fundamentals of Muy Thai boxing and whatnot.
You know what I mean?
Be Barely,
rarely are going to see guys throwing late up Cresson kicks and all this fucking
karate point.
Karate Shit.
I am in a Raymond Daniels similar style.
When you're in there,
you're like,
what the fuck is going on?
And then he ended up standing in front of them,
which is what they want.
Well,
he's got way better hands and Raymond now,
right?
The thing that makes him like Raymond is getting better with his hands,
but Raymond has issues when guys close the distance and smother him,
like with Niki holds can did like with Joseph Valtellina did to him.
But wonder what,
I don't have any problem with that and wonder where his hands are nasty.
And he also has this weird thing he does where he pivots from his hip back and
forth like a fucking snake and like he's so good at like moving back and forth
from his hips.
And that's like a lot of that point karate stuff.
Yeah.
I don't,
I'm excited about that flavor because of those two dynamics.
Because the tire and speed and one,
one boy's got good range too,
but tiring can close that gap.
And then one of the boys creativity with,
with,
with what he does,
like he throws everything at you.
Tyrons got that one punch power though.
That one punch thing is just so disturbing because he could just,
the last fight with Lawler was out of nowhere.
Nowhere.
And he can do that at any point in time to anybody.
Yeah.
To anybody.
And there's no one that can take that shot.
You just,
you,
you can't get hit by it.
You can't get hit like that.
Whereas Wonderboy is much more of an accumulation type,
uh,
damaged door.
But you know,
wonder boy,
he's been hit before.
You know,
like you gotta think Jake Ellenberger hit him and hurt him and uh,
you know,
Jake's got real power to,
of course he hit him and hurt him.
So it's,
it's really a matter of whether or not he can stay the fuck away for,
um,
as long as it takes a slow tyrant down.
Yeah.
And then get his hit the weird game that he has,
particularly with his front leg,
he can do shit with his front leg that you just do not expect.
Front leg sidekicks,
front leg,
roundhouse kicks.
He's sneak some over the shoulder and drops him down on you throwing that lead
leg hook kick.
Yeah.
That's that shit.
I mean,
like when you're like,
what the fuck is going on?
Worry.
Uh,
Johnny Hendricks.
He's like,
yeah,
no.
Like what?
You know?
And then now you're a target for that guy who was just doing his shit,
you know?
Yeah.
Scary.
Well,
that sideways stance too,
he stands like completely karate style sideways with his hands down and it's
just a different thing.
It's a totally different style of movement.
And that was the one style of martial art that I was,
I've been waiting for for a while.
And you've seen it now with um,
uh,
Michael Page and Bella Tor to this style of the point karate guy.
Those support guys who can,
they can close the distance so fast and get the fuck out of the way so fast.
They're just a completely different thing and they're real good at countering to
like Michael Page is a master at countering.
Yeah.
I'm,
I'm not hating on Michael painted and hate that gangly pseudo style.
Oh Dude.
The dancing stuff.
I don't know why.
Why do you hate it poly?
Because I feel like I'm a classic like old school heart.
Just put your notes to the grant and do it the right way.
Right.
But I understand that's his style,
but for some reason it just bothers the hell out of it.
Well,
don't you think that's also a big part of why it's so effective?
Because it bothers the fuck out of his opponents too.
It's like you do not want to get knocked out by a dude's gonna dance afterwards.
Dance during dance.
Right before he kaos you,
you know,
Fuck Battersea Richard Abraham's up
next.
Mike Methey Eda.
We haven't talked about a fight yet.
I like Abraham man.
Yeah,
I like how he fights.
He's pretty aggressive.
He,
he likes to throw big bombs.
I call,
I call what he does.
[inaudible] Muy Thai hood.
Moitai that's funny though.
Jitsu.
How did you come up with Thug Jitsu man?
There was,
there was Houston was a big,
a Jujitsu town and some,
somebody was using it as like trying to denigrate me.
You know,
they were like,
if you want to,
you want to train some good Jujitsu,
you come over here and you train with this guy and this guy.
But if you want to go learn some of that thug Jitsu,
you go train with eve and Saul and those guys because,
because we were doing kicks and punches knees and then they didn't like that.
They just wanted to do some missions and do positioning and,
and that was it.
Nobody wanted to get hit in Houston back in the nineties Oh that's interesting.
Joke's on you fucking ran with that shit.
I saw you fight for first time it hook and shoot dude against Aaron Riley.
What year was that?
That was the 90s right?
No,
first time was the nineties I think the second time was 2001 no,
2000 old school man.
That,
that is as old school as you get right.
Makes me feel old.
Those were great fights though,
man.
Those are great fights.
I don't,
it's weird cause I liked beaten up.
Aaron Riley.
Aaron was tough.
You know what I mean?
He was tough but he wouldn't stop.
Like he wouldn't quit.
But um,
the,
the second time we fought,
it was one point where I,
Atlanta did a knee like to the face and then just saw blood immediately after.
I surely felt like,
felt like I need a burlap sack of light bulbs.
That's what it felt like.
It was disgust.
Oh Man.
A burlap sack.
I remember thinking during the fight when that happened.
I was like,
that felt like light bulbs.
Oh my God.
What do you think it felt like when Michael Page landed that neon cyborg when
its forehead Kayden Cyborg so crazy.
He's like,
I'll be fighting to get in three months.
Like what?
I hope not.
The way he went down to that was another one of those times when you see a guy
in agony in the cage,
that's no man.
I don't know if I'm fighting after that.
You can get hit in the head a lot.
That's bugs the shit out of me the most about I pokes when when someone gets
jabbed in the eye and you see him scream out and cover their eyes and turn their
back then and we tried to defend themselves sometimes.
Anthony Johnson one was the worst.
Oh yeah,
with Kevin Burns.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I've seen a gang of them now,
man.
I just don't know why they don't go to the pride gloves.
I mean it just seemed at this point in time,
like a no brainer.
It just doesn't make any sense to me whatsoever.
They continue to have these gloves that not only is it hard to keep your hand
curled,
but it like it.
It's trying to open your hands,
like the UFC gloves are trying to open your hands,
like to keep your hands close,
you have to force them down.
Whereas the pride gloves,
it was hard to open them a prod gloves or keeping your hands like that.
So as you're throwing punches,
you know,
I just think also two guys had the half to get away from doing this open palm
thing to the face to push guys off.
And I think when guys do that,
they should be penalized at point.
You know,
how do you stop them from doing that?
That's such an instinct.
It is an instinct,
but I think some guys don't do whatever.
You know?
There's a lot of fighters who never,
never guilty of I pokes.
So why is that?
I mean it's not like it's impossible to avoid.
I think they just have to make it so that if you poke somebody in the eye,
it's an instantaneous one point deduction.
And people say,
well that's too harsh.
You know,
they didn't mean to do it.
Maybe they didn't mean to do it,
but it still was done.
So the opponents still suffered damage,
you know when you poke somebody in the eye,
how many times do you see like a Matt Mitre on Travis Brown fight where a guy
gets poked in the eye and also in the whole fight changes and then one guy's in
trouble and he's not in trouble from a legal technique.
He's in trouble from getting poked and then the dynamic of the fight changes.
He can't see so good.
And then he winds up getting fucked up.
See they should just stop,
walk to the guy over a good look and then
come back at five minutes.
So we'll see that.
That would be crazy.
Manage of guys were allowed to poke you.
I'll give you poke someone in the eye.
They're allowed to come over and they get a free poke.
Love it.
Oh wasn't that,
wasn't that one of the first rules that was like,
it was just like,
no,
no.
It was just no,
no fish hooking or something.
No fish hooking.
No idea.
No,
I college and you were allowed to grab hair.
You were allowed to punch nuts.
Keith Hackney.
But some guys just have done it so many times on Joe San.
Yeah man.
How crazy.
That Joe's Han story.
That's one of the craziest stories.
And all of them,
I may,
Joe San,
who seemed like this lovable guy who was really into Jesus,
it seemed kind of crazy.
He used to come to the comedy store and hang out,
hung out with Joe Shaw sign a bunch of times because he was friends with Bobby
Lee.
So He'd come down to the commerce talk.
He was jacked.
It was three feet tall and two feet wide.
He was jacked,
you know,
and he would,
uh,
he was just real weird.
It felt like almost dangerous around.
I'm like,
it's Kinda,
it's just seems so odd.
And then they do some,
he got arrested for something and they do some random DNA test on them and find
out he was a part of a gang rape.
And now he's in jail for life.
He's in jail and while he's in jail,
he killed his celly.
Yeah,
I didn't know that.
Killed a cellmate.
I'm pretty sure.
See if that's the case.
Joe Sohn Kills Cell Mate.
I'm pretty sure he did.
But yeah,
he's in jail for life now.
That's a wrap.
But it just,
what the fuck man.
Out of nowhere,
I forget what they arrested him for two,
but it was,
it was,
it wasn't anything like that.
Joe's yeah.
Possible murderer.
Uh,
he's a crazy dude,
man.
For sure.
Rapist.
A possible murder for sure.
I remember when he walked into the cage with a fucking cross strapped to his
back,
him and chemo,
both those guys,
it was so up with Jesus.
They had a walk to the cage with a cross strapped to their back.
Even Jesus himself and be like,
guys,
that was a long time ago.
We don't need to do this anymore.
Cause his cellmate was a convicted child molester.
So and did he kill him?
Yeah,
he was standing over the body off him.
So he was found standing at the door with cell,
the body of his cellmate,
50 year old convicted child molester.
Michael Graham was lying unresponsive in the bottom bunk.
He's pronounced dead.
Hmm.
Well I gave him a pass on that.
Give them a pass on child molester.
He said he killed grant with a combination of kicks and punches.
Sohn.
Pleaded not guilty.
Yeah.
Oh Wow.
When you said son,
I thought though.
Cause you say that a lot.
Oh son with a combination.
Uh,
all right,
here we go.
Be a pretty good one.
I thought that was from wearing the why Colin his head one time I saw him fight,
but I guess that's a real mark on his head.
Oh,
okay.
You guys,
have you ever fought in Denver II?
Yeah.
High altitude.
Nate and I fought and I fought Nate.
Nate was 163 pounds.
I was like one 62.
Nate used to be 163 that's crazy.
It's like 19 though.
Wow.
He's back to one 85 now,
right?
Yeah.
He just,
he just,
he just won by knockout.
Yeah.
Amazing.
You'd be knocked out tandem or core with a head kick.
That dude has been around a long fucking time.
Nate and I flatten 99.
Wow.
That's amazing.
Named Mark Hart,
you know,
um,
Brendan Schaub said he's never seen Nate lose a single round in the gym.
And he,
one of the things he said about Nate is that Nate is probably one of those guys
that left too much in a jam.
Just had way too many Jim Morris with Shane car when he used to spar with Shane
fucking Carwyn,
which is like what?
I didn't realize how big he was.
I saw the Ellis mania thing.
Oh we can't holy shit.
Well he like this like requiring dirt like well you have one arm tied to his
body,
which is even more insane.
They will start taping arm to his body and yes,
two people,
they had to make gloves wore in the UFC.
He's he,
him and Brock.
Yeah.
His,
his hands are bigger than Brock's.
That's ridiculous.
Yeah.
I remember I was at um,
um,
where the fuck was I?
Oh,
I was,
I was at a mall Easton's Jujitsu,
a school in Boulder and I was on the mat when we were trained and we're doing
drills and now the corner of my eye,
see what looks like the thing from the comic book movie.
Fantastic four.
It looks like the thing,
like if the thing was a real person walking in and I look up,
what the fuck is that?
And it's Carwyn in between fights,
you know,
he would get to like 300 plus pounds and uh,
cause he was,
he was a giant.
I mean,
he was giant and I saw him walking.
I just remember going,
what in the fuck?
Like what are you,
what do what I can see.
I can't imagine what Nate does with that guy.
I just realized what the thing,
the thing that was made of rocks.
Yeah.
I mean that was the size of him.
He was so fucking big that carbon has that,
that weird power to where he can knock dudes out with like six inch punches.
Like he knocked out Gonzaga Gonzaga had him hurt.
And then he,
uh,
as he's wobbling backwards,
he uncorked a six inch punch that puts Gonzaga in the dark lands,
stuff like that.
It's still weird because think about the fight with him and,
and,
and Brock and Canada in Vancouver,
and he beat the snot out of Broccoli first round.
He just didn't conserve himself enough.
Any gas,
right.
Yeah,
I remember it.
Gas Hard,
trying to put them away first round and Brock isn't a guy that they can take a
lot of like a punishment like that.
You don't think he brought that guy but he survived it and turned it back on?
Well somehow or another,
somehow or another he survived it,
but I feel like to this day that have car would've just stayed calm and just
kept that fight.
Standing and striking.
Brock was fucked because he was a commensurate wrestler.
I mean,
I mean he might not have been as good a wrestler in wrestling as Brock is,
but in MMA he's right the fuck up.
They're like,
good luck taking them down,
especially when you've got to get close enough for him to tag you.
I feel like to this day that if he just stayed calm and just box the fuck out of
Brock,
he'd be in the UFC heavyweight champion for sure.
But he just tried to just end it real quick.
Which makes sense because when you see,
when you see Brock run away from some of the shots that he ran away from before
that and chain hits like he hits.
Yeah,
exactly.
And just close the show and then he's big.
Right?
I mean like he's way bigger than Mark Hun.
Yeah,
he's Mark [inaudible].
It was kind of the same scenario,
but he didn't have the wrestling.
Yeah.
Mark Hunt's was nowhere near or near the South Bronx.
So fucking big.
He's big in a way that even the chain is big in a different way.
It just,
his bizarre,
Brock's even wider than Shane.
Yeah,
they built,
I mean,
when you,
when you cut to me to 65 changes.
Yeah,
man,
what is that?
Yeah.
I mean they're,
they're still trying to figure out what Brock was,
you know,
like they're,
they're trying to mount some sort of a defense there.
They're coming up with like skin cream now they're saying if skin cream made him
piss hot
guys are so hilarious.
Clomid and fucking skin cream.
I don't know what happened.
Well.
What's funny is there actually was some sort of a hormone peptide in um,
the uh,
the skin cream for psoriasis that Chad Mendez use.
Chad Mendez has some pretty serious psoriasis and there's all these photos of
him.
You could see him ma online whereas weren't shorts and shit and it's just all
over his legs.
It's real bad and you have to take,
a lot of times you're taking what is essentially a steroid cream to try to heal
the,
the area.
And that is what made him test positive when they found the cream,
they tested the cream and him and Yup,
sure enough.
But it's,
so it's a medication so he has a legitimate,
I mean he has a real element you see as the services pension.
You got this as basic.
Yeah,
I believe so.
Well you saw it as no fucking joke man,
which is really funny watching all these guys go over to Bell Tor.
I think it's going to be a,
it's going to be interesting.
It's going to be interesting to see what Bellah toward does.
We're like van underlay and all these other guys that are going over there and
tails for scale.
Yeah,
yeah,
of course.
We'll chill.
Um,
they said that Charles said that they're tested them like crazy.
Right.
But I mean,
they might be my fucking son of a text message.
Hey Yo,
we're testing you like crazy and three days,
wink,
wink.
[inaudible]
Commission.
Right.
It's not even,
it's not a new soda.
No,
no one's doing it the way the UFC is doing it and the way UFC is doing it.
I mean,
in a lot of ways it's,
it's dangerous to their brand,
you know?
I mean,
a lot of ways it's,
a lot of people would say it's not a good idea financially,
but it just shows their commitment to trying to clean it up.
California is doing randoms to now,
just as the Athletic Commission,
the Commissioner came here from Georgia and he's,
he's wrecking down.
Yeah.
That's awesome.
The problem with the,
you saw the thing is that it's,
if your boss,
the people that pay,
you saw that the test is the UFC.
That's,
I think that's a conflict of interest.
At some level it should be,
you know,
a state sanctioned or somebody away from both parties,
because who,
who,
who makes the choice on who gets tested?
Because signing when you told drug tests and the California for example,
the California Athletic Commission is going to contact Bella tour and say you're
fighting.
This guy is not fighting.
He failed a drug test.
When you fell a test of the [inaudible],
they're going to call the UFC McKay.
So,
uh,
this guy failed the drug test.
What do you want to do about it?
And that's not,
that becomes a problem.
Yeah.
This guy is called cocaine in his system and then he fights for,
we'll just lose those results till after this main event.
Yeah.
But that's different because it's at a competition.
There's a certain rules.
Oh,
what happened to him?
There's certain nuts.
I thought he's knee buckled.
I thought he got hit with a push kick to the leg.
But I think there's,
um,
there's out of competition testing and then there's in competition testing and
when you get tested for something in competition,
it's very different than at a competition when it comes to recreational drugs.
But when it comes to performance enhancing drugs,
like even if it's at a competition,
like save your five weeks out,
he tests positive for cocaine.
That's not going to affect your performance in the ring in a,
in a way that's going to damage your opponent.
But if you test positive for some sort of steroid,
then it will make sense.
It kind of makes sense.
It makes sense.
Until you talked to Nick Diaz,
well that was the most ridiculous shit that you saw.
No,
that was in Nevada state athletic commission.
Right.
Not only that you sought and no Wicki were Novitsky is 100% against it.
He,
he thinks it was ridiculous.
Well,
that same fight and make filled for that of commission.
It's been an AP for five years.
Anderson failed a drug test for steroids and they had lost his results until
after the fight.
Look at this knee buckle.
Watch this shit.
Lugging them off.
Did you see this?
Did you see that?
I was knee just buckled it.
That was awful.
Yeah,
it was horrible.
I mean Anderson was doing,
well,
I don't know if he was doing,
but he had steroids in a system.
Right?
For whatever reason he said it's from Chinese Cialis.
It was just hilarious.
He's fucking,
I would like to see if someone pub,
someone's should publish a list of all the excuses fighters have made for
pissing the high.
Are they good?
Make a t shirt.
Yeah.
Right.
Like a tour,
like a world tour tee shirt of the back.
All the different excuses.
Sylvia failed for like winstrol or something and he said he was doing it just to
get to,
so we have this body would look better because he was getting so much shit about
looking fat.
Yeah.
Well the Tim Silvia that knocked out Rico Rodriguez was a monster.
You going back to that Tim Silvia,
that Tim Silvia was one of the scariest heavyweights ever.
I,
that was when he got pumped.
I think that was when he goes,
yeah,
I remember that fight because I remember he had a hard time making two 65.
He had a cut weight to make to 65 and he wasn't,
he wasn't fat at all back then.
I mean,
he was,
he wasn't shredded.
But for Tim Silvia,
I mean,
he was real lean watching Tim Silvia walk around.
He doesn't look like,
like an athlete isn't it looked like he,
she,
he would have ever been in a heavyweight champion of the UFC.
But man,
he had hot,
oh fuck.
Yeah.
Well Dude,
I talked to Kelly start about that.
Who's,
you know,
a,
um,
a real famous strength and conditioning coach and knows a lot about physiology
and he,
and he thinks that,
oh shit,
he thinks that,
um,
Tim Silvia,
that pigeon toed thing that he did,
he thinks that's correctable.
He's like,
you just got to retrain your body how to walk and stand.
And for some reason he never did that.
But start really believes that like the mechanics of your body,
like you've kind of been cut into a groove where your body's gotten accustom to
walking and standing in that way.
But if you adjusted that and train that,
he would be a way better athlete and it would move like,
you know,
like a Travis brown or something like that was a big tall guy who moves.
Great.
Yeah.
But I mean,
as a grown man,
you think he can do retrain.
I understand you can do,
but if he wanted to take takes a lot.
Yeah.
I mean,
I,
I listened to Kelly,
I think Kelly knows what the fuck he's talking about.
Yeah.
I don't know if he's right,
but I mean,
I would imagine there's something short of them having some scar
tissue or whatever that forces him to walk that way and then you could change
it.
But I don't think it's likely to grown.
Man has already been successful.
It's gonna be like,
you know,
I wish I could walk a little less,
less goofy.
Let me fix this year.
Yeah.
I mean,
I don't know what makes you walk.
Pigeon toed.
Jamie,
pull that up.
Tim Silvia goes and fixes walk in next year.
We see him in the NFL.
Yeah.
Well I don't know about all that.
The last thing,
I think that dude needs to get him to that anymore.
Yeah.
That ray Mercer fight.
Uh,
that was,
that was the end of the wall.
That,
that was a nice
kick in there.
It didn't matter.
Oh,
we should probably say we're watching round three.
It's 27262520420 two seconds to go in.
Does it?
Explaining what causes it.
What causes pigeon toe pigeon toes caused by one of three conditions.
Metasys,
serous Matar Sus Metta,
Metta Tarsus,
metatarsus Adductus,
tibial torsion or femoral anteversion.
Each condition is specific to its location.
Here's a brief description of each.
The foot pigeon toes occur when the foot tends to resemble a kidney awe.
Or when a metatarsus adductus has an inward curve at the outer edge of the foot.
If your child has this condition,
you'll probably notice it while your child is still a baby.
Sometimes the doctor will try braces or special shoes while the child is still a
baby.
Six to nine months old.
Help you manipulate the bones into growing straight.
The condition will not clear up on its own.
Metatarsus adductus requires treatment.
The nature of which varies depending upon whether the condition is flexible or
fixed.
Most flexible cases respond to conservative treatment,
which indicates passive stretching,
bracing and specialized shoes.
The fixed type requires serial plaster casting.
If conservative treatment does not help,
then reevaluation as in order to make sure the patient does not have true club
foot instead of metatarsus.
Adductus.
Huh?
Interesting.
I just,
right now I'm just,
I like looking behind the veil,
man.
There are times when when I'm listening to you about gas and,
and you're,
you're,
you go into one of those and I'm like,
is he like,
what is he doing?
Where's that coming from?
Oh,
now I know.
Now I know.
See how it works.
It's called the Internet.
It's like magic.
Yeah,
but Google is,
you're asking someone else can do it.
I'm like,
how are you asking someone else to do it?
And then you're reading it.
Oh there you go.
Get it.
I'm not going to give away the secret.
I just get it.
Poffle Duane Ludwig with Whitney Mann.
Whitney Miller.
Know that I love Duane man.
He's a good dude.
He's a wizard.
That guy is a striking wizard.
He broke my orbital daddy.
Yeah,
that's not very nice.
So what did he hit you with?
A fun.
I was in his guard.
I'm on top,
I mean as a guard and he throws a punch.
He throws it this way.
So he turns his knuckles over and like casting style and all the knuckle hit me
right in the eyeball.
I'm on top of him and I'm
like throwing shots and then he throws that punch and he hits me and I put my
head down on his belly and hold on his biceps.
I'm like,
fuck that hurt.
That really hurt.
Like that was one of those moments in a fight.
Whereas like that hurt and I couldn't see straight for the rest of that was the
first round from the bottom here on the bottom.
He was losing his guard.
Close guard.
He threw it.
That punch hit me right now.
Eyeball since that
doctor said,
um,
two things happen.
Either the eyeball ruptures or you're fracturing to relieve the pressure.
So I got lucky,
my brother in law,
Aaron who was uh,
these like mid thirties,
he uh,
as a,
uh,
it'd be late thirties.
Oh that's fucked.
You see that?
I fucking hate nasty.
Why would you even do that?
I hate that.
Anyway,
he's a pitcher like a pickup league,
like a just for fun leagues,
uh,
playing baseball for a long time and he throws a pitch and then it gets hit line
line drive right back at him on a fucking Sunday afternoon.
Hit Him Square in the eye.
Like ruptures is,
I lost his eyes,
had like 10 surgeries,
losses eyeball his eyeball now they're like talking to me.
We might be able to keep the eye with like filling in cause it opened in the
back like a flap and like all the shit leaked out and then they had to fill it
with this oil and they're trying to hope that they can at least save the eye.
But the Vision's gone.
Ah,
awful.
Jesus Christ and like for like basketball for fun,
like a fun game.
I'm a fucking,
Sunday is terrible.
Terrible.
Yeah man.
Fuck that.
Fuck that kick to you.
Don't like that kick to kick to the thigh.
It's cool.
But when you're trying to extend the guy's knee like that,
I think it's shit illegal in glory and well,
I mean it really depends on where he's hitting him.
It's,
it's such a weird thing because if your leg is,
if you know your leg is slightly bent and the guy catches you above the thigh
with that push kick,
it's going to extend your leg and it's going to hurt.
There's not,
I mean the way he did it,
that was really nasty.
I mean that was one of the worst ones I've seen.
Did you ever see that one with Miguel Torres who I sit and when I,
for the first time I was on your podcast,
it was awful.
But that every time I see it as bugs me,
I had a knee surgery and we were talking earlier about how long it takes you to
come back mentally forever.
And I was out for a year from an ACL and MCL tear.
But like in that last three months,
especially that last camp,
getting back into the ring,
like every time you feel like any kind of twist or pop or any scar tissue that
breaks,
like you just freak out and you make like a girly noise.
Like ever.
I was a fucking spider.
Ran Across the room and uh,
yeah,
it was really hard.
So every time I see any kind of shit like that on the knee,
it bugs me.
Yeah.
That's why people are so terrified of heel hooks,
you know,
he'll hook,
scare people more than anything because with,
with the difference between tapping and not tapping quick enough is you being
crippled for a year
and yeah,
super effective.
But that's why a guy like who smaller Paul Horace is so hated,
like he's the one,
one of the most hated guys and the history of the sport because he holds on the
heel hooks.
Those are,
those are the two.
Those are the two guys that I hate.
This shit.
The flashy dancers and the heel hooker.
This shit is going to be crazy.
He Kovar Hoeven and bought her heart.
You seem bottled lately.
Oh my God.
It looks like he's on all the steroids for sure.
All the start for sure.
For sure.
He's so much
more.
I want to watch.
Oh,
it's going to look it up.
Look at him in that picture.
Oh Man.
Look at that fucking picture from his Instagram.
Holy Shit.
He looks like he gained 1520 pounds of muscle.
I mean you look at like his last fight.
He did not look like that at all.
Well,
what I love about this fight to,
it's first of all,
Rico's in his fucking prime but bought,
has been training for this fight for six months.
Like he's been putting it up on his Instagram and he hasn't fought in forever.
Look at this.
When he was fighting with Shin Protection and head gear,
I was already a household name,
so it doesn't matter.
Rico,
you cannot deny Rico Verhoeven is a bad motherfucker.
I mean,
he is so high level right now and his endurance and pace and athleticism for a
heavyweight is really rare.
He's something special.
He's super athletic and he said Jari at dude and like he's a fucking giant dude,
so's Bhattar and bothers us.
Have Ej like just a straight getting like super excited.
Really.
Shit.
I'm fucking,
yeah,
we got to do one for that.
Right?
Let's do one more juiced up.
He gets the more,
I'm like,
fuck yeah,
I can't wait
because I thought I was a little worried that you know,
Rico is in his prime and butter hasn't fought in a while and his last fight
didn't look that great.
Oh God damn it all big.
I'm like,
fuck.
That's the same night as the UFC in Toronto.
Cancel it.
I should.
I'm thinking of it now.
I thought,
Joe,
we talked about this.
You're only going to do,
you have seized when it's in Vegas and close to home for you.
Right.
You're not going to go out of the North America,
Canada,
Canada's North America.
There are there a sort of America go commit a misdemeanor and you won't be able
to go.
It won't be here for one of our friends.
There are people.
Hmm.
There's going to be really good about this.
Really thinking about cans,
the UFC to watch that fight.
How fucked up.
I don't feel like calling the UFC.
Hey Brian.
Stan,
what's up dude?
What'd you do in December 10th do it,
man.
I was December 10th yeah,
my flight's at Simberi.
10th Oh,
well.
What am I going buy or you want to know?
Beltour I'm canceling the fight.
Fuck it.
Yeah.
That's crazy.
That Bella tours doing that on the same night as Gloria.
It's a UFC
fight in Italy for ability or they're doing like,
uh,
I think it's,
it's,
it's three events or two events.
Is it going to be belted toward kickboxing or is it Bella?
Tour and billets were kickbox so they'd combine it.
So like one kickboxing fied one like shockwave did or,
yeah,
I believe so.
You got to find a time where you going to fight for the U s time?
I think they're actually going to,
I think they play it a week later.
TV time or for the last time.
Well,
so you'll be able to watch it.
Yeah,
because you'll fight.
It will be morning here early in the morning when you're fighting.
Probably
it's my buddy Casey green and he's up and my sparring part in the last like
three or four fights is really a good dude out of it.
He taller than you,
this guy?
Yeah.
No,
I think I have about an inch on him.
He's gotten a lot better over the last 10 years and he works so hard.
Work so hard.
He's like real consistent.
My really excited that this Kevin Tough fighter on his hands lists Thai guy.
He's fighting.
He's got like 170 fights.
God,
that's so crazy cases out of Saxons in Van Nuys.
Right?
Bama said he been,
I'm coming up to train with you.
Yeah.
Obama's been fucking buy.
You should come through.
We've been,
uh,
my,
my coach has been torturing us,
but we're getting some really good working.
Well,
I'm just a real cool cut.
Yeah.
I like who's Bomba Mamba.
He was on,
he was a kid on,
on,
on sales team.
On the ultimate fighter Brazil.
Oh,
okay.
I guess we were like lived with chill or lived up to the up there.
We're chill.
Was good for a banking partner for a long time.
Now he's hearing Chell such character like oh world world champions you Jitsu
guy.
And he was like,
Oh,
I'm gonna work on my kickboxing.
I'm like,
cool.
And we started shooting drills.
I'm like,
this is mother fuckers could the fuck this tie kid is 20 years old and he has a
hundred and what fights 170 160 is fucking incredible.
Right.
That's insane.
The first tie tape,
I have a watch from a friend from Thailand.
They had like two 17 year olds.
They had like a hundred and something fights.
Well in Thailand you're prime is like 16,
17,
18.
You know,
if you're,
if you're 23 years old,
you're like over the hill,
like you're fucking getting older.
What about a guy like Sam Chai was 36 even Sanchez like I don't think he's like
maybe Sanchez still is,
but for the most part those guys that like sand shy or blue collar,
whatever,
those guys aren't even like the prime in Thailand anymore.
They're gotten so old and so big and now they fight the forerunners everywhere.
That's what you were saying like top level and Thailand has like 113 pounds.
16 powered
one 34 wins.
32 losses,
zero draws with 45 K I was dye is incredible at 20 years old.
I have a lot of fights that he has as many Kaos is,
I have fighter right?
That phrase saying that's an end.
He's 20 that's crazy.
That means he was born in 1996 that's insane.
So when he was born,
I don't know,
but I'm assuming it was when he was like probably like eight years old or five
years old.
His parents like put,
took come to a Muy Thai camp and that camp probably took,
raised him and sent him to school or whatnot.
And then every day after school,
since he was like five years old,
he fucking train moy cage.
Casey's regular weekends,
five wins,
six
losses,
two knockouts.
Crazy.
Boy,
that's a big step up for him.
Yeah.
He's got a lot of,
he got the size advantage for sure.
And this one.
And then he also,
um,
usually those ties when they come over and they do,
or when they switch over to kickboxing there first time they don't do that well
because it's so different.
This live rule set and stuff.
How good are the tie fighters when they started getting bigger and heavier
weight?
This is one 70.
Right.
That's big for a title.
Yeah.
And he's not,
he's probably,
you know,
eight.
He didn't cut an ounce,
you know,
you'd probably over eight and waiting with his keys on it,
make 70,
which is like a normal thing,
you know?
Yeah.
He weighed one 69.
But yeah,
they're just not that big of people.
It's like even book out is just not too many guys that book house size.
We see guys that were like used to be 150 pounds and then they just got super
fat and other fight and the one 85 but they have a hundred fights.
Even Super Fat,
that dangerous,
you know.
How do you say his name?
Sit songs.
Sit Song.
Here's the song Penong that's a really famous camp and Thailand,
so the and Thailand.
The fighters,
their last names are the,
usually the gym named that they represent like the Brazilians,
except except the Brazilians are kind of just pick their name like Lisa and
[inaudible]. [inaudible]
Cleveland t bell's.
Not as your real name.
Nah,
Tiago Elvis.
What's Gleason?
Does guavas last name?
No,
not really.
We only get t by his real name.
Oh,
Chaco Alvarez.
I sign his real name.
What is this?
What are you talking about?
Are you serious?
He's dropping it.
This is the exclusive right here.
Tiago is listening right now going,
shut the fuck up.
Shut the fuck up man.
I'm fighting next month
when they,
when they come in,
they change their visa,
their name,
their,
their visa or whatever into the u s they make,
they choose their own names.
I don't know if that's legal even because look,
next time you travel,
look at the list.
If you look at the list,
you could see the guy's real name.
Um,
for travel man sits on peanuts is a bad mother fucker.
He's got a quick trigger on that,
right kick man.
He,
when he slams it into the forearm,
you could see Casey just reacting to it.
Good.
Overhand right too.
You see Tiago down to 155 pounds now.
Yeah.
Whatever's real name is,
oh,
what's his name?
He's dad at one 55 man.
He looks great.
He looks good.
Such a much better wait for him.
I bet he's going to be a killer at one 55 I'm looking forward to this fight will
hit his real name.
His real name.
Wow.
His middle name is Herculano.
That's a dope name.
Oh,
that's glazed and t bow.
Yeah,
no,
that is the name.
Is that Gleason t bow.
His real
name is Johnny Gleason.
That's his name.
Johnny.
Johnny Gleason.
Herculano Elvis.
So he went with Gleason t bow.
Why didn't even go with Alvarez,
please?
Synopsis
here.
Rossi.
Yeah.
Fucking leg cake's done.
Given the heat and eat that right hand.
He's back though.
Um,
come on.
Casing Schilling.
Who's the,
who's the Best Moitai commentary?
Is it Vinny?
Shoreman I think I didn't really enjoy Vinny.
I think Vinnie's really good.
He knows his shit,
that's for sure.
Absolutely.
Um,
it's hard finding really good guides.
I mean,
uh,
obviously Valtellina he's super knowledgeable.
Oh,
he got tagged.
Oh Shit.
Uh,
oh.
At the bell.
Yeah.
They call that an oh,
he's hurt man.
He's,
or now he's hurt.
They call it a slip.
Yeah.
They call it a thrill.
That is not slip.
He was cracked.
The referee is Pro-america
Mark Marin make America great again.
Make America great with his right hand.
He got,
come on son.
He's hurt there.
Well,
we can't go out and knock down though.
You can't really call him.
Knocked down through another shot after it.
Right?
Yeah.
I mean,
there was a lot of slipping.
Yeah,
he did fall down from a slip.
Good job.
Breath.
I America go America.
Go Mark.
All good.
Good.
Got Good to get it.
Give it to him.
Mark.
Casey,
is it hard?
Okay,
so in a Moyie Thai fight,
kickboxing fight,
like in glory,
when you watch him remain,
you guys getting beaten on his feet and your teammates getting beaten on his
feet,
you're like,
you have to take down you.
You figure like there's another way.
When you guys getting beat up on their feet and Muay Thai,
what do you,
what are you thinking?
Yeah,
cause there's no other way.
Yeah.
This is,
we've got a big shot.
We've got to change something here.
Oh,
I like to see Casey start musing.
This movement stopped being,
don't be so predictable for that.
Stand in front of you.
Thai style.
Yeah.
Well there's also sees chart needs to be like more American right now.
Not trying to fight him and wait Thai style.
I guess this guy because it's just too much experience.
Do you think that guys automatically s try to fight the style of the ties?
Because,
I mean,
that's what they idolize,
right?
I mean like everybody who's a Moy Thai fighter,
they,
they idolize the greats.
You know,
they idolize these high level guys and then they wind up fighting on Monday.
Yeah.
I don't think it's intentional per se,
but I think you ended up doing that.
Or um,
we should just watch a bunch of Ramon Dekkers fights.
Yup.
What's going on sir?
Cut.
No,
Casey was complaining about it,
about clenching and kneeing the time and the referee stopped it,
but he didn't
stop.
The Thai guy didn't stop.
Okay.
He doesn't know what the fuck is.
No,
he's here in bar.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I winning.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
Let me keep fight.
I think it's a boy.
You were asking do I think it's kind of like the Wonderboy thing too.
Like when you,
when you're in that moment,
you don't realize that you're,
you're kind of playing the other guy's game sometime.
Chin.
Yeah.
Okay.
There's a thing that you see with guys like sit song peanuts.
When you see guys that have been doing it,
their whole live with it,
their,
their triggers so fast.
Like the way he throws that,
that kick that let's switch kick through just through and the way he throws.
It's like they have,
they have such fluidity because their technique is so a part of like who they
are and how they develop as a human like yeah,
just throw that right kick to the arms.
It's like,
it becomes like a part of how they move.
I mean he's probably been moving,
throwing kicks and punches and avoiding them and and clenching.
He just did it again.
He just clinched him and hit him in the knee there.
I mean he's been doing that since he was a baby.
Yeah.
It's just the,
that I that fight,
it's just so much to fight Iq and also the efficiency of the movement.
You Watch Casey and I seen some of his other fights and he fights,
usually fights at a much longer range.
He's like really close to this dude.
He's so punished already.
You know?
That's part of the problem with deep into the second round,
he's just been beaten up so much.
And the last thing you want to do with the tie with that much experience as the
clenches and Gloria Roosevelt's was a clinch anyway,
but like that's what you ends up happening.
You know,
for some reason you keep doing the same thing.
But yeah.
Casey usually has a really a lot better movement and I'm moving side to side,
but I think he's getting flustered here or maybe he's looking for the big shot.
It's not coming.
Get aggressive with,
did he hurt his knee?
Fuck was that,
did he hurt his knee there?
I'm sure Simon Mind,
like his leg just gave out.
He's still wobbly.
What does that from,
was that from a punch and then see it?
Oh,
he's fucked.
He's still fuck Bullock he's trying to move.
Yeah.
Uh,
fuck.
I should have stopped it.
Oh,
he just got stunned.
he's hurt.
He's hurt.
I said,
it seems like he's not just fun.
Yeah,
come on.
He's got something wrong while drive.
Come on.
Right.
Ooh,
his leg went backwards.
The long ref.
Yeah,
the reference top it.
No.
Oh Man.
Yeah,
he's his leg.
Oh.
He's too tough for his own good.
He's got 10 seconds left around.
The referee stopped the fight.
Oh Shit.
Right before he got k owed.
Ooh.
Yeah.
When a guy,
is that hindered by something you've got to kind of stop the fight.
What happened with his leg?
I'm sure they're going to show us,
but that was one of the weirdest way he went down.
Yeah,
and also the way like he was trying to get up and it would just wasn't working.
It was like his ACL at blown out or something.
It's like when you,
when you,
when you just kind of tease the cockroach or bug spray
black.
I grew up in The Bahamas.
Mad.
What the fuck?
We're all like [inaudible] I do that
here.
Let's see it here.
Okay.
You hit him on the right hand.
Is that it?
Hmm.
That's weird.
Oh,
I see.
I was a left hook.
No,
that's the,
that's the left hook is the end.
Well what,
what made him wobble like that?
No,
that's the very end of the fight.
He was already hurt,
but he already had a problem with his leg was great.
Camera.
I want to know this is terrible.
Replace.
I would,
if I would be asking the truck,
I want to know what happened.
Did he,
was it a punch?
Was it an elbow?
Like what caused him to go down the first time and why was he so wobbly?
Was it because he got hurt or was it because of a knee injury?
Man,
why don't they show that?
Get on it.
Glory.
Is it like 12 year old doctor right there?
Is that,
yeah.
You gotta be 14 to be a Doogie Howser right there.
Holding onto him.
Dude.
Fuck.
Showing us this.
Show us what happened in the past.
I don't know why they're not showing that this is,
this is a very strange,
don't they broadcast this overseas also?
It's probably commercial time.
I think you're exactly right.
Yeah.
How the fuck is this not on regular TV?
It's so exciting.
I mean the in the depth of talent look sits on peanut and it's 20 years old.
How many of these dudes are out there and there?
Is there a hundreds?
You know,
it was a lot.
Yeah.
The depth of talent and kickboxing is off the fucking charts
and uh,
isn't mal pet fighting Kyle home back tonight?
I heard that a Kai.
I got hurt and they pull it out of the fight.
I heard it.
I tried texting him but I haven't heard,
but I heard him when the loan is neon this recently,
this week maybe.
Oh my God.
That reached out to her.
Do you know how many fights mallet that has?
Some are 200 to 800.
That's crazy.
Yeah,
it's,
it is amazing.
It's amazing.
Um,
you know,
he has a brother.
Who else is on the,
um,
the lion fight card.
Did they cancel the whole card or they just can't the main fire,
the main of it,
I think now,
uh,
mellow feds fighting Joe Joe something.
Joe Not Ofwat.
Yeah.
Holy Shit.
That's a better fight or a really good fight.
At least it's a really good fight.
And then the,
uh,
my buddy wrote me a is fighting on that card as well.
Who's modeling lion fight has some outstanding talent.
They really do.
Yeah.
There's a California and in the u s in general,
there's a lot of,
uh,
there's a lot of really good Manito more so probably than kickboxing because,
cause there's so many Moitai gyms here in Los Angeles.
Yeah,
makes sense.
It just seems to me it'd be like the most underappreciated,
underrated sport in the u s especially like,
what is the one thing that people complain about an MMA like,
oh fuck and go to the grown.
You're queer and stop hugging each other.
No one goes to the ground.
This is all stand up.
And yet still,
I think Moyie Thai also,
it was much more entertaining.
Inboxing,
straight boxing.
Oh yeah,
for sure.
And I think boxing's entertaining.
Don't get me wrong,
the greed,
I still enjoy it.
But yeah,
I mean,
so the talent's there and the people to watch it or here.
So where's the problem lies?
They're going to show it to us.
Show us the fucking replay.
Yeah.
I mean,
that's a part of the problem.
They call them Joseph Joe Schilling is that you get these Thai guys beating up
Americans.
So,
okay,
this is world class kickboxing.
So we're going to make a match up with there.
One of our American up going American stars and we're going to match them up
with a guy with 160 fights there.
Kind of fucking interesting,
interesting.
Let's see it again.
So there is a right hand.
Okay.
Is that right hand?
The what's short circuited in them?
Hmm.
And this is what the end,
the end.
This is the ends.
It,
he,
the referee should have fucking called did that guy's behind him waving it off.
Who's the guy waving it off?
He was like an official.
Hmm.
Incredible.
Well,
either way,
who makes that match up?
That's a good question.
Why would you make that match up?
Yeah.
I mean maybe they just need it to fight pain on 600 hundred,
260 something.
Thank,
he literally has
16 times more fights.
That's crazy,
man.
Well,
he's a bad motherfucker,
that's for sure.
No,
it just interesting to see.
Uh,
I,
I would hate for glory and for kickboxing in general to stay at this level about
the heart on Casey.
We're all sitting here saying,
stop the fight stuff of the fight.
He ain't going to stop the fight he wanted to.
Exactly.
Yeah,
you get it knocked me out.
Account guys are fucking monster.
He didn't even try to take a knee when he couldn't stand up.
You know,
he didn't,
he didn't say,
let me just take a knee here.
And is he praying to the Thai king who just died?
Just died.
Yeah.
So that's really common too.
Also in Thailand,
they always,
there's always usually carried a photo of the king to the ring and whatnot.
Very loyal to the king over there.
So when the king passed away here recently,
it was last week,
I think it's like a really big deal to the
Thai people may hear if Obama died,
it would be like a big deal,
but not enough people would be as
Malaparte.
It had a picture and he posted something on his,
on his Instagram about it.
And I don't know if anybody's standing near with a tribute to Obama,
they wouldn't get any of our presence.
Yeah.
If Obama got shot,
maybe a month into office,
people would be sad.
But after a month they were already blaming him for the economy,
you know?
But after eight years,
yeah,
he'll probably get shot now they're just going to repeal Obamacare.
The same type of people that still want to have confederate flags would be
cheering.
Those people be so happy.
I go back to Texas sometimes and literally two miles from my daughter's house on
a corner on a,
on a,
on a highway intersection.
There's,
they just got confederate flags just lined up hanging and they're selling them.
They just sit in there and their trailers selling confederate flags.
People driving around with confederate flags flying out of the back of their
trucks,
their pickups.
It's,
it's a different,
it's weird coming out here because I grew up with,
I seen that a lot.
It,
it wasn't strange to me until I came here,
lived here for a year and then went back there and saw it.
So I grew up in Ohio and that was like a thing,
but it was like not like a racist thing.
It's like a southern thing and it's like part of history.
Know what the fuck are you talking about?
Like,
what the fuck are you talking about?
No,
it's like redneck.
It's not,
you know,
it's not whatever.
And I'm really in a grits chip,
like all pissed off too.
They're like,
you can't use a,
like they got rid of it or whatnot.
Well they were lending history.
I'm like,
what the fuck kind of history is.
Yeah.
That's a history you want to fucking keep or knowledge of the Nazis hung onto
that.
Germans like there was one time when we were strong.
Right.
Or the rise
rising,
uh,
rising sun.
That rising sign is still a big issue with a lot of fighters that have that
attitude is p hat.
Yeah.
But some fighters have that tattooed and you know,
some people think it's incredibly offensive.
Koreans and Chinese people really get offended by it.
Yeah.
I think,
yeah,
it's easy for people outside of that to not understand what this,
those symbols actually actually mean.
So this is an interesting fight.
Cavalera he's a bad motherfucker.
Um,
uh,
not,
not familiar with Dallas and neither am I.
He,
I know he fought.
And Gloria before,
this is like his second fight.
His first fight,
he,
but he took it on like a week's notice and he found a heavyweight.
Hmm.
So I dunno cause look at the things,
there's a couple of guys that drop weight on this card and the uh,
the middleweight turning contender tournament.
There's this guy,
macho,
macho or Machado and Machado.
He fought on the contender tournament,
a tool five at Gloria 32,
but now he's in the Middle Way tournaments.
So students with Mike's gym,
he's still,
even though he's finding to a five,
it's still carrying some body fat on them.
How many weight classes glory have now?
Um,
five,
right?
45,
55,
70 85,
two oh five and heavyweight.
Oh,
they're so close.
Why is it so much like mmm,
because they're unoriginal,
original and they want it to be just like the UFC to sell to the UFC fans.
That's so we did cause they're calling two oh five light heavyweight.
That's hilarious.
The UFC is what used to,
uh,
before the UFC he made the way classes or whatever.
Middleweight was one 54,
just like boxing.
Right.
You know,
and then there's like junior light heavy.
There's like a million types of middleweights.
No,
yeah,
yeah.
Well middle weight was one 60 but it was one 54 to one 60 right.
Super Middleweight one 68 light heavyweight one 75 cruiserweight one 95 there
was a time where,
you know the UFC didn't even have a 55 when eve Edwards as the baddest
motherfucking 55 on the planet.
You were the uncrown champ man.
It's a long time ago.
Long time ago.
But you were the uncrown champ when the UFC eliminated that right after you
knocked out Josh Thompson,
you were the consensus best 155 pound guy in the planet.
And then the UFC said yeah,
it never really ended this way.
Class.
Yeah.
That was in the hemorrhaging money money days.
They didn't have any money.
No kind of sucked.
But it is what it is.
Right?
No Man should give you a fucking belt though.
Yeah.
This is break you off of this.
Break you off.
Shit out this.
This is still something for the Mantel.
And I just go home and I put my,
put my,
I make a playlist on,
on fight pass and
watch my journey to the title.
Pretend that I can just take a burlap sack.
Philadelphia,
the light bulbs
you hear that sounds like a burlap sack.
Didn't know in that fight Aaron Riley had happened his entire lower jaw
reconstructed with like metal and have his teeth wired into place.
And I did.
I didn't know he had all those wires.
I knew he had to have surgery.
I knew he had surgery goes,
it's pretty significant.
I think you literally broke the,
where the teeth connect to his lower jaw.
I think you snapped all that.
Hence the light bulb analogy.
It makes more sense now that for sure.
Yeah.
It sounds like it's Dick move into the house and you're like,
I know he had surgery.
Like,
cause you were fucking,
uh,
I wrote that down in my diary.
Dear diary.
Aaron Riley had surgery to Aaron [inaudible] has been on the receiving end of
some fucking ruthless fights.
The Robbie Robbie Lawler.
He introduced Robbie Lawler to the EOC.
I know that was in fun.
And then Chris leaving.
No,
not crazy.
Leave and I'm sorry Chris Lidell.
Yeah.
Well Chris Liebing introduced the world to Anderson.
That was tailor made tailor made for him.
Yeah,
I remember that.
He went there if like,
I mean you always go into a fight.
Confident,
but he went into that fight.
It's confidence leaving can beat.
Yeah.
And then it was like,
hello world.
I'm Anderson Silva.
Yeah.
That was when Anderson was really like,
he had taken time off of pride and then he went and fought in cage rage and he
cage rage.
It really came into his own when he fought cage rage.
Those are some of the most impressive fights you ever had an entire career.
Oh yeah.
Tony fricking with the back elbow.
How about Lee Marie?
Beat the fuck out of Lee Marie.
Beat the fuck out of him and Lee Marie was scary back then.
It wasn't Lee Marie like a,
I heard he's like a fucking debt collector or something over there.
Oh,
he's way,
way
most gangsters.
Gangster that ever gangster
lean.
Mary's responsible.
He was one part of the biggest armed robbery in the history of England.
He's still in jail in Morocco.
He got a girl pregnant from jail.
That's how strong his comments.
He fathered a child while he was in the pokey Pablo Escobar stuff.
He,
um,
he also interested in also had a crazy fight.
Would Jorge Rivera,
do you remember that fight?
We're Rivera.
He let Rivera Punch him in the face cause Rivera was like a hard hitter and he
stood right in front of Rivera and Rivera clinch out with them and hit it with
bombs.
He's stood out.
I'm looking at him hitting him
and if he needs to be a beast,
I remember from,
from where he was fine.
You know,
Anderson used to fight 167 pounds.
Yeah.
And Pride.
Judo all that's right.
It does it shoot.
Oh champ.
He beats soccer I for the belt one 67.
Wow.
That was like in [inaudible] 99.
Do you remember that kid who used to fight?
What the fuck was his name?
He used to call himself the Brazilian killer.
Alex.
Steve Blank's Taleb.
Alex dribbling.
Yeah.
He's to call himself the Brazilian killer because he beat a bunch of Brazilians
as tough ass white dude and a Anderson Shin to Muckross the eyebrow and opened
up a new vagina on his forehead.
Yeah,
Steven,
it was Steven was bad until that happened.
Yeah.
Addison will change your life,
man.
Yeah.
He'll open up a vagina on your forehead.
What he did to Carlos Newton and pride.
Oh yeah.
A flying knee.
Boom.
It,
it's weird.
Some of the losses that he had,
the like the Real Joan and oh yeah.
It's like had a broken foot going into that fight.
Oh yeah.
I didn't know that.
Yeah.
Real CHONe and hit him with the craziest flying scissor.
He'll hook,
tap out.
Ever.
Was it on that foot like you probably like right away
maybe,
but I honestly chose him,
was beating him on the feet.
Anderson did not look good in that fight.
His timing was off.
It was tentative.
He just wasn't properly prepared.
But that was also when he was going through this transitionary period where he
left,
um,
shoot the box and he started Moitai Dream Team.
You remember that?
Yup.
Yeah,
he,
he had uh,
like left and then sort of established is,
it was like he was in the middle of like transitioning between gyms and I,
I just don't think he was trained as well as he had been in the past.
What's your favorite all time?
Well,
and not even all the time.
Let's just go back to,
because you've been doing this for a long time,
even watching them and may the whole time it's been around.
Joe,
what's your favorite MMA fight from back in the day?
Man,
I don't know if I have a favorite.
I don't think I have a favorite,
but I remember looking forward to those Vandelay fights more than anything on
the planet.
He just,
my all time,
he'll be like,
at the time,
at least my favorite just cause he was just fucking tornado of chaos.
He was so primal,
you know,
it was just so filled with rage and he would be looking at the guy across the
ring and doing that shit with his wrist where his role,
his hands.
He was just so fucking crazy like snake.
Yeah.
Fucking like he uh,
he was so crazy context or what.
But I think like when cro cop knocked him out,
that was one of my favorite fights too because the style that Vandelay used was
not a technical style.
Like he swung punches with his arms.
He was very overly muscled juice to the tits,
just fucking jacked and super aggressive.
And you know,
he knocked a lot of guys out and want a lot of fights.
But when you saw that shit against cro cop,
it was just not flying and it just was not going to happen.
Like Cro cop was at a completely different level when he came to striking.
And then in that fight Vandelay striking was exposed because I remember watching
a,
a of an old school Vandelay fight with a friend of mine who was a striker who
knew how to box.
It's like,
God,
this guy throws his wild ass punches.
He,
you know,
he doesn't cover his chin and he just,
just,
everything is arm punches and looping like MMA striking is kind of fucked up.
I'm like,
wow.
You know,
I mean it's easier said than done.
Like there's a lot of good strikers who stood in front of Angela and panicked
cause he was just so fucking crazy and screaming and
all he has to do is land one of those.
Oh yeah.
But I'm with Cro,
cop,
Cro,
cop it,
the first fight,
it was one of those weird rules.
Fights.
I remember that they had shorter rounds.
They limited the amount of time on the ground.
It was a,
and it was a draw.
It wasn't a fight where they had a distinctive decision like you couldn't me,
we'll make any on that.
Because the betting line was the,
I guess the,
the,
the people putting up the betting line,
they didn't realize that if the fight went to the distance,
it was a draw automatic.
Oh,
so they bet for the draw.
Yeah.
And they paid out to,
hmm.
That's interesting.
But that was back when you could fucking Ben Online,
man.
God,
they got to bring that back.
I would be betting on everything online.
If online betting was still there,
I'd been on this for fun.
Why not?
Right?
This isn't the books here at kings is,
are they shut draft,
draft draftkings is fantasy.
It's different.
It's like,
you know,
you pick fighters,
you pick rounds.
It's like a sneaky way of getting around.
Gambling could kind of gamble,
but it's not the same.
I want to be able to bet 50 bucks on this guy.
I want to bet 100 bucks on that guy.
I want to be able to bet I'm a fucking grown man.
I pay taxes.
American.
Isn't that what Bo dog was?
Yes.
Well that's why that guy,
Calvin Ayre had to leave the country.
He,
he's,
he's a criminal because he had all this online gambling shit going on and he was
an American citizen,
so he can't even live in America anymore.
Not only that,
I don't even think he's allowed to visit America.
I think Calvin Ayre lives in like Costa Rica.
Do you remember Calvin air?
Do you remember Bo dog fight?
I remember about does somebody else like that too?
Um,
it was a gang of those guys.
Shoot,
I forget his name.
There turned a bunch of entrepreneurs and the criminals
just change the law America.
America.
But Calvin,
I had some great fights,
man.
He brought the world chill son.
And that was the first Chell Senate fight.
Cain Velasquez headed first fight on Bodog.
Yup.
Um,
and he fought for Boda Boda Doug and he was the Cham Bodog Mazda Mosbey.
Dot.
Jorge Mas at all.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
He put on some good fights and he put him on the beach and the girls were bang
and he had ring card girls that just cheesiness gamma was always like on a beach
somewhere.
So most include Costa Rica.
Exactly.
Costa Rica.
Yeah.
He put everything on like where he likes to hang out.
It's like shit,
it's,
have a fight here.
And then once was in Russia,
that kind of sucked.
It was cold.
It was November.
Yeah.
He did it in Russian.
He had fade or fight.
Matt Lindland.
Yup,
that's right.
Remember that?
And I think Matt Lindland got fucked in the fight.
Remember fade or grab the ropes.
Matt Lindland got the clinch on fader and Matt Lindland was about to take
forward fade or down a fade or grab the ropes and held on hard and then reverse
the position because he grabbed the ropes.
You know,
I remember that and I think Matt Lindland got fucked financially too,
if I remember correctly.
I don't think he got paid or he didn't get paid what he's supposed to get paid
or something.
There was some sort of controversy,
but the controversy about the takedown was gigantic.
Could you imagine if it,
Matt Linden would've beaten Fader at that time?
Oh my God,
I've been crazy at that time.
Fade or was fate or,
yeah,
but that was post pride,
right?
That was post.
Yeah.
He
had gone through a lot of weird shit.
Right.
In pride,
I feel like there's fate or in pride and I think fate,
Orin pride is the all time greatest heavyweight.
I feel like Fade Oren pride.
If you want to look at like and who knows what's going on as far as like
chemicals and steroids and all kinds of shit.
You who knows because you know that everybody was doing shit.
Right.
I've told this story before but I've told this story before but I wish I still
had a copy of it.
But the pride contract,
the contract says this is what it reads.
It says you will be tested for cocaine,
heroin and other barbiturates.
Then the very next line was all caps and said you will not be tested for
steroids
in the contract ends and told me about that an anyway and since the G.
Yeah,
he's awesome.
I love that guy.
He's coming into town so I know you get a hold of that dude.
I think it was k one k one or heroes maybe dream I heard but it was like
everybody would go in for the drug test and then they were,
when they came out,
like they were just big cups all the way along like the on the floor like outs,
like cups full of Piss but like nobody's name on it.
And that was their whole drug testing system.
But everybody pissed in a cup is ted.
No clue who's was what.
That's awesome.
I saw something with ensign on Viceland a couple of days ago.
Um,
what was he doing?
It wasn't,
he wasn't,
he wasn't even hosting the show.
The Guy,
I don't remember the guy's name.
Anyway,
Ensign was,
uh,
he had these guys in Japan.
It was street fighting,
so they had on MMA gloves,
but they like,
you know,
I call,
they have the car race,
race car guys.
It seems like they had,
they parked a bunch of cars.
They meet up,
made a ring with the cars and they're just throwing now it with little gloves
on,
concrete on concrete.
It's on vice land.
It's,
I think it's on this week or it was on last week.
Viceland is crazy.
I love that network.
That's amazing.
They put on some insane programs.
That's like a,
a real man channel.
Like,
you know,
man cave channel.
You sit,
you sit in your man cave and just watching it,
have you ever watched?
Fucked US delicious.
That dude came in here,
man.
He's action.
Bronson smoked more joints in the course of an hour than anyone in the history
of the podcast.
Half these joints that these roaches are sitting in the ass shoes.
I never seen anybody just burned through joints like a chain smoker through
cigarettes,
two hours.
I mean I was so faded,
I had no idea what we talked about just three minutes ago and he just keeps,
he keeps hitting it.
Snoop is like that.
I was on a nick,
nick was in town.
He was doing that Gigi and snoop Dogg is this football thing he does?
No,
it's like a,
it's like a podcast network.
Oh yeah.
He does it with video.
Right video up there and uh,
went in there and like he just blunt after block,
after block,
after block after block,
like through like a pound that we used to go up.
We were like,
we could nick hang with one.
But it was like,
it was,
it was rough.
But you can just see like
how like he was though.
Like even snoop was like on some other shit going on.
And then how did it action Bronson do after smoking all those joints?
Well,
he's still,
she was barbecued when he got here.
He got here cooked and he got,
he kept getting cooked.
I mean it was like,
yeah,
you're done dude.
Like some dudes just don't stop.
I don't,
I stop man.
I like when we do podcasts,
I'll take a couple hits and I'm like,
I'm good.
You guys good?
We're good.
But some people are never good.
They just keep going.
I don't understand it because it's different mentality.
You know who,
uh,
who got me one of the most high will get the ax kick.
Um,
do you remember a cabbage?
Cabbage,
Korea.
A cabbage.
One of my favorite fighters I've ever,
he's an animal.
The,
that is the kind of fighters I really want to see.
The people that come back.
Go ahead.
He was in,
uh,
in Vegas and me and him in any bravo.
We,
uh,
went to my hotel room and he,
he,
he had this fucking chuck can't take blonde and we were so high we could,
we should have stopped.
But he kept saying,
Yamato the Mushy,
you know,
which means warriors and warrior spirit.
He kept saying that Yamato demoss she Qi and he'd pass the joint.
I'm like,
all right,
man.
Yeah,
Samurai spirit.
I don't want to disappoint cabbage.
And we just,
the rest of the night we're done.
Like we went to a bus,
we went and ate and then were just like all paranoid,
fucked up,
contemplating mortality for the rest of the night.
But he used to save my head's full of rocks and junk or some shit like that.
It's all full of rocks and junk.
With that Hawaiian accent,
he could take it,
man.
Oh Man.
Oh my God.
That fight with Sylvia.
I remember they fought Tim Silvia.
Tim Silvia beat the fuck out of him and um,
and our Lawsky to my rescue or Lawsky kr 10 [inaudible] him in a k one fight.
I want to say,
I feel like it was a kickboxing fight.
I feel like it was in Hawaii.
Yeah,
Dude.
That dude look like Stephan Bonner for a second.
Hello.
Hey,
look,
it's Joe Schilling,
ladies.
Gentlemen.
They only show you getting your mouthpiece knocked out.
These fucks?
No,
that was Simon get in his mouth.
Oh,
that's right.
And has he done man?
What's going on with him now?
I don't know.
I hope so.
Did you watch,
uh,
the uh,
Simon Marcus,
uh,
Jason Wellness fight?
Did you ever want to watch that?
Saw The highlight?
I didn't see crazy fight.
Now I'm crazy fight dude.
It's like all the wind went out out of Simon sales.
Like Jason Wellness was getting battered early on and Simon look fantastic.
You look super aggressive,
super strong.
But then somewhere,
somewhere around the second round it looked like he's was just losing all of his
pop and then he did some weird things.
You see that weird thing he did against the ropes?
That's all he was stood there.
He is like a bravado kind of thing.
Yeah.
Let
them tee off on him.
One give it to me and then fucking gave it to him or I gave it to him.
I have my wellness can crack.
We didn't know that more than anybody.
Yeah.
That should be interesting.
It looked to me like a Simon sounds even like Simon was getting tired and you
know,
and I had heard that he's not with his old coach anymore.
It's maybe that's it.
But the,
as I as asking Eva,
being in Denver when I fought there,
it makes a big difference.
The high altitude and a,
he's fighting Dustin Jacoby,
who I don't think it's anywhere near the,
the caliber fighter to fight a guy like Simon,
but he's from Denver and that gives them a lot of advantage of,
that's tonight.
Yeah.
Do you think assignment should recover though?
Mean he got knocked the fuck out just a couple of months ago?
Yeah.
I don't think that's good either.
No,
no.
When I knocked him out,
he fought again.
Like I said,
it's got like that fun part,
but in China,
like I don't know right away and it got knocked out again.
Who Killed Him and China?
I forget the guy's name.
I don't remember,
but it was an upset.
It's on youtube,
but that was a big upset.
That's kind of scary.
You,
you heard about um,
Jordan portions,
CTE like 25.
Right.
And he only had two losses and one by Kao.
It's like I,
I know we got CTE man,
like CTE,
chronic traumatic encephalopathy,
except for head trauma from head trauma.
Brain damage.
Yeah.
But they can't test it and they can't see it until you're dead.
Postmodern ma or to autopsy.
Oh,
so it was all it he had it or if the car portions want me to hit by the car.
Right,
right.
Yeah.
And he was only 25 and then they found out that he had that and didn't even
know.
Yeah.
Oh,
that's awful.
Well,
what's crazy is he was okay.
I mean,
he was articulate.
He,
he fought well,
he functioning fully functioning,
and then they do this test on them and they're like,
yeah.
Well,
what they're concerned with is that they're missing out on,
you know,
a lot of the damage that,
uh,
you're,
you're getting in the gym and that there's no way to really detect it until
you're dead.
But it's just like the slow creeping thing that's happening to you.
And then,
I mean,
when,
when does it like a guy like Jordan portion is 25 years,
it'll fully functional,
articulate.
He can hang with any conversation.
But then what does that mean when he's 60 or 44?
That's the big question.
What does that mean?
Yeah.
What does it mean for a guy like Peter Hertz?
It has been Kol like 14 times,
right?
Yeah,
no,
yeah,
yeah.
Fucking a Cyborg.
Yeah.
If he didn't have it before,
after that me,
he's got it now.
He probably has,
if he has it after,
you know,
just two of them.
I'm sure I already have it.
I think we all,
I,
I promise you there's,
you know,
they all have a role player.
My cousin was,
had had concussions and multiple concussions just playing high school football,
you know?
Yeah.
Fuck yeah.
That's probably,
I mean,
if,
if you could see it,
that would probably be,
uh,
an epidemic right now.
If you could see who had it.
Right.
It was like a light bulb that went off on their head.
And what do we know about it though?
Like what?
What does this degenerative takes time to show it's full affects eight to 10
years after you're diagnosed with it,
you really start seeing the damage because it slowly gets worse.
Start drooling and Sheila depending of course on whether or not you still
receive damage.
Supposedly there's some athletes and NFL athletes that either kill themselves or
did some,
some extremely violent things because they weren't fully functioning like that.
A Will Smith movie.
That's what it is.
That's exactly what it is.
Yeah.
It's not like they think about like these uh,
the uh,
WWF guys are like the pro wrestlers always.
They always in advantage to fucking psychotic fucking crazy deaths.
And then everyone's like,
oh,
they're on steroids with them.
Maybe they get fucking slammed in the head and like,
have you seen Kurt angle outside of the ring?
Lilly?
No.
He like looks like crippled,
like can't even turn his hand.
Even hardly moves.
Like that man looks terrible.
And then they turn the camera on and he's like,
ah.
I'm like,
I pulled us together,
but he looks really fucking bad,
Huh?
Yeah.
A buddy of mine just went to a high school football game and he said in a high
school football game,
he saw six kids get laid out,
just laid out or their boom collide.
And these kids were just laying down fucking knocked unconscious out of their
fucking mind.
No high school football game.
Think about that though.
I mean you're taking some of the Beth and high school there,
Beth,
at best athletes in their school.
But when you get to the NFL level,
some,
some of the best athletes in the world,
you put them in a box and you just say go 60 times and they just run into each
other.
That's what it is.
It's,
you know they're going to have brain trauma.
This is no way around that.
All of the money comes in and all of the other,
the other people like guiding you come into play,
you know when you're a high school kid,
you know,
and then you've got these fucking crazy dads.
They're like,
come on.
So nigga be telling my cousin had like a broken ankle but like still play the
fucking state championship was like in Ohio was like big football town,
you know.
And um,
yeah,
he had like multiple concussions and playing with injuries and all that ship
because it was like a big deal.
Yeah.
You gotta be a man.
I got to be a man.
Crazy.
The biggest fight in kickboxing history.
Butter hires an excellent fighter,
but it's my time.
I am the champ
fighting was Shin protection.
I had Garrett's already a household name in Japan where the real men were
fighting such a g
let's by like the fourth thing that they were like,
no,
you can't say he wrote another one that he can't say that.
Okay,
fine.
Your household name.
Okay,
we'll take it.
That's going to be a crazy fight,
man.
Yeah.
Um,
there's the real problem with all the CTE shit is there's nothing they can do
about it.
It's not like you get a broken bone and they can put in a titanium rod and they
can screw it in place and yeah,
my heel up,
I'll be all right in after awhile.
CBA.
But it's just that they don't,
we don't know that yet.
I mean there's nothing they can do about it now.
Right,
right.
But yeah,
so I guess the next step would be to be figure out a way to test for it while
people are still alive.
But did you,
when you got up here,
Jamie,
what is this?
This is Joe Nemeth is,
yeah,
he's got under hyperbaric oxygen therapy.
It says,
ah.
He says he's,
this is his quote right here.
He's got a trial.
He's trying to get some money for at a research center where they're going to do
testing to see if they can.
So that's my thinking is much clear,
explains finding the right words.
It's become easier.
And I remember events with more clarity.
One of the really great results of my sleep has improved.
I sleep more soundly and I have vivid dreams with the therapy now completed.
Joe maintains that the lasting benefits are both mental and physical and now
more energy and strength.
I feel great.
How much pussy you think he's getting still?
Joe Nemeth used to walk around with a fucking gigantic for code on when you can
wear for just balling out of control and the 1970s
it was an old school dudes,
man,
old school football players,
they get fucking banged up.
So yeah,
I think it's few now that they've like recognize this is the thing.
Then they get started looking in to how you fix it or whatever.
But I'm sure like CBD oil and altitude hyperbaric chambers and all that Shit,
right?
Well hypobaric is the mushrooms exact opposite of altitude.
High altitude is low oxygen.
Hyperbaric is high altitude or
they find that if they that over,
they oversaturate you with oxygen,
that all of your cells tend to open up and then it starts to figure out new ways
to repair itself.
Is the idea between that
it's mostly great for broken bones but supposed to be great when people have
injuries,
like a recovery time increases
well graduate cells increases your red blood cells.
Right.
And that's what helps with the healing.
No,
I think that's the,
that's the hyper.
The one with less oxygen increases the red blood cells.
The more oxygen is what repairs.
Oh.
And I think that's supposed to be really good for,
I did it a few times after my,
uh,
to repair from like,
knockouts.
Did you feel it,
you feel a difference?
I never had felt a difference ever,
like negatively,
but I just did it to be safe,
safe,
smart.
Are you one of those guys who doesn't feel like the effects of things?
Say you're taking some supplement that's supposed to be great and you don't
really feel it?
No,
I feel like I have a really good awareness of my body and like I try to,
I tried to be really good about that,
but I mean after like being knocked out like I felt could have been knocked out
I think two times,
three times now where it was like a half hour after the fire where I still look
real pretty fucked up,
you know?
And then after that happens I'm like really aware of it and like I've even asked
my girl like my,
my being normal,
like my slower.
I'm like fuck I fuck keep forgetting my car keys and like,
dude,
your highest fuck all time.
Now
I'm like,
are you sure I'm not like dumb or like,
no,
just do your high.
We always lost your keys.
But ironically good for your brain.
Yeah,
it's good for inflammation,
but you never know.
You don't want to end up be that guy that they didn't know that is like slurring
a slow rise.
We've all seen those punchy guys in the gym,
you know,
and those guys who are punching the gym and they start talking about finding it
again.
We've all seen those guys where they just,
they in their mind,
they're just,
just got to get in shape.
They still got it.
They can go back and do it again.
And
can you just want to tell him,
man,
Joe,
you said,
um,
after getting knocked up once or twice,
30 minutes later.
So I've been knocked out like two or three times also,
but only one of them do.
I remember not remembering a big chunk of change.
So when I flat out,
I don't remember leaving the cage.
I don't remember walking back.
I remember sitting there with,
with Tyron and somebody else in the doctor and I'm talking and I'm having it.
I'm literally saying something and then I realize my wife's in here and I'm Jai.
My consciousness comes back to me in the middle of while I'm speaking to Tyron,
I'm talking to Tyron and I'm looking at my lung.
Why the hell is she back here?
Like,
and then I ask him,
man,
he told me what happened.
And I was,
I couldn't believe it.
I didn't,
I didn't remember fighting any of that.
I don't remember any of that.
I just know what happened cause I watched the tape.
So to this day you don't have a functional memory?
No,
I saw a stitch that night and he was like,
we talked on your way back.
It's backstage.
I don't,
I don't remember that conversation at all.
I don't remember seeing,
I don't remember the walk
from the octagon back to the dock
two or three times I've been locked up,
maybe three times,
probably been knocked out.
And uh,
it was just one time where that's ever happened at the exact same thing.
Was it the last one?
No,
it was my first one actually.
When a psycho one.
When I'm Simon.
No,
was it Simon?
I think it was Eddie Walker.
Did you go lion fight?
I got,
I was winning the entire fight and went for like one bass thing and got clipped
and uh,
I,
they woke me up in the ring and I,
they walked me in backstage,
but I don't remember walking backstage.
And I remember La Scott can't the lion fight.
A promoter was like checking in on me and like talking to me and I came to like
as I was talking to him and I'm like,
oh coach,
I need your phone.
And I call my girl,
let her know I'm okay cause I know they watched it and I call and she's like
laughing.
I'm like,
what the fuck are you laughing about?
Like I just got knocked out and she's like,
this is the fourth time you called me.
And I was like,
oh other than that I've been,
well since that time it was a good like 15 minutes that I,
that I had no recollection of.
Yeah,
that's the big one,
right?
What happened?
And you tell him and then they ask you again about what happened.
You always see that with the guy in the back locked up.
Like what happened though?
And like five minutes they're like,
what happened?
I'm like,
Bro,
he's still got knocked out like you were.
You got fucked up.
Scary.
That is such a weird thing that the missing time thing.
Yeah,
because I mean you're,
you're,
you're interacting with people and like what is that?
Well,
how does your,
what part of your brain is turned off for that period of time?
Yeah,
that's strange.
It's scary,
dude.
That was why after Overeem fought Steve Bay,
I was like,
you can't do this anymore.
I can't interview guys after they got knocked out.
It's just not fair.
It's just not,
it's not right.
Yeah.
That was really cool of you to do that.
Like quieter from that perspective.
Like I,
that was like dope shit that you,
you said that like stuck up for them.
Cause watching it as a fighter,
you always like,
I'm a cup of guy that if somebody starts saying something embarrassing,
like I almost want to turn it off.
Like I get embarrassed for people all the time.
Yeah.
People think that,
like I said,
a hung over him out to dry.
I didn't know if he was right or not.
Yeah.
I didn't know.
I mean if you don't know what we're talking about after the fight over him got
knocked out,
knocked out pretty bad,
but he was,
it was a fight where there was moments.
We had his moments in the fight.
He,
uh,
he tags tpa had Steve Bay rocked.
I mean it was a crazy one round.
And after the fight he said,
you know that Steve Bay one,
but that he feels that,
that,
uh,
Steve Bay tapped that.
He got ahold of the gear.
Steve Bay tapped and I went,
whoa,
okay,
well let's take a look at it and we couldn't see it.
And then I said,
do you think it's at another angle?
And he said,
yes,
I do.
Okay,
let's see it again.
So we showed it at different angles.
There was definitely no tap.
And so then I'm like,
this poor dude,
like he just in front of all these fucking people in Cleveland,
he just gets knocked out and now it makes it look like he's a sore loser.
But you can't,
you can't count on his memory right now.
He just got shut off and Al's just been shut off a ton of times.
He's lost in the UFC by knock out,
he's lost to Travis Browne by knockout.
He's lost to Ben.
Ben Rothwell by knockout.
Yeah.
But this is just just to you go see big foot silver by knockout.
Steep Amy.
Oh,
check by.
Knock out.
Am I missing anybody?
He's been CalEd four times just in the UFC at least.
Right?
Because anybody else Cato Kao dumb.
No,
I think that's it in the UFC then you've got to think all the times it's been
chaos.
Surrogate Keratan off.
Knocked him out.
Um,
shogun knocked him out twice,
right?
Didn't he?
Um,
chuck,
Chuck,
Dr Mount.
Yeah.
Chuck Kale Room.
A brutal Kao.
Yeah.
Bought or knocked him out.
Bought her,
stopped him.
But,
but the bottom stop,
which was one of the worst ones,
weird stuff,
was it to knock out two knocked down thing in a tournament.
You know,
he got knocked down and they stopped the fight or they think you can get knocked
down,
but he was fucking wobbled.
Yeah,
you'll wobbled.
And the last one you got kicked and he fell down and that was it.
So I mean,
a ton of chaos.
A ton of Kale losses.
Okay.
There should be a really good fight.
Spirits,
by the way.
Fargas super tactical and UNRUH smiling ones on his fire right now.
Is Reus smiling?
Is he thinking about doing MMA?
Because I'd see him at Black Zillions a lot.
Yeah,
he is.
He's a,
had a couple of them.
They fights I think,
um,
just recently he's been training with like things I think for at least a year
now bouncing back and forth and uh,
you have Varguez really,
really technical and a real tricky,
but I just think,
uh,
response got the experience,
the high level experience in the uh,
power.
Yeah.
Being in a locker room with,
with risk Mala hidden pads as he's probably the hardest I've ever seen anybody
like most impressive paddler where you're,
it was like,
Whoa,
what the fuck?
Really?
And I'm like,
fuck more than Melvin.
Yeah.
Well I've never,
yeah,
he never seen Melvin in there and say Japan's two,
there's a video of Melvin and Mike's holding the pads from Melvin.
He's just like Jesus Christ for the glory 10 fight in a tournament.
We all like,
somehow we ended up in this little tiny room with semi Schiltz in this little
tiny room with this two.
And there's like no fucking,
it was like eight guys.
One of them send me shelter in this tiny little room to warm up and a Robin
starts hitting pads and I didn't know who Robin was or whatever.
And like,
uh,
as soon as he hit the pad the first time I was like,
Yo move out of this guys.
We'll give them some space.
Call Him Sir.
Like his fucking hit him the hardest shit hitting the hardest shit and he's
only,
what is your 145 pounds?
This one is his first fight at one 45 but he was 55 and he's a,
he's a big fella.
He's probably what when he was probably walking around 180 pounds but he's
pretty short.
He's like five,
seven,
five,
six.
It looks real lean
right now.
Yeah.
This is an interesting fight cause Varga,
like you said,
real technical and he's not like a real chance taker.
He fights,
he fights a smart fight.
Oh.
Whereas we're small and super aggressive
and he got,
the other factor is responding,
cutting this way to 45 and then also it being in Denver high altitude.
And you had a hard way cut,
right?
Interesting.
E five rounds.
The title fight.
Oh,
I'm,
and then Vargas from Canada,
which I'm assuming is probably high altitude maybe,
but about my check on that Montreal is at sea level.
There's no fucking idea how the O'shea a a boat when he's lost the belt.
No,
didn't he?
I don't know.
I feel like,
you know.
No I don't.
No,
no.
I thought he lost it to the Adam.
Chuck D.
Well,
glory.
If like they're in negotiations,
it doesn't go well.
They just fucking give your belt somebody else
that how it works.
Yeah.
This shit ain't gone.
Shit ain't gone correct.
Amazing.
Big.
Very diplomatic.
You were talking about Melvin Joe and,
and that dude is an athlete,
right?
Yeah.
When he was down in American top team,
I threw the football to him.
He threw a football back of me and the thing came back like a helicopter.
Well,
he's from Holland.
I know.
They don't even know what a football is.
It was still weird whizzing back at you like a fucking yeah,
that was a stud.
Scary striker knocked out mark home a one punch man
in an MMA fight and he was outweighed by literally a hundred pounds.
Yeah.
I mean,
Mark Hunt was close to 300 pounds and Melvin was somewhere around 200 pounds,
probably less than 200 pounds.
He's always probably like one 91 eight,
five k OTE.
And what one shot.
Yeah.
Melvin's probably one of my favorite fighters of all time like that.
But if there was a fight on TV,
like I'm always going to turn it on the moment,
man.
Off Fire.
When you knocked him out,
was that a special victory for you because of that?
Yeah,
well,
he was my first like big,
big name,
I guess for MMA.
You know,
that was one of the big names.
And,
uh,
you know,
it was a,
it was a guy that like I really looked up to and like really respected a lot
and,
uh,
it was like meant a lot to me that,
that I was even gonna fight him.
But I think that that also helped me stay motivated going into it that had so
much respect for him.
So he's,
my worst fights are guys that I don't think I look at him like I don't think
he's that good.
I don't mean to like take them widely,
but I just see them and I'm like,
this is not right.
Scary Guy,
you know?
And that's like,
almost all my losses have been that way to me.
Goes a motherfucker,
dude.
Yeah.
Ego will protect you.
Make you think you're going to be all right.
We tend to fight to your Kelo beautiful,
nice left hook of the
Ethan Stein from glory.
Uh,
he's one of the social media team and I was talking to,
and I bet money,
but I think his job is he saying is John's broken?
[inaudible] came out.
Oh,
he didn't have it in.
Hi.
Sorry.
Oh Man.
Do you know his mouthpiece out at the beginning of the round?
He fought around without his mouth.
Bass.
That's on his corner.
Yeah.
Ban Him like you forgot your mouth piece wasn't then like unless he got stung in
the first round,
didn't know what the fuck was going on.
Got cracked again.
You got other shit.
Don't believe that shit.
This,
this Doug Jensen mother fucker come up pieces in it.
I know.
I don't know.
He might be ice from Canada.
He's from Canada.
They're different up there.
Two different gene pool.
Reus smiling.
Cool.
Oof.
Funny thing about responding as he has that Dutch style,
they very rarely black lake cakes there.
Just the,
do you know the typical Dutch style is who's almost,
who's tougher?
Fucking hit the answer right back here.
Yeah,
it's right by,
and I forget which fight it,
but I talked to,
I texted,
uh,
Robin and congratulate them after the finals.
Like you have to be,
it was Korea and like his legs were like all fucking purple and his ribs are all
messed up.
And he's like,
no,
I'm never,
never injured after my fun.
I never,
never have a problem.
I'm never saw and like I,
oh my,
I already know going into the fight like,
um,
it can if he hasn't got an extra bike and a tomb and because I'm going to break
my fucking feet every time.
That a yeah.
How many times you broke broken your feet?
I've broken all my toes,
like at least twice.
Uh,
I have a couple couple of wedge joints in my,
um,
on my right foot that a pretty regularly pop out of the socket after.
The worst is when the joints just don't come back.
They like a lot of the joints in the foot are kind of like this.
And then once you break them,
they go over top of each other.
Oh,
you went down again and kind of get that back in there.
Damn.
We're just moms on tear duties.
So much power and especially down at one 40,
one 43,
I guess.
What's the other glory rule?
Not the three knocked down,
but not in one round,
but in the,
in the whole fight.
Uh,
I think it's four knock downs in a fight.
Is that what it is?
Yeah.
Oh,
stunned them.
But that's a,
those are only for tournaments to those lousy.
Okay.
Tournament's are so fucking crazy.
They really are.
Tie Up.
There we go.
Just get out around and reset man.
Man.
What they're going to show that tooth flying out
great.
Mm.
Yeah.
I went flying into the audience.
That dude?
Yeah,
that was UFC one soccer kick or was he on his knees?
He was getting up.
Oh,
I remember that.
I was,
I came home from school and I read in the TV Guide magazine or whatever.
They had kickboxing versus judo versus karate versus song.
And I was like,
my style of bag,
my Stepdad,
I was like,
here,
here's the 20 bucks please.
I just want to watch this.
This is good to be awesome.
Well,
you doing martial arts then?
I was doing traditional martial arts.
I was doing con Kung Fu.
Wow.
I've been doing it for about two years at that point.
So when you were fine like Erin Riley,
you were really only doing martial arts for like six,
seven years,
Huh?
Yeah.
Wow.
That's interesting.
Man.
You were a quick learner.
Thanks.
It was fun,
man.
It's easy to pick up on something when you like doing it though,
right?
Of course.
And when you're young and you're free and you don't have kids and you're
obsessed.
Yeah,
and you don't know you're vulnerable yet always in shape,
tired your energy,
live off Mcdonald's all day
is the most awesome thing.
May in Burger's going to the gym.
I remember hearing that about Michael Jordan.
Michael Jordan would need a big Mac before every big game.
You're like,
what in the fuck?
I guess if you eat good all the time,
you get kind of get away with that.
But you really only get away with that when you're in your twenties that was
true.
It's not bullshit.
It's bullshit.
It's steak and potato is like his game.
You know?
I think he was just sponsored by Mcdonald's.
Oh,
interesting.
Very interesting.
Steak and potatoes make sense?
It makes sense today,
but there's a lot of clips of a Floyd Mayweather eating cheese cheeseburgers and
drinking mountain dew,
like between the rounds.
Well,
he apparently likes to drink soda like while he's fighting to replenish his
sugar or not.
When he's fighting,
while he's training to replenish your sugar.
Like he'll have a long workout and I'll drink a coke and then isn't he like the
only guy in Nevada that's allowed to drink Gatorade between rounds?
What the fuck?
They work that out and look it up.
Pull it up Jamie.
Not put look it up,
Jamie.
Is that really possible?
You like Gatorade came rounds,
talked about it like the one who the fuck has allowed to do this?
It's like,
well it's Floyd Mayweather.
You can do what he wants.
That doesn't seem fair.
How could that be?
How is that possible when you undefeated,
why do I remember that though?
In Nevada you are,
you know the amount of money that he brings in,
right?
What does it say?
Roll it back there.
Vargas Vargas bear barred from drinking Gatorade.
Fernando San Fernando Vargas.
What years is
2006 damn.
Fernando Vargas was still fighting in 2006
interesting.
He was banned from drinking Gatorade in his corner between rounds a minute.
Wait,
rematch with against Shane Mosley.
Junior middleweight
pull up up gatoraid and Floyd.
Floyd Mayweather didn't come up.
Maybe a just showing just made that shit.
Oh no buddy.
Joe Chilean doesn't trust you're googling skills.
Jamie's on his phone.
I'm going to go to youtube.
I'll find the video.
I don't know if they got fact check,
but look drinking Vargas,
just purple water front kicked him or the face it happened,
but I'm trying to find,
okay.
When that Vargas thing came up,
they reminded me of something I was,
I brought up to you earlier.
Ogun um,
my favorite fight from back then.
I think you will like this one.
MACACA versus Paley.
Oh yeah man.
The first thing,
it was good,
cool old school.
Do you remember what pay late fuck Chuck Paleo Fudge Chocolate Dell.
And they fought in one of those rings with the ropes.
The net than the not of the bottom.
Yeah,
I remember that shit yet with no gloves.
No gloves.
Yeah.
Old School.
Floyd Mayweather versus Manny Pacquiao.
Was it then?
Yeah.
It was like a recent fight that I noticed it.
Do you want to read in between rounds?
Must be nice to own Nevada state athletic commission.
Oh,
Michael Michael,
Cassie,
UFC fighter.
Put that up there.
Oh really?
Yeah.
What is that?
How the fuck does he have Gatorade?
Okay.
Hmm.
We'll get that.
All those MMA fighters commenting.
Michael Page commented on a Floyd Mayweather fight.
Really interesting.
What do you think about this upcoming Kovalev Andre Ward fight.
Andre Ward.
Do you think so really those think Andre Ward's this.
I think he's a,
he's a bad mother fucker,
but Kovalev was a big guy.
Yeah,
I just think he's,
he's just,
I think pound for pound is,
is,
I think it's gotta be a Andre Ward.
He's just so smart.
These guys are going off Vargas.
Megan,
to come back here a little bit.
Another one,
Floyd Mayweather and my team.
The money team might be the only corner I've ever seen a lot of drink Gatorade
during a fight.
Aljamain sterling and other MMA fighter.
All US peasants or demoted to water,
Mayweather,
Berto.
That was a different fight.
See all of us.
Mike Dolce,
can someone please explain why Floyd Mayweather can drink Gatorade during the
fight in Nevada state athletic commission.
Friends suspend us for anything but unsealed water.
Interesting.
Hmm.
I wonder what that was about.
They're just so happy.
He was making them so much money.
So much money.
Just such a smart guy in terms of like,
his style was never the kind of style that would make a bunch of people come out
to see him fight.
But all that shit talking made all those people want to come see him lose.
It's weird though because some,
I mean some of his fights,
you see his offense.
I think about um,
Kodo,
think about Judah,
Judah authorities.
But that was the weird one.
Angel enough.
Freddy Not Angel Bedford.
Um,
was it age or mind man?
Freddo
right.
I'm
giving him fucking gate or aid.
That is fucking crazy.
Gatorade.
They are opening up a Goddamn Gatorade.
It's a purple drink.
Just the perpetrator.
That is crazy.
His dad's giving him Gatorade.
That's so illegal.
Wow.
How the fuck did they get away with that?
Amazing.
That's amazing.
That's in Panama.
Louis Shit.
I was just thinking of that was trying to think of my high school.
That's one of the gimme the other bottle.
Yeah,
the one I may want a mixed.
All of a sudden he's Aaron Pryor and Alexis Arguayo
loose from Holland with a nasty left hook to the body there.
Oh Shit.
Nothing upper cut.
When I first joined Att Panama Lewis was,
was in there sometimes.
Was that like being next to the devil
because people don't remember that Billy Costello fight.
Do you remember that fight?
No.
Um,
Louie Resto was a fighter who fought this kid,
I think his name is Billy Castelle Junior.
And uh,
he was a real promising up and coming fighter and Louie Resto was a good boxer,
but not like a knockout box or where it's Collins was a big knockout boxer.
So,
uh,
Louie Resto beats the shit out of college.
When he took the stuff out of the glass,
Dad grabbed the glove and felt it.
The Guy,
the dad suspected it and after the fight he grabbed a hold of wrestles gloves
and rest pulled away and there was no stuffing in the glove.
He had,
it's just basically at hand wraps on and just bare knuckle beat the shit out of
him and it fucked Collins up so bad that Collins his eyes,
he lost his vision and he lost his ability to fight.
And so after that fight he became a raging alcoholic and wound up committing
suicide.
Drove into a tree.
I remember that.
I saw that documentary.
It was a really good goodness.
Water and electrolyte drinks are allowed in the corner.
Any electrolyte drink must be brought to the arena in the factory sealed plastic
bottles.
Moreover,
a contestant must provide the commission and its staff with any information
about the request to drink in sufficient time to make a determination as to
whether to drink is approvable.
Example,
no stimulants,
alcohol,
drugs or questionable ingredients.
Examples,
electrolyte drinks that had been approved include pedialyte,
vitamin,
water,
smartwater,
option,
Gatorade,
Powerade and propel.
Huh?
Unless you're an MMA fighter,
is that true?
I mean,
is that what it is?
Isn't the boxing specific boxing dot NV dot.
Co does boxing you have um,
different.
Is that Nevada?
So boxing has different rules.
Is that what it is?
What are you looking for brother?
They have different weight classes.
Is that possible?
That boxing has different rules?
Do you want a real joint instead of that dirty roach?
I'm like,
well,
I'm going to smoke one of the fucking,
what's his name?
I don't want to fuck his
real one.
Wow,
man,
that is,
um,
that's crazy.
Did they stop the fight where we were talking?
Shit,
but it was,
it was at the fifth round.
I thought it didn't go into the fifth,
but I don't remember.
I do remember seeing a four.
He's so gross.
So he said so clueless,
clueless.
Just who's that?
What's that gentleman's name?
John Franklin.
He's the glory promoter.
Supposedly the promoter.
The face of the thing.
So what happened
here?
We were talking so much shit about Gatorade.
We missed the ending of this awesome fight.
What a night.
Boom.
Boom,
boom.
Vargas is really impressive.
He is.
He's just let them get too close,
man.
Yeah.
I remember him fighting on the lion fight cards with me because when we coming
up and then he fought a,
uh,
he's uh,
watching him come up,
him and,
um,
Giovanni Bellini where on the,
on the same cards like,
cause me coming up at the same time with a in California.
So seeing these guys,
he's gotten really good and he's really technical.
He watches,
he always gets his hands.
Come right back.
Robin mentoree smile.
It was just a super high level.
It's a gorilla.
It's a weird how when the Canadians are good at Muay Thai,
they were really good.
Yeah.
Like I just feel like there's not going to be Thai people or really good Thai
fighters.
They didn't
in Canada because it's cold.
Who wants to go there?
I miss some really,
really good,
no serious Mexicans in Canada
go where they can make,
make it to Canada.
We were talking about this Jamaican Gins
in Canada that was shocked.
I remember when I fought Simon,
we had a,
it was like the most,
uh,
talked about fight Muy Thai fight in the u s pretty sure it still is.
And,
uh,
we both started sending these videos back and forth,
like talking shit and like really loose is the first Conor Mcgregor Chell son
and type thing that anybody had done.
And it was a big part of my career.
And,
uh,
we sold out the hard rocket,
the lion fight,
which was like a lion fights biggest,
uh,
gates or whatever had been all three of my fights and two of them were with
Simon.
So we're talking shit back and forth and uh,
he's like speaks with like a Jamaican accent.
But I think thinking he's Canadian and I'm like all us with fake motherfucker,
like all your like have,
you know,
faker accent,
blah blah blah.
And I'm like,
what?
You're one of like two Jamaican people in Canada.
And apparently there's a huge
Jamaican to me.
I had no idea.
Not as a lot of Bahamians and Canada.
I have no idea.
So the Commonwealth nations,
The Bahamas is a Commonwealth nation and most of the Caribbean is,
but I can move to Canada right now.
Oh,
that's cool.
You know,
I can,
I can move to,
can,
I can live there for a long time without,
I still would have to get citizenship or get paperwork done.
But like when the UFC goes to Canada and everybody has to get a visa,
things like that.
I don't have to do that.
Huh.
Interesting.
I can just go there and work.
That's interesting.
But do you have units?
US citizenship.
You have a green card?
Yes.
So they can kick you out of America if you don't like,
if you talk shit about Donald Trump or something like that.
Yeah,
they could
get out of our country.
You don't like our new king?
He's pretty fucking close to being the new tank too.
That's so,
so scary.
Just a couple,
couple of Wiki leaks.
Couple of wikileaks dumps.
I reveal more shit about Hillary Clinton people jump ship.
So I taught,
I do a podcast,
I'm sure dog and um,
I did one with Nick Lancey.
Did you call them plug on the neutral corner?
So I did one with Nick Lens and lenses is,
he's all about um,
what do you call it about Donald Trump?
Nick Lenses.
Yeah.
Really?
It's all he loves Donald Trump not lead us in love.
Donald Trump.
He's not like Donald Trump.
Yay.
But he's so anti Hillary that he's like Donald Trump and this guy's fighting the
establishment.
Uh,
that's where we,
that's the way to go.
It's hard not to feel that way.
I mean,
although I think I'm just going to write in Bernie to be honest with you.
Yeah.
I think I'm,
I don't even know if it's going to count,
but I was still rather write in Bernie.
I was talking to my friends about this and it's because
I don't,
I fucking hate both of them,
but I can't figure out which one I hate more.
And if I did fera which one?
Eight or more.
I don't trust that one.
Not to make me regret voting for them either way.
Right.
I mean,
I think you're screwed either way.
Well,
it's such a problem having someone,
either one of them,
right.
It is a problem,
but it's a problem having someone who is outside of the system,
they'd have to step inside of the system and try to figure out how to make
things happen.
Like I wonder how much,
it would be interesting to see if Donald Trump won,
just based on what happens when someone's a complete political outsider and they
get to a position where they're running for president.
Like Obama was an insider.
He had already been deeply entrenched in the system.
Hillary's obviously an insider.
What the fuck would have happened,
you know,
Bernie Sanders got in.
What,
what would happen if Donald Trump gets in if someone who's really pretty
independent,
you know?
Yeah.
It's,
it's one of those things you have no idea because it's,
is the Senate and the congress going to stand behind them
also be able to pass laws.
Trump says crazy shit.
You know what I mean?
He's,
he says so much shit about like what he would do if like he was president and
Hillary be in jail.
Like it's like you can't,
like you're not the law.
Like you can't just lock her up man.
Like there's a reason why we have this whole system in place.
Like you can't just circumvent that and now that you're the king,
like it doesn't give you ultimate power.
But his perception of it or the way he talks about it is that if he got in he
would have that ultimate power since disturbance.
It is disturbing but it's more disturbing to me because you see guys like Rudy
Giuliani and he supported this bill to get people that are on the terrorist
watch list to have to wear ankle bracelets.
Right,
so you didn't commit a crime,
you're just on a watch list,
but you are being treated like prisoner.
Rudy Giuliani is was trying,
I don't know if he's still,
if that bill is still trying to push forward,
but Rudy Giuliani was trying to push this thing forward a couple of months ago.
What exactly is the fucking terrorist watch list and like how crazy is,
they have a list and you're on the list,
but you're not totally a criminal,
but we think he might be a fucking criminal.
So we're going to put up,
we're going to write you down.
You're on the naughty list and San is not happy with you.
You kick off a plane and you're going to get out on the fucking terrorist watch
list or you can,
if,
if you,
if you go and you look at the terrorist watch lists and you read the names that
are on there,
by the time you get to the end,
your name should be on there.
That's,
that's,
I mean that's how they'd work.
The is why anybody can be on there.
Well there's probably a while it was on there.
Yeah.
Yeah,
because his name is Mohammed Law.
Yeah.
King Mo.
Well there was a,
a woman I believe who was our Green Party candidate who was on the terrorist
watch list or at least she was on the no fly list.
Yeah,
the don't,
the no fly list is funky.
Like they just put you on the no fly list.
Like,
Hey,
wait a minute.
I can't fly,
but I can take buses.
What can I get on a train?
What about about can I get on a boat?
Can I find myself?
Can I go out in public?
Yeah.
What the fuck is that a no fly list?
Hold on man.
Like if you're not going to arrest someone for something,
like how the fuck can you keep them from going places?
You can keep him from flying.
That seems so is it.
Hears it.
You can't fly because we are afraid you're not going to come back or like you're
like a no blame when they're on it.
Yeah.
Well planes are connected to terror,
right?
Especially now because of nine 11 yup.
They're just,
you can't break them away from terrorists,
planes and terror.
They go hand in hand.
One of the ways to stop live stream has ended.
Thank you for watching.
What?
How's that possible main events,
but just start at uh,
six and 15 minutes.
Oh,
is that on this or did we sit through the,
that was at the prelims.
Yes.
It's like a super fight series.
What they called it.
Oh,
so there's another thing for four more fights I think.
Oh my goodness.
I know.
I was like,
I game broadcast on ESPN three,
which is like the Internet thing.
So can we watch this on here too?
It should be.
I'm pretty sure.
Oh No,
I bet it'd be on here.
We still got 10 minutes,
but I don't think we have ESPN three dude doing,
we can get their web,
their web thinks if you have ESPN,
you can just get it on online.
Oh,
uh,
Vargas corners stopped at between rounds.
Thanks for bringing that up.
Okay.
It says Varga versus then rue Smolen but it doesn't say,
it doesn't say anything else.
Oh Man.
Yeah.
Main event is on ESPN three.
Okay.
How do we do that?
Can you do that?
Can you do that for us?
Yeah,
I think so.
Beautiful.
Oh,
that's interesting man.
So essentially it's just like the UFC.
The UFC has those uh,
uh,
fs one and reclaimed pass ones and they have the fs one fights just like that.
So it's just the prelims.
Let me see that.
Oh boy.
Young Jarem.
He's going to sort it.
Oh,
Eve Edwards.
You're really good analyst.
I just want to tell you,
I really enjoy your analysis.
Your grade on the mic,
your,
uh,
you're,
you're really humble for a guy who fought as much as you fought to.
You don't bring yourself into it too much.
And if you do,
it's like really succinct and important.
Like you do an awesome job.
Thank you man.
I was,
um,
I was going to try to not be humble when you said that something smart ass,
but I couldn't
blow it away for you by you saying that to thank you.
Really good man.
You have a real good insight too.
You know,
you're obviously,
you were very intelligent fighter when you're competing,
you are very creative and you know,
you had a very,
uh,
a good,
high fight Iq.
You're very aware of what's going on in at any point in time.
I think that that intelligence style of a you're fighting makes for really good
analyst because you,
uh,
you're not,
you know,
you weren't a guy who tried to overwhelm anybody with power or aggression or
any,
you,
you were,
you was laying traps and setting people up and using really clean technique.
And I find,
you know,
like I said,
Vandelay probably one of my all time favorite guys to watch because you see
what's pure chaos.
But I find that people like yourself oftentimes make really good analysts
because like you're a guy who was like looking at fighting at whether it's MMA,
stand up on the ground,
whatever it was,
you're looking at it at this very analytical level.
It's for me it's like asking questions and that's one of my boxing coaches.
Kenny Weldon used to say that when I fought Aaron the second time,
he watched the fight after the fact and he was like,
I was like,
so what do you think Kenny?
He goes,
that kid has a lot of questions.
It's like,
what do you mean?
He has a lot of questions.
He's like,
every time you do something you're asking them a question and then I'm sorry,
every time he does something he's asking you a question and you're answering him
with like,
I'm going to do this and what are you going to do about what I'm doing?
And he's just asking me,
why are you doing that?
Why are you doing that?
So he's like,
he's saying he's asking all the questions but he has no answers.
So he's asking me questions.
I've been giving him matches and um,
I think that's Kinda how I watched fights or how I fought.
I would try to do something and see what you're doing because of that.
You kind of play with that and feel it and,
and that's how I watch other people fly to watch.
When I watch guys fight,
I'm like,
what is he doing?
Why is he doing that?
Is he trying to set something up?
This guy going to Rhea,
how's that guy going to react to that?
What's he going to do about him?
What's he going to do about his strengths?
He knows he's coming in with these strengths,
so how's he going to try and take those things away?
Or has he just gonna try to impose his own strengths?
I,
for me,
that's what fighting is.
It's be making yourself as comfortable as you can be at all times while making
the other guy as uncomfortable as he can be.
For me.
That's what I,
I tried to look at and I try to see if guys play like that.
How,
how are they going to play that game?
Yeah,
that completely makes sense that you have that kind of style without approach.
You know,
I just always admired the way you would set things up.
You always had a real technical style fund,
which I mean,
like I said,
I admire chaos to,
I admire those Melvin Manhoef dudes too.
You know,
and my,
I admire a Vandelay like maybe more than anybody just because he was so wild to
watch.
But,
um,
I found,
I find that for analysis like Dominick Cruz is another guy I think knocks it out
of the park because he's so,
he's so smart and his assessment of risk and reward and putting yourself in a
position where your opponent doesn't exactly know what you're going to do,
but you know how he's gonna react because you're,
you have this awkward style that you've seen other people react to for a long
time.
But for them it's like this new thing.
They're standing in front of this guy who was switching stances.
And bouncing and moving up and down and back and forth.
And you're not exactly sure what the fuck he's doing,
but he knows what you're going to do.
Yeah.
Because he's so used to doing it to regular people,
like everybody who stands like,
you know,
like certain guys that have that like Moy Thai style and God,
they're getting,
there's so much that they're giving a guy in that situation.
And when you've got a guy like Dominick Cruz,
like he's not predictable at all.
He's like flipping stances and moving around and throwing punches from these
weird fucking angles where you would swear he's doing it wrong.
Right.
Yeah.
It's for me,
I always look at the way someone explained something to me is as the easiest way
to explain it and bad ass grin.
Tyron said Ben Likes to cause scrambles,
right?
That's what dom does.
Yeah.
He's causing scrambles on the feet cause he's,
he's not in a traditional position.
He's not,
and he's not coming at you like everybody else does.
So what he's doing is initiating a scramble right away when you're,
when you get a guy on top of you,
like Rda and he's good at establishing position.
If you can create a scramble,
then you have a better chance of getting out.
Then if you that if you just try to use basic technique and Dominic is
comfortable in those scrambles,
he,
he's been in them so many times.
When you react you have like three or four reactions.
But he has like 22.
Wow.
Damn.
You know,
he did a great breakdown.
A charac from the underground cure genesis.
Yeah.
He uh,
see if he could find that he put it up today.
He put up a,
an article
breaking down all the variables of Dominick Cruz's footwork.
Really interesting stuff because you don't,
until you see it as a list,
like all the different things he does.
And Keurig did an awesome job of,
of just sort of a breaking down all the different things in his fights and it
just makes you realize like,
wow,
that guy's got a lot of options man.
Like someone was,
I think it was Ludwig was saying that he doesn't think he has good technique.
A blanket.
How can you say that though?
Cause you land so many punches.
Like how can you say it?
Like it might not look like everybody else's,
but God damn it's working.
Oh,
I mean it works.
It's crazy how effective it is.
See this is all the stuff that,
that Kirk wrote down,
all the different stuff that Dominic does.
Pretty interesting,
right?
Yup.
A neo footwork is what people are calling it,
right?
It's like a Tj Dillashaw style.
He's got a very interesting style too.
And uh,
I uh,
I hit pads with Dwayne recently.
Dwayne showed me some stuff and one of the things he's doing,
his all,
he's switched stances.
He's doing like these,
you're switching and throwing punches as you're switching.
He's got a lot of this switch stance stuff that he's Rick really incorporating
into these combinations.
And you see it a lot from TJ.
I mean Tj is as comfortable from a south paws.
He is from an Orthodox and he's doing a lot of these switch moves.
Like they're,
they're hitting pads with these and they're very confused.
You know?
So remember when,
when I said I don't like that style,
that Geeky pseudo style because not because,
but Dominic style,
that style I think is the style to beat that.
The reason I say that is because the way Dominic is approaching it,
he's approaching it from a educated,
I would say more educated,
more studious place.
Mm.
These guys are approaching it from trying to get you to buy the wolf ticket.
Ah.
You know,
so they're,
they're giving you these weird looks because that's going to make you get off
balance,
get stand there for them.
Be The guy that's just a target.
But dom is giving you these looks from a fighting perspective.
He's always in position to fight those guys.
When you're,
when you break dancing,
sometimes you're not in position to react.
Dom is always in position to react and that's why I think that style is the
style that beats the other style 10 out of 10 times.
What's really interesting is I don't recall anybody before Dominick Cruz doing
it like that.
I really don't it,
it's a lot of what,
I mean it's limited,
but Muhammad Ali did a lot of things like that with his boxing,
you know?
Yeah.
The rope a dope and his footwork that that's,
that's a part of it.
That's a part of what dom does.
Dom does it for MMA,
so he has to be aware of the kicks tie ups and clinches.
I mean,
how many times you see guys press dom on the fence?
Yeah.
Almost never.
Never.
Very rarely do you know,
the,
the real super fight is him and mighty mouse.
That's the real super fight.
Yeah.
But I mean we saw that you did see it,
but we saw it.
I think mighty mouse is far better.
Yeah,
I really do.
But he's so much smaller,
so much smaller as fact is a fact.
I mean,
he's got to be comfortable fighting one 35 when he was always so much smaller
than those one 35 pound guys.
But from the,
uh,
I think it was the Ian Mccall fight on when Ian Mccall took his back and
battered him.
He's talked about it.
Like that was like the big shifting point where he just realized like,
um,
that he's really gotta be dedicated.
He can't,
he can't fuck this up anymore.
I can't have a full time job.
He can't be taken beatings like that.
And that it was more of the fact that he wasn't putting the time in versus hip,
not having the ability to,
he knew he could fight better than that.
And so then you see him from that fight on slowly emerge as,
I mean at this point,
pretty much the consensus pound for pound best fighter in the world.
Especially now that John doesn't have a license.
John was the other guy that was in the mix for that.
But I think mighty mouse takes less damage,
is destroying more guys more in more of a,
a crazy technical impressive fashion.
Like when he stopped,
so Hutto I mean that was a work of art man.
The clinch work and those knees to the body.
That was as good as I've ever seen anybody beat anybody.
You know?
I mean that was his stunning.
Yeah,
that's,
that's the highest level of mixed martial arts is defense too.
When he went to the ground.
So who don't took him to the ground,
he's got butterflies in,
he's moving,
he gets back up to his feet.
I mean some high level shit,
man.
He and he and Hertz who,
who go to the body,
which is why,
so who don't took him down super,
super high level.
So,
so the reason I,
the reason I think a guy like that gets that good especially so quick is because
he doesn't have a favorite part.
He doesn't like,
he loves the whole thing,
you know,
you know those guys that they're good strikers and they love striking.
So that's what they want to do all the time.
Like no,
he works in everything because for his offense to be as good and his defense to
be just as good.
A lot of guys just want to be offensive.
Guys just want to win in the gym that I just want to get on top and they want to
stay there and they want to control.
So when those guys get put on their back,
they don't really know what to do or they have a much harder time escaping or
transitioning out of that position.
But not a guy like that though.
Those are the best guys in the world.
And you look at,
you look at Dj,
you look at dom,
I mean even Connor,
right?
Um,
the Nate fight is a bad example because that was the first time he was in a
fight in the UFC and,
and he didn't like it the second time he did better.
But at the same thing with chat,
the little bit of a fight he was in with Mendez when he was on his back,
he did some work,
got back to his feet.
He did.
He,
he wasn't so uncomfortable with a,
with a dominant wrestler that on top that he wasn't going to be able to get back
up.
Yeah.
Well,
Connor is,
is definitely evolving.
You know,
you,
you could definitely tell that he's,
uh,
like especially his approach to the second Nate Diaz fight.
He fought that fight,
very smart.
And He survived some moments where it looks like he was gassing out,
or at least he got that opportunity to reset.
If he wasn't gassing out,
he's definitely diminished.
But he managed it.
He managed much better than the first time because I mean,
when he got in trouble that first time,
he did try to change the game.
But when it wasn't in his favor,
it was like,
I kind of want out here lady.
They spear.
I mean,
as a fighter,
I look at that and I'm like,
his spirit kind of broke there.
But he asked for that fight again and then he did it again and he did run into
some trouble and he improved and he fought through it.
The second time he didn't,
he wasn't like,
oh,
this is a real fight.
Now I gotta get Outta here.
No,
he was like,
I'm staying right here.
So I'm excited to see that Conor fight Eddie.
Because I mean,
yeah,
Nate is the same kind of guy.
He's not going to worry about those kinds of things.
But like Eddie is a different beast.
Eddie's that Philly beast.
He's a savage.
So I want to see,
I want to see them get into a fight like not could easily happen to,
it could easily happen.
Eddie Abras the fucking savage.
He really is.
He watched that Hockfield Los Angeles stoppage.
Holy Shit.
The combination he hit him with,
I mean,
and the,
the,
the sheer amount of punches he through the barrage that it took to put them
away.
I mean he had some fucking serious endurance to press the pace like that.
That's the one thing that Connor has been struggling with,
right?
Yeah,
yeah.
With that pace and endurance and,
and Eddie has the power to put that pace on him when,
when Nate gets him tired or it gets him hurt on his feet,
he's got that power and not as dynamic.
He's,
he's a very strong guy too.
Like he's a very strong guy for one 55 I'm looking forward to that too.
I'm curious actually to see what Connor looks like at 55 because right.
We haven't seen him there in the UFC.
We've seen 45 and then you've seen him cut?
No wait and wait like one 69 I think he weighed against Nate.
It would be interesting to see what is Connor look like when he's at one 55?
I mean that might be the perfect weight for him.
It's entirely possible.
We might see a better McGregor at one 55.
I think that's the deepest division.
Yeah,
I think it has been for the longest time.
And that if,
if,
if anybody dominates that division,
like Rda did it for a little,
he looked dominant for a little bit.
Um,
even coming up to the title fight,
he looked like he was going to hold on to that for a while.
Um,
but everybody there so close everybody that way class is so close.
So if somebody does it well,
what about Norma Grumet off because he ragdolled everybody he's gotten in there
with,
that's the one guy you can't say it's close with because everybody,
he's got a hold of,
he's beating the fuck out of that guy is special.
Right?
That's your man off a special.
That's true.
I like,
I like that guy because what you said he special.
Right?
And when you see that special thing,
then I guess people kind of get lost in the void when everybody's close to being
just as good as each other.
Then you kinda just fight to get just a little bit better than the other guy,
just a little bit better than the other.
I just gotta be better than him.
But then when you get the John Jones that comes into the arena and he's,
she's leaps and bounds ahead of everybody else,
then you realize there's a bigger gap and guys start closing that.
Right.
Like a Alyse Alinka Alexander Gusterson.
I mean,
he always fights at that level,
especially when he's in a title fight.
But I don't know if,
if John Jones didn't exist,
if he would rise to that occasion.
Hmm.
What I mean,
he sold.
So somebody's got to show up in the lightweight division at some point like that
too,
to make people raise their level.
Because guys right now,
which is the deepest and toughest division,
but guys are so close and maybe no Maga Madoff is that guy.
Hmm.
Well,
he certainly has been in when it comes to grappling,
like what he did,
the Dos Anjos was,
was pretty stunning,
you know,
because there was like,
man though Sandra,
this is a legit Brazilian Jiu Jitsu black belt,
super strong guy,
really good on the ground and it just seemed like number Grumet off.
Just got ahold of them and just did whatever the fuck you wanted to.
Once we got him on the ground,
just throws dudes around.
It's almost like he's built different,
but he doesn't,
you know,
like if Gleason Tibau was doing that to dude's,
I'd go,
I that makes sense.
Look at that fucking guy.
But when Norma Madoff does it,
it's not necessarily just some overwhelming physical attribute.
It's his technique and his aggression.
Just,
just super fucking aggressive and tight with his grappling and his positioning
his ground and pound his horrific.
He's a scary dude,
man.
He doesn't,
he doesn't even have to think about the way he does those moves.
I remember when you said that and when you say ragdoll on people and Rda,
Rda took that shot on him and he was in the third and he hit him with it.
Uchi Mata basically right from the over Hook whizzer and tripped him forcing it.
And that's not easy throw to hit.
And especially from that range,
it didn't look like it was going to happen,
but he does it to the guy who goes on and become the world champion that way.
And then dominate other guys at that weight class.
Yeah.
Like that guy is special man.
I wanna see,
I wanna see him improve his standup and get and get and just get better.
I want to see him do things like Dj is,
you know,
just working on his weaknesses and get,
cause I mean that guy would never lose.
Imagine if he had Djs,
MMA Iq and skillset,
but his rest with,
with his red,
what is wrestling in ground is now like who's beaten that guy?
I would send guy to fight wars for me.
Yeah man,
look,
he's he rag dolls dudes in a very unusual way.
And you,
every now and then a guy will come up like that that can do that.
And he does it with intensity and aggression.
Like Damien Maia,
rag dolls,
a lot of people too,
especially lately,
he gets a hold of guys like I did with Rick story,
but he's doing it in like this technical squeezy way.
You know when Norma girl Madoff gets a hold of dudes,
it's a smash.
Everything is smash.
He's driving you into the ground,
smashing you into the ground that's smashing.
When you're on top of you.
Damien Maia is just constricting.
He's like moving into position and he slowly closing you off and he's gonna
choke you.
It's a totally different kind of domination.
But then,
I don't know if it's entirely the fairest comparison,
cause Damien is obviously far,
much longer career and he fought at one 85 and he fought again.
It's against Anderson.
He got knocked out by Nate.
He's had a lot of ups and downs in the UFC.
Jake shields beat him.
People forget that Jake Shields essentially out grappled them,
but number coming in off.
Good luck.
Good luck out.
Grapple that dude.
Good luck.
But what's his,
what does it take down?
Percentage like two,
it's probably a million percent.
I mean,
he takes down everybody.
But the other thing about number go Madoff is um,
uh,
that he gets injured a lot and you got to wonder,
is it because of that insane fucking aggressive style of his,
it's so,
it makes it so fun to watch him.
Is that like you're kind of red lining your body too much?
Yeah.
Right?
I mean,
you got arrest,
right?
You gotta heal up.
You can't always be on.
Yeah.
But I mean,
can a guide like a Damien Maia who trains very technically,
I mean obviously he wrestles and he does like a lot of chaotic movements as
well,
but probably not nearly with the kind of intensity the number men off does.
You've got to wonder,
like that style is obviously super effective and very fucking devastating and
fun to watch.
But I wonder if preparing for that style and executing that style is almost like
ultimately too much on your joints,
too much on your body.
I guess the question would be then is can he be no a Madoff without that style?
Like does he have the skill to translate that to slowing it down and,
and,
and turning the volume down.
It's not what you always wonder about when a fighter gets injured,
when someone blows a knee out or something like that.
That and,
and,
and the situation they're training in.
I mean,
you know,
you go into a boxing gym to this day,
you go into a boxing gym and it's sparring day.
You go up the wildcard exploring day and there's only two guys in the ring.
There's only the two guys that are punching each other in the ring.
You go to an MMA gym and on the Mat there you and I work in.
But then Joe and and and someone else or working over here and that guy tries to
take,
take Joe down and he runs into my heel.
Got It.
Does happen all the time.
I think that happened to Rashad Evans.
I think that's how he didn't fight against Shogun for the title.
Wasn't that what happened to Dominic?
Did it happen to him as well?
I wouldn't,
I wouldn't doubt it.
Got It.
So common,
it's crazy because that would be way more safe in boxing and they don't do it in
boxing.
Like in boxing,
it'd be way more safe.
Right.
It'd be much less likely that you're going to collide.
Take downs.
The k the takedown was especially cause you know like as well as I do.
If two guys are going at it,
one guy's defending in,
the other guys weren't really insistent.
They could go all the way across the fucking gym.
Yup.
Everybody's seen it and everyone's like,
Whoa,
whoa man.
And now you have all of these takedown.
What marks all over the mat?
You have just these puddles.
Exactly.
That fucks kickboxing up hardcore.
Those member when they used to have fights where the Matt would have like some
sort of a us some logo on it and they,
before they figured out how to do that right.
Those things would be wet.
It's fucked from the sweat and they would become like ice skating and you just
throw a kick and go flying through the air.
I thought at that I'm king of the cage.
Wet and wild.
That's right.
You did.
Holy Shit.
Tell people about that.
Cause that,
that I think to this day is like one of the all time legendary fight cards.
Do you know about king in the cage?
Wet and wild.
Even school school.
Is She mad king in the cage event and we're,
we're,
we're supposed to fight outside at um,
Soboba is,
you know,
maybe as it's boob.
Is that what came in the cage?
Well,
I don't remember,
but it was a native American casino.
I remember that.
And we were fighting outside king,
all the king of the cage events where outside.
But it starts raining and everybody's,
everybody's ready to fight.
They still ready to put on the show.
I'm king of the cage.
You could wear shoes in Kik.
So basically we went out there and fought in the rain on a vinyl mat.
Ah,
it was even was you,
you fought the Jared,
was that the same Jeremy Williams that went on to fight Nate Diaz or Nick Diaz?
Is that the same guy?
I think so.
The guy was on the ultimate fighter.
Is that the one I'm thinking of?
I'm thinking of the wrong guy and think of the wrong guy.
The Jeremy Williams is the guy that committed suicide.
Oh Damn,
that's right.
I knew that guy.
There's another Jeremy Williams who was the light heavyweight guy,
right?
Yeah.
Oh,
that's right.
He was a good dude,
man.
That was a bummer for a lot of people when that happened.
I didn't really know him.
We,
we kind of stayed in touch of course,
and you see each other at other events and whatnot.
And it was,
I had no beef with him,
so we would keep talking.
Um,
and he always seemed like a nice guy,
man.
He was friends with Chris Brennan.
Yeah.
That's minimum.
Curtis Brennan.
Yeah.
And Chris Brennan,
who's always been a really good dude.
Yeah.
That was a,
a good friend of his,
and I remember that was a,
that was a big bummer when that guy killed himself.
Fucking depression,
man.
Oh,
Duncan Trussell explained to price and really good yesterday he was saying,
you know,
imagine what it's like if you like did it just did a lot of ecstasy and you know
that feeling,
if you've ever done ecstasy the next day where your head is like,
fuck this,
what did I do?
Oh my God,
my brain's drive feel like shit.
But you can get through it because you know it's not going to last.
But he said like,
imagine going through that for 10 years,
you know,
imagine that feel and that's your reality every day for 10 years.
It sounds miserable.
I don't know what x is like.
It's not good.
Well,
it's good when you're on,
when you're off.
It's not good.
It's,
I only did it once and I loved it,
but I was like,
dad is not worth the juice is not worth the squeeze to me at least.
So,
but also I wasn't taking five HTP.
Apparently if you take five HTP right afterwards,
it helps your brain a rebuild.
Do you take after you wake up after you take it?
I think he's supposed to take it like,
like in the middle of it so that like when you come out of it,
you're,
your body's already starting to crank up its production.
If that might be completely unscientific though.
But I do know that the five HTP is supposed to help you.
So you got get no sun x and they get each team.
I mean,
and that's obviously not the best description of depression either.
Sometimes people,
depression is social,
sometimes it's from,
from life events.
You know,
who knows,
who knows what's causing someone to feel like shit.
That guy was a good dude.
He seemed like a nice guy.
I'm thinking of a different guy.
I'm thinking of the guy who fought Nick Diaz.
He was the first guy to stop Nick Diaz and then he was on,
his name was Jeremy,
but I don't think it was willy.
Can you,
uh,
think it was Jeremy Williams?
What I'm x talked about him is inside his name.
I didn't,
I couldn't picture of
the all season,
the ultimate fighter that Nick Diaz was on.
I think that Jeremy Jackson,
Jackson Sherman,
Jackson,
Jeremy Jackson,
Israel.
It wasn't,
was it Nate Diaz?
Nate Diaz is here.
It wasn't nick.
No,
nick fought.
It wasn't on the ultimate fighter.
Nate was on the ultimate fighter.
Goes on the ultimate fighter.
Yeah,
I think it was.
He on was,
no,
it was in the UFC.
It was just in the UFC.
Jeremy was on the ultimate fighter.
Everybody got it.
Nick was him in the UFC,
but nick had fought him before.
Right.
This is it.
This is the fight.
Nick Diaz vs Jeremy Jackson at IFC warriors challenge 18.
Wow.
What year was that?
Play?
That shit.
That was his,
that was his claim to claim to fame on the show that him and Nick Diaz had that
right.
Jeremy Jackson.
That's what it is.
Jeremy Jackson had nasty hands,
man.
He was a really good boxer.
Yes.
Nick.
One time.
I asked Nick one time who is the hardest silver hidden and uh,
he said he didn't say who hit him the hardest.
He just said that Jeremy Jackson hit me.
Hit hard as fuck.
See if you watch like his,
his striking here.
He was good.
Yeah.
He was a good boxer and they were both super young.
I think nick was 18,
if I remember right.
It was,
it was close to it at least.
I think they were both pretty young hair man.
But uh,
and then nick went on to,
I think nick beat him by submission and beat them by decision.
Did he find them three times?
I think they had a trilogy.
I think nick warm,
although,
no,
I don't think,
I think Jeremy stopped him.
Huh?
I think he stopped him in this fight.
I think this was the first fight that nick ever lost.
I think this is the,
actually the only time the naked ever been stopped.
Yeah,
man,
I,
I had heard some crazy rumor that I'd hoped was true that they were going to try
to set up nick versus Connor.
I'm like,
my God,
that would break the world.
Do you know how like insane the hype would be for a Nick Diaz versus Conor
Mcgregor fight?
I mean,
could we even,
can you even imagine how crazy that would be?
So good that,
that that would be like the sequel to,
Oh my God.
Yeah,
a much better bigger my God Avengers movie.
Could you imagine if they do that?
I mean,
look,
the thing is a nick has never making one 55 again.
He's just not,
he's way too big.
It,
he didn't think he could do it.
He could absolutely do it.
He's not that big.
Oh Man.
He looks,
I mean,
it doesn't look small.
he's going to have to lose [inaudible] amount of bonds.
60 I don't think he's ever at eight 55.
That's one.
1655 of the UFC.
I think he fought 55 against Diego Sanchez.
Um,
I think they could say,
could leave one thing niggas ever funded.
55 yes.
Yeah.
Nick fought at 55.
Make Fun of 55 I believe you.
Fuck.
Go me if 55 or do you fight him at 60?
He fought Gomi at 60.
60.
That was pride.
What a fight that was.
Oh my goodness.
That was crazy.
That was when gum,
he was going to go me,
it was just knocking dude's dead.
And Nick took some bombs.
He had that big ass cut on his cheek and he locked up that Gogal Plata.
He fought a lot of,
when we were training for the Anderson,
I was looking over his,
figured he's fought a lot of hitters like in there,
like fucking probably knock him the fuck out of people.
They were like,
okay,
let's match him up.
That was Nick's opponent.
Do you remember when nick knocked out Robbie Lawler?
So we were in the same locker room that night.
Nick and I,
and um,
he was hitting pads with my co with his coach and he was,
he was being nick.
He's back to hitting pads is early in when he was boxing.
So his boxing has gotten much better over time,
but he was hitting pads.
It didn't look awesome.
And he was just,
I'm a knock this mother fucking out.
Yeah,
it's right.
Just get just pumping himself up in the back talking about how he's going to
knock or I'll be out and do all this shit.
And I was just like,
he ain't knocking out nothing.
All those bunches.
And then he went out there and knocked him out with a jab.
What was kind of like a little like a hook.
A short long hook.
Yeah.
With the lead AOL.
So yeah,
Short,
Long Hook with the little,
yeah,
it was like a straight arm,
but it was like a little pop to it.
I was,
I was taken aback dude.
He was talking so much shit before that fight to this day I've said that that
was one of the most interesting things that I've seen as a commentator is like
there's reactions that people have to certain things and sometimes it's
psychological shit.
Yeah.
Like sometimes there's these crazy moments where people like Rhonda Rousey
Gotten Holly Holmes face and it was like,
Whoa,
what the fuck is going on?
Like there's moments where you see in fights where you can do,
I mean don't you feel like that there's,
yeah,
there are times when shit like that happens where you just see that someone,
you,
you see it,
you see who they really are for a split second.
What you see these,
see these,
there's this weird moments when you see someone affected by shit talking.
And Nick got into the cage with Robbie Lawler and you start to go on Stockton
mother fucker stocked and mother fucker and Robbie Lara's like,
what is going on here?
Because Robbie's like a pretty mellow dude,
like Robbie,
super violent.
And a lot of people think he's the Boogie man.
Like people are scared of Robbie cause he's so violent.
I mean he's a incredibly aggressive fighter.
Bad mother fucker.
Right?
But you could see Robbie was like,
what is going on here?
I,
this dude is yelling Stockton motherfucker and two oh nine bitch,
I never knew that.
And then he's standing in and he's going,
what bitch?
What bitch?
What are you gonna do Bitch?
What you gonna do Bitch?
And he's like talking all this crazy shit to him while he's hitting him.
And you could see,
you could see like the effect it was happening.
Like you could see nick,
they were both,
okay,
look at the age there.
Nick was only 20
man.
People forget how fucking young he was when he was fighting at a really high
lookout.
Beautiful.
Bruce buffer is like you went into a time machine
and um,
nick came out and from the moment the fight started,
he's just talking mad shit.
He's pretty yoke.
Then he had that one giant advantage.
Not just like being tough and being crazy like those,
those were good.
He had a real good ground game that people would sleep on.
That was big too.
But it's fucking pace man.
His endurance,
his endurance is insane and his pace is constant.
He's never breaks.
There's no,
no rest.
And it's incredible.
How quickly with SAP guys,
well you could see it just drain them.
What's like,
I think like where I was at 20,
like what I was into at 20 a 20.
He's like that.
He's the kid that was on like the cross country team fucking swim team on the
summertime and you haven't his brother go mountain bike and all day long
as kids,
you know,
and he's funny and cute.
That high level precedent.
Yeah.
Yeah man.
His uh,
his extreme endurance and it's participation and triathlete events and you know,
he's done iron mans I think.
And I know he's,
I think he corrected me.
I said on a podcast once that he had swam back and forth from a Alcatraz
Alcatraz twice.
He said five times.
He's done it five times.
Dude,
I swear he was making fun of them.
I swear to God is big a foot a day.
Like a week ago or two weeks ago we were talking about this and he's like,
they just never done the triathlon.
Never done Alcatraz.
I've done it like four times.
Probably thought,
look,
he's talking to him.
He was like,
what bitch webpage?
He's like,
Nate's never done it.
So he was a pussy because he knows swam from Alcatraz.
Just dude,
that is shark infested water that is legitimately 100% shark infested water.
You're not just swimming,
you're swimming through the habitat of one of the great monsters of earth who he
just clipped him with a right hand there.
This was such an interesting fight,
man,
who was such an interesting fight because I thought of nick before this fight as
really a Jujitsu guy.
I didn't think of him as a striker.
That same here.
That's why I was thinking when he said he was gonna knock this move.
Who the hell?
I was like,
we started getting really good at boxing when he went over to strike for us.
The strike force,
uh,
Virgin Have Nick Diaz who's like,
it's all dailies.
Oh yeah.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
What's an [inaudible]?
Yup.
Got Damn.
See that's the fight.
If I was the guy with the cash,
listen guys,
just do this.
Connor likes fight at one 70.
Guess who else likes fight?
They won 70 nick fucking Diaz.
Come on.
But I mean maybe Nate would get pissed it,
his brothers stepping in and fighting him and Nah,
meaning they seem,
they seem like they're,
they're,
they're one and the same.
This symbiotic man.
But do you think like here,
like this is like 12 years.
The,
there's a shot.
Yup.
Wow,
that's crazy.
Show that again.
There's a short right hook there that's done them.
This is a fun time capsule,
right.
To go back and watch fights from that long ago.
Yeah.
It's funny cause I,
I'm,
I'm working here it comes.
Yeah.
See he had stung them with a punch before that,
before he circled in that dude.
Yeah.
Wow.
That was the birth of Nick Diaz and the UFC.
Really?
That was where people got excited about them.
I roll,
I
rolled with Nate for the first time during that,
um,
that fight week was there with nick.
I just remember it now.
Nate was there with nick.
I went down,
I didn't,
my team wasn't there for awhile and I went down to the workout room.
I was just jumping rope and nick was like,
hey man,
that's all you're going to do.
I was like,
yeah,
my team's not here yet.
He's like,
you want someone to rule with is my brother's here.
So I wrote with Nick and Nate and um,
he's really good.
Then he was like 17 he's really good though.
Yeah.
Do you don't see their ground game dot often cause they're,
they like to strike like the entire last fight with Conor was an almost entirely
stand up fight.
But when you see him,
when he gets guys to the ground,
like the way you went through Connor,
that that whole sequence of beating them up,
taking his back and choking him does very sharp.
It's not,
there's no room,
there's no fat in there.
It's no room in there.
And you can see it.
It was for him,
it was flawless.
It was just,
it was,
he'd done that a million times before.
He has ten thousand ten thousand hours of that.
Oh,
a hundred percent yeah.
Yeah.
And then,
and there's really almost no substitute for that,
but
there's so many fucking good fights to be made now.
I mean,
nobody's even talking about Michael Johnson is going to fight men off Michael
Johnson's.
Right.
That's exciting.
So that's exciting.
This is the first time when the UFC as has put together a card to the two oh
five card for me.
Like in my personal opinion that when they hit pipe,
it is the biggest card ever.
I'm like,
yeah,
I mean,
this is,
this is the biggest card ever,
but there's like four or two or three good fights on it.
Like to be big fights.
This card,
every single fight on this card could main event and a shill.
Yeah.
Like whether it be a fight night or whatever,
every fight on this card can mean of any show.
It really could.
It's crazy.
Yeah.
It's an,
it's a nutty card.
There's three world title fights and there's so many great fights.
Like the number of growing off Johnson fight.
Rashad is fine.
10 Kennedy,
there's a lot of good fights on that card.
Tiago Alvarez.
Yeah.
Whose Shadow?
Fighting again?
He was supposed to fight I Quinta.
They changed it.
That's right.
But who,
uh,
who replaced yet?
Here it is.
Where is it?
Where's Tiago office?
Oh,
that's good.
To Hell.
That might be just as good that,
um,
I hated hearing that though.
That ally acquainted thing.
Yeah.
That was a bummer.
You know,
I don't know what the full story is.
I don't know either,
but I'm a fan of I aquanto he's a fun dude to watch.
There's a lot of guys out there.
I mean
it's crazy because this,
this is,
I feel this is the first generation of,
of guys that have come up as MMA fighters the whole time,
the whole way through.
Even even Nate being as young as he is,
he still,
he was still a Jujitsu guy coming into this,
but there are these kids now that a fight like Mossad backtick.
I feel like Massaad is one of those guys that he started training MMA.
Yeah.
And when you're doing that,
how important is it to find the right coach?
The right coach is so valuable.
Yeah.
Because how many guys can give you that full sort of for Rasa Hobby,
Matt Hume sort of experience or they've got black belt level or Jujitsu,
like real worldclass striking.
They really know what the fuck they're doing and they understand the game deep,
deep in and out.
Yeah.
There's only a small amount of those guys and it's not a coincidence that like
the,
the great ones like Demetrius Demean Demetrius gives up all of his credit to
Matt Hume.
You know,
I mean it's like he found a guy who was a pioneer of the sport who was a real
high level Moy Thai guy,
real high level,
a a black male in Jujitsu and competed at a real high level in Japan.
He,
nobody fought well the fans.
Yeah,
but he um,
he fought pat Miletich remember that he stopped pat military in an MMA fight.
Like mad Hume in his day was a bad motherfucker.
So it only made sense that he would also become a great coach.
But how many of those guys are there like that?
Like that's got that kind of Matt Hume type experience and understanding of the
sport.
It's coming now now,
right?
Because of of guys from my generation like Dean Thomas and Mike Brown.
Right,
right,
right.
Yeah.
Josh.
Josh Thompson is about to be retired.
He or he's closer to retirement.
Then some of these younger guys,
these guys are,
shoot,
there's so many guys now that at that point and this next generation of guys are
going to know they're not going to have to go to a Jujitsu gym and then to a
kickboxing place.
You know they're going to have these coaches that know the game that they are
teaching them mixed martial arts and not teaching them individual parts of it.
Don't you think there's still going to be specialized coaches though for each
individual thing?
Yeah,
for sure.
Because because those guys from that generation know that hey they,
they're good at it altogether but there are still parts of it that they are not,
their rating is not going to be a hundred.
Right.
Well like Duane Ludwig is probably a real good example of that because obviously
Dwayne,
Dwayne kickbox had a real high level.
He,
he's excellent MMA fighter and when you watch like what he's coaching,
he's primarily coaching,
striking,
you know,
he understands ground game very well.
I mean he did submit people,
I don't know what is Brazilian Jiu Jitsu belt is,
but I'm sure he's very competent on the ground.
But Dwayne is more of a specialist in the striking than anything else that he
does.
So it only makes sense that you would want to have a guy like Duane where that's
where his brain works.
His brain works on these combinations and you'd want to like,
yeah man,
do that.
Like fucking definitely keep doing that cause he's going into these crazy deep
places with his techniques and his movements and his ideas.
Dwayne's got,
he's got,
he's got all these systems written down like,
like a lot of his,
his uh,
style is documented as opposed to like,
a lot of people just have it in their head.
You know,
they have all their moves and their head,
they'd have the,
what they do in their head.
Ludwig's got all this shit written out.
He's a freak man.
Again,
the best,
most complimentary way possible.
But he's a freak.
Yeah.
Cause see when,
when,
when Trump becomes president
and then society falls and,
and we get buried under ashes.
A thousand years from now,
somebody's going to find that manuscript and recreate the Duane Ludwig neo
footwear style of striking and they're going to build statues of,
Dude,
you make me scared of the election office.
You're in California.
You got to register to vote.
You have two more days.
I think folks,
I really think with both those guys,
you've got to put your wore pants on.
Both people running.
Yeah.
Well you could vote for Gary Johnson even though he doesn't know what it,
Oh,
is it?
I didn't know what Aleppo is either.
Apparently there was a good fight going on here that we completely and totally
missed.
That dude looks so much like Chris Kamozi.
It's crazy.
Yeah,
it was that Chris Carozzi.
His brother can't be,
no,
we're going to say I lost my train of thought.
You Sea Bell Gar Rui versus Ariel Machado.
Wow.
Hmm.
We didn't watch this fight for a second.
As so often is the fire campaign.
Middleweight is a middleweight tournament.
So this is the first round in the middle of a tournament
tournament for tonight.
And then the next one is,
uh,
at a senior.
Yeah.
Style bender stub in there.
Do you know style bender?
I know of him.
I don't,
I don't know personally.
Fun Guy to watch fight.
Yeah,
he's a,
I'm really interested to see how,
how this goes.
Yeah,
me too.
He's super technical.
I've seen a bunch of his shit online and he's sort of dabbling in an MMA as
well.
He's thinking about fighting him.
He's working hard and doing anything and gets up,
but he's just like fighting.
I'm like the China show so I haven't seen like the,
like the similar competition or whatnot.
So I'm interested to see how those go.
And then Robert Thomas is a got a slower,
I fought him.
He was slower but he fucking,
he's got like a granite chin.
He's got a cabbage face.
Like I hit that guy so fucking hard and like he took it.
Wow.
I was thinking about the cabinets face.
That's fine.
You mean that the most common,
the nice guys.
Good guy.
He's a very,
he's these very talented Simon and Marcus.
When you said that guy he's starting to do,
I'm getting into some MMA.
When you look at like kickboxing at this level?
I think like they should,
if they want to get an MMA kickboxing and take like a year and really straight
most of the time wrestle.
No.
Yeah,
play with the submission.
Played the submission game and just learn it,
understand it.
But learn how to wrestle right first like after their kickboxing.
Because when you can wrestle and you're comfortable and confident and throwing
your keys,
throwing out your real kickboxing skills
and feel confident that you can defend,
take downs and if you do get taken down,
you can get back to your feet then.
Cause that's what MMA is now.
I mean the submissions,
if you get taken down,
the only time you're,
you're seeing guys stay on top of the icing and control position is when the
other guy can't really wrestle.
Hmm.
You know guys,
you have decent takedown defense when they do get taken out and they work back
to their feet.
Unless you're fighting Damien Maia.
Exactly.
Then you're getting taken down by a ball constructor and know he's,
he what he did a Rick story.
I remember watching that going,
I did not think we were ever going to see that.
Like stories such a gorilla.
I mean he's such a such a physically strong kid that to see Damien get ahold of
them and just constrict,
he just constructed them,
got to his back,
got ahold of his neck,
neck,
cranked him.
And that was a wrap.
I mean the way it did it,
it was a stunning,
the way he did that Carlos is stunning,
stunning,
stunning.
I didn't expect,
I expected him to be better than Carlos and the ground by probably by a big
margin too.
But I didn't see him just kind of walking there in my eyes.
It's a testament to the ground game of Roy MacDonald because Rory Mcdonald got
taken down by Damian in the first round and it,
a lot of it was Damien on top of him in the mouth and he defended,
he defended,
got back to his feet and then beat his ass in the second and the third rounds
just stand up.
You know,
Rory underrated ground game.
Who did you fight and he fought someone in Metamorris.
What was it like?
Jt Torah is like someone who was really good and he got caught in a Kamora and
he's got his arm all fucked up and he would,
he didn't tap,
I'm trying to remember who he fought but he went to,
you know what they call a draw at those,
cause they don't really have scores if you don't,
if you don't submit the guy that goes to a draw.
Is that who it is?
Yeah,
it's JT Torres and Torres is super high level kid in the grappling scene,
you know,
I mean he's a,
he does really well in like high level black belt matches in the grappling.
So for him to step in like that for Rory to do that,
while he's a professional MMA fighter and a take on this kid,
super impressive.
And he hung in there.
I mean look at him.
He's attacking leg locks here.
They're both
exchanging heel hooks.
I hate you.
I hate looking at heel hooks.
I know,
right?
You're waiting for that to sound like crack,
crack,
crack.
I know that he doesn't get finished with this.
He look,
I still don't want to look at it and know.
Right.
Cause guys get hurt even though they don't get finished.
Yeah.
Like you don't know that they're hurt and they keep fighting and there's some
inflammation and later they realize there's a big ass tear and they're MCL or
something.
That shit happens all the time.
And then you walk in,
you feel it when you try to walk up the stairs.
Have you ever had a knee surgery?
No.
No knee surgeries as fortunate.
That's incredible for a kickboxer.
That's incredible.
I've been lucky.
Damn,
that's a mate.
Well you must do it smart.
Too Smart.
I mean it Kinda also,
it seems like my thing going,
what was my question about a guy like Nigga Madoff who has that insane pedal to
the metal style,
whereas you who,
although you had a very aggressive style,
it was very well thought out.
It was,
there was,
it was very technical and your approach,
it's not like I'm planning,
I don't got the ant the idea,
I'm going to be technical.
That's just how my brain works,
I guess.
You know what I mean?
Only because I understand that well enough to do it that way.
And this is not to insinuate the number of office and technical know.
Obviously he's,
yeah,
he's super technical,
but he's aggressive with that.
Yeah.
He,
he'll just kind of come after you and go while and it turn that,
turn the heat up all the time.
I wasn't,
that guy is angry.
Yeah.
That's a good way to play it.
You know,
you don't,
you're it,
you,
you fight calm and collected.
This dude fights calm and collected.
I hate to segue like I'm a fucking professional announcer here,
but a style benders.
A bad motherfucker.
He looks real smooth.
I really enjoy watching him fight and I've been looking forward to this fight in
particular.
He's um,
he's a fun dude.
He's fun online too.
He wrote some funny shit about a Brendan shop and a,
there's two girls were having a pillow fight and Brendan chavs concerned they're
going to get CTE.
It was fun.
He's funny,
man.
He's a funny dude.
Yeah.
I guess like he listens to the fighter and the kid and maybe Brennan shop's been
talking too much about CTE,
but he was just being hilarious for Chabad,
want to help these girls diagnose for CTE.
But um,
he's,
he's like,
in my opinion,
when it comes to kickboxing,
he's the epitome of technique,
you know,
of uh,
of,
of a technical fighter.
And he's also super creative.
I like watching them fight like hell.
He moved.
Yeah,
very technical.
He's very smart the way he fights and he's also extremely capable.
You know,
he's,
he's got some extreme towns.
Should be interesting because like you said a Joe,
he's been fighting in China a lot,
right?
Yeah.
Law Just Europe over there.
He gets paid a lot to fight over there I guess.
And um,
yeah,
now he's making his way to glory,
which is,
I guess this is broadcast everywhere,
right?
We're on ESPN three,
we're watching it right now,
but where,
what are the parts of the world where they have like 120 countries at?
Gloria's got there.
They're bigger assets are overseas.
I guess.
I was so psyched when it got on a UFC fight pass.
Yeah.
Oh so fun.
Just to be able to watch,
like throw it up in the gym,
get motivated.
So,
um,
oh cause it's just saved up there so you can yeah,
I just DVR.
Yeah.
You go to,
yeah.
it's like a DVR.
Well I wasn't aiming rather,
I wasn't thrilled about it because the sponsors sponsors.
Yeah.
When I was fighting on it.
And then because it was just,
uh,
he don't get ratings for oh,
for fight pass sponsors.
Yeah.
Right,
right,
right.
You wouldn't even know how many fucking made watch Hulu or if anybody tried to
explain it to a sponsor is like explaining,
like go to the GFL.
Dot.
Come and watch me.
There's a lot of people that have fight pass,
but there's a lot more people who don't have bypass.
You know what I'm saying?
Like,
fight pass is awesome.
And if you're a,
if you really are a,
a,
a fan of MMA and you can afford the scratch,
how much does it cost?
How much does flight path that is so cheap.
Super cheap.
That's super cheap or cheap.
It's worth it.
Like if you're a big time fan and if you're just becoming a fan,
like that's where it's even crazy.
Dude,
you missed out on all the great shit
but it's like a awesome,
awesome deal.
Cause all the INVICTA fights a little life flights,
all the fucking shit that for everything.
I had this,
I had this crazy idea one time I thought silly idea to um,
make you able to make play lists on fight pass,
you know.
Well I'll have some,
some people's playlists like
some,
some of your favorite fighters playlist on fight pass because of the fights that
inspired them to come and do this thing.
Yeah.
Dude,
that's a great idea.
That's a great idea.
That should be an option.
Like a,
on your fight pass,
you should be able to have a star and you can add it to a,
uh,
added to a collection.
Yeah,
dude,
that's slick.
I like that.
Then you would like be able to find like what,
what would don Frye pick?
You know what I'm saying?
Well goods,
Don fries all time favorite fights.
You know,
it's going to be a slobber,
knocker
style bender.
All kinds of weird ads on his shorts.
What's up with those shorts that just has a lot of,
I thought that was a bunch of flags.
Like a tiger tiger,
a pink tiger.
What do you see in here?
Joe talked us through this at the coochie shorts.
Ooh,
beautiful.
Beautiful question.
Mark kick.
What do you see in here Joe?
When you watch them?
Uh,
cause you know Thomas,
right?
Yeah,
you fought him.
He had a,
Thomas is a,
as actually the right now is watching.
Thomas looks a little different than he's got a little more head movement.
Uh,
and he's more of a boxing stance.
Ooh.
Thrown decent punches.
He used to have these,
like Thomas used to have this overly Thai style and I mean it's like these guys
that try to fight and try to mimic and copy a traditional Moitai.
Hmm.
And uh,
at one it doesn't work when you're that big in my opinion.
And it in this style of rules is not good.
Interesting.
Suppose the kickboxing,
why do you think it doesn't work when you're that big?
Because a traditional way time,
when I say that is all about like body cakes and it's like a very upright,
you stand very,
very upright and it's a slow pace thing.
And I think that the guys that are creative that uh,
you know,
makes their punches and the kicks up and we used different movement have more
like an American kickboxing style or a Dutch kickboxing style,
a different style than the traditional way ties route I think is more effective
than the rules are set up for that.
Well why do you think it's more effective with people that are heavier though?
I'm just going to slow.
Slow.
Interesting.
So,
so like the,
the guys who are shorter or the smaller guys that was a nice light tech.
The guys who were smaller,
like the
elite guys at the lighter weight classes,
they could,
they could move quick enough to pull off that upward stance.
Yes.
So the whole,
like if you think about like Moitai like it was designed as like a martial arts
for a bunch of people that are 135 pounds.
Right?
Cops,
you know,
but the,
and the way the rules for traditional Muy Thai does the slow paced five round
fight.
It's like a really slow pace.
It's all about um,
uh,
way slower pace.
It's about gambling.
It's just really different.
And we'd go watch it and then they tried to copy it and then they a fight at a
slow pace going to send you just cracked him.
Is it about being tougher?
Like the traditional style?
Is that,
does that Kinda what you mean or no,
not at all.
No.
It's like,
why?
Like it seems like I,
when I think about it,
traditional Thai style,
it's Kinda screaming up and throwing straight straight shots and trying to land
that hard kick to the body.
Robert Thomas looks way different.
What looks different about him?
He's like,
wait a lot more.
Turned into his stance.
He's got way more of a boxing stance as opposed to having like where he had
before.
He was really squared up.
Uh,
he's sitting down in his punch.
He's sitting down.
Where so you see a lot of improvement?
Yeah,
I mean,
yeah,
for my liking and then uh,
he's being a lot more aggressive with his hands.
So it really good glory.
37,
Los Angeles,
January 20th.
Um,
you said lion fight is on fight pass.
Is it on fight pass?
I think.
I think I heard a couple of really?
Yeah.
I didn't know lion fight was on it too.
I thought they were,
I could be wrong,
but I'm pretty,
I don't think I am.
What's so funny,
I was just as like,
if Abella Toy fipass
poor bell.
How do you guys see this fight somewhere?
Uh,
it's interesting Thomas.
like you said,
he's definitely,
it seems to me he looks like
a better fighter than he was when he fought you.
Thomas used to not like use his hands like aggressively.
So I didn't think he did.
And I told him after the vice work on his boxing line,
but he used to be all about like this step up me and this body kick and I
haven't seen him try to do that at all.
And He's thinking much,
sit sitting down a lot better and it stands.
I don't know if he's winning on points or not,
but
hey Janice,
you say it out of Sonia.
I've been saying,
how have I been saying I didn't know how to say it.
I said
the shorts are dope though.
Yeah.
It's like I look kind of like fuck.
I see it's stuck on my brain now because monitoring.
Well I think you know Robert Thomas looks good here.
What are you going to say?
Oh,
the body.
Nice.
Damn.
Ooh,
the solar plex.
I don't know.
It might be it.
Yeah,
that was a bad one.
Wow.
He got back up at nine Taylor.
That was a tough one.
Jesus Christ.
This claim.
I don't cause I'm like,
it wasn't like trying to fight on ballot though.
So no fight bath of gobble everything.
I know,
right?
It's cool to put everything in one spot.
It's like Netflix.
I personally route for Bella tour.
I really do.
I think it's good for everybody to have more events.
I think it's good for the sport.
It elevates a sport.
I don't think it's bad for the UFC.
I think the UFC is giant.
It's only going to get bigger.
I don't think it's bad that Bella toward does good.
And I think it's great the way there,
what they're doing now where they're taking fighters who you know did well in
the UFC and maybe it didn't work out for them or maybe they decided to try to
chest her options like Rory Macdonald,
Phil Davis,
you know,
they're developing a real roster.
Yeah.
And Lori's Worldclass,
he's a worldclass welterweight in anybody's book.
What happens because of that is because now you bring these guys with that UFC
level experience cause it's all,
yeah.
Some of those bell told guys can walk right into the UFC and do well Michael
Chandler.
Yeah,
exactly.
But not all of them.
Right.
But when you bring that UFC level experience back to the Bella cage,
then that rate,
that's the same thing that I've seen before about that void.
There's a point now these guys can raise their level.
Some the guys that aren't there,
but they're in that environment.
Right.
You would know this.
You're in the loop.
What happened with Ben Ascaris [inaudible] why did he not go back to bell tour?
He was the champion.
Like that's so rare that a champion leaves with the belt and winds up going and
fighting somewhere else.
Yeah.
I don't remember at all.
I know I asked them about,
oh how convenient.
No,
I vaguely remember,
he's the one guy that troubles me the most out of all the people that are not
competing right now in the UFC.
He's the one guy that troubles me the most because,
uh,
I would want to see what he can do.
I want to see what he can do.
He's,
I mean,
people say that his style is boring or that they don't like it cause he just
gets on top of guys and becomes a blanket and punched him in the face.
Mike.
Yeah,
but he can do that.
Like,
don't you think it's imperative that we show what can be done?
Like can he do that to Damien Maia?
I want to know who we can do it too.
I want to know who we could do it too.
And there's only one way.
Look,
he's done it to a lot of people.
Look what he did to Korskoff.
You know how,
what a bad motherfucker cars cough is,
right?
Yeah,
man,
man.
Manhandle them a have them.
I'm really on that.
A lot of dudes,
he mugs him.
That's what you do.
That's the fight.
You bring him into the UFC to flat.
Yeah.
Put Him in Damien Maia is a coal main on,
on,
on a,
on a bank card or or put him with a,
uh,
exciting young kid who's going to come after him,
you know,
put them in their own.
Yeah.
There you go.
Mike Perry.
Someone.
Someone who's going to do something crazy.
Go out and throw wild punches at him.
Make it up.
Make it a fucking scrap look.
One of his toughest fights in Belterra was Jay Heran.
Yep.
Right.
Jason Wrestle.
Yeah.
Jake and Russell.
Jay's,
uh,
he's a very good MMA fighter and he can wrestle and so that he was better in the
striking then.
Then aspirin was at the time.
Right.
But asking to strike,
he's not that bad either.
He knows how the fuck get away from Shit.
Yup.
And when he gets a hold of guys,
he takes him down these ways that just not expecting,
I really want to see him in my,
and now fuck.
Yeah Dude,
I want to see him in a lot of guys.
I want to see him in Wonderboy.
That's what I want to see.
I mean,
wouldn't you want to see that?
Can you take that dude down?
Can you get ahold of them?
Can you get past those kicks?
Like what's going gonna?
What's going to happen there?
Fuck man.
It's like there's not a whole lot of guys that are specialists in and that's
much of a pure sense as he is.
He's a wrestling specialist and he's a real world class wrestler and anytime
there's a guy like that out there for me,
it's just like shit.
Yeah.
Especially when when they come in with a different style of that specialty,
like askern style isn't the same.
I mean,
no magna Madoff is a specialist as a wrestler,
but [inaudible] style is different.
Exactly.
African style is just bizarre.
It just holds onto guys and weird way.
Nice.
And he just seems so much stronger than he looks.
He's very interesting man.
But just,
I hate to bring that up again,
but the only reason why I do is because I am a fan of the sport.
I'm a big fan of the sport and I don't think the sport is the most exciting
shit.
I think the sport is the sport.
If there's something that's not as exciting but is more effective,
that's still a part of the sport and you can't ignore that something just cause
it's convenient for your vision of what makes a sport dynamic and exciting
because then stopped the sport anymore because then it's the sport plus
entertainment.
But this guy's going to stink it up.
We're going to keep them on the outside and he might not,
I mean it might be Jay hair on squared.
You get him in with or with someone like a wonderful boy or Tyron Woodley or
someone along those lines,
you know,
entire name.
They know each other.
Go right there.
Their teammates,
they fight.
No,
no,
they wouldn't.
I don't think they would fight.
I doubt they would fight even for the belt.
Wow.
Well that would be an interesting fight if they weren't that good friends
stylistically because Tyron is a really good wrestler too and that,
but they know power.
He know each other to.
I think I honestly,
in an MMA fight,
I think it's bad for Ben simply because they know each other so well and Tyron
is more explosive with the striking.
Oh,
oh,
oh ow.
I say that style bender.
It's no joke
standing up
just 15 seconds ago.
He's going to survive is caught.
Shit.
Okay.
Whoa.
Beautiful combination there.
Oh right hand.
Ooh,
Ooh
short.
It's a dope as fuck they are.
It's a fun guy to watch man.
It good fight.
Okay.
Robert Thomas look a lot better though.
Good.
So that was a round one of the tournament for him.
Right.
So he might have to say if he wins this then he fights in the next year.
Who won?
Who were paying attention?
We weren't paying attention to at all.
Not even a little.
Jamie Solomon.
Paul,
this is another fight that I'm really interested in or style matchup I'm really
interested in is that explosive speed of tiring versus that slow methodical
style of Maya too.
That's another one.
Like kitten.
Can he take tire it down?
That's in here.
Get to Chiron and you're going to have to go through hell to get to them because
there's no question in the world,
there's no question in my mind at least the Tyron moves far faster,
right?
So he's a very difficult to get ahold of grappler,
right.
Anyway.
Right.
Very good wrestling.
And then he moves far faster and he's got thunderous power.
So mine is going to have to take chances.
So in taking those chances,
close that distance,
he's,
he's not kicking specialist either,
so he's going to be taking those chances with his hands and you're just going to
run into these potential counters,
especially in the first round for,
for anybody.
Tyron is the scariest and the first round because he just has so much speed and
explosion and I think it takes,
guys were surprised they day to my surprise.
And it probably takes them at least around or about around to adjust to that
speed.
At the very least,
there's been some knock outs like the Josh,
Tom,
Josh Koscheck knockout.
Remember that one?
Yup.
Oh my goodness.
Just,
just a fucking bomb over the top.
Yeah.
The way,
the way he was.
I can picture it in my head and the way he's standing up over him in that,
in that it's kind of scary.
It looks scary when you see,
cause they're both,
it looks like two superhero has just gotten into a fight.
Yeah.
Yeah man.
Caustics another guy.
What a fucking accomplished wrestler.
That guy was four.
You got an MMA,
you know,
super high level wrestler.
That kid Gregory Gillespie.
That kid is legit good,
really good wrestler,
you know,
really good.
He's a four time all American and he's um,
national champion.
This guy before,
um,
I met him.
Everybody else was like,
I was going up there to train and everybody's like,
yeah,
when you could get what Gregor man,
he's,
he's a beast on top.
I went up there for about three weeks.
First go,
we go,
he takes me down.
I'm like,
all right,
cool.
This guy's supposed to be a beast on top.
And I get up,
I get up on the very first try.
Right.
It was the last time I got up for three weeks.
I went to Japan
for three weeks.
Three weeks.
I,
I couldn't,
I couldn't do anything when he was on top of me.
Wow.
I couldn't do anything.
Nothing.
There's dudes like that.
He's really good.
Bam.
Yeah.
There's like what we're talking about,
about specialists or people that just have that higher level.
Well that's one of the things that always intrigued me about aspirin.
I said Pedis would say like,
I couldn't fight that dude.
That dude,
he just holds me down.
Do whatever the fuck he wants to me.
I want to see the Ma.
I want to say Ben used to like,
he,
I met him when I first met Tyra and I went up to Missouri to train and um,
we were retiring,
took me some time to some tournament and Ben was,
he was just going out and pin and dude,
I mean,
he's pinning like college level wrestlers in the first period.
Sometimes like,
quickly,
um,
Dean Dean says to me the first time he met Ben or they'll order,
the first time he worked out with Ben,
he's like,
Ben,
just asking him goes,
do you know what a sprawl is?
Like,
like he just,
he couldn't do anything about what Ben was doing to him.
So he didn't know.
Ben Didn't know if he knew how to sprawl.
Like Dean Thomas doesn't know how to sprawl.
Wow.
That's how good he is though.
Right.
And how good he is.
Did you ever see when he rolled Marcello Garcia?
Yup.
Marsala just tap,
tap,
tap them.
Marcel is just so freakish,
you know his Jujitsu,
especially in his prime.
So Freakish.
Oh I saw that as a beast dude.
Yeah.
I was in Brazil when he emerged on the scene in 2003 when he fought a Shaolin
and choked him out.
He got his back and then in the rolling and spinning he put them to sleep.
Like as,
as Shalon was trying to defend,
he's getting his back and I believe he got them from the side.
I think he'd wind up like rear naked,
choke him from the side and that's how he put him to sleep.
But it was just Shaolin refusing to tap cause nobody even knew who Marcello was
back then.
And that was like one of his most impressive,
like early on victories like that to this day is one of my all time favorite
submission victories that I've ever seen anybody uh,
perform because it was just so explosive and fast and final put them to sleep.
It's very rarely see a high Lynn high level guy like Shaolin he barrow get put
to sleep,
you know,
and that was the first time we'd ever seen Marcello Shaolin was one of those
guys too.
Like when he came to MMA,
he was one of those dangerous guys.
Oh yeah.
Super high level grappler.
Yeah.
I mean,
uh,
and this was the Abu Dhabi 2003.
Jamie.
See if you can find that Marcello Garcia vs Shaolin.
It's only,
it's not a fast fight.
I mean,
it's not a long fight at all,
I should say.
Match fighters get mad.
Jujitsu guys call it fights.
Fires like to match Bro.
Dot.
A fight.
But a boxing match is a fight to,
isn't that a fight?
Here it is.
As he takes his back like this,
you get hit.
That's a fight.
This is a match.
It takes his back and he chokes him here.
Like sideways.
Yeah,
that's he put them asleep.
This is,
um,
boom.
I was final.
This was,
nobody knew who Marcello Garcia was.
Everybody knew shall Lynn was,
you know [inaudible] I remember that.
Uh,
hearing about his name right after that,
seeing that video.
Yeah,
I remember that.
Play that shit again Jamie.
It was crazy.
Do it like,
yeah,
right from there.
Okay.
No,
the thing about Marcella was that arm drag to the back was just so unstoppable,
so unstoppable.
He would get to that position,
man.
It was just so tight.
Look at he's,
he's essentially
one hook and he's like on top on the side.
These get them spun around and flattened out.
Cheat back.
Yeah.
He was chest to back and he act like he stopped him from rolling out of it
perfectly.
It was just death,
like the way spinning and trying to resolve.
Never at least have that chest the back.
No,
never.
He's squeeze something else,
man.
Oof.
That is one of my all time favorite submission victories,
but just because of the,
the finale to it,
but also the,
the fucking ruthlessness of his technique.
He had both things going on.
It was like,
he had an incredible technique and aggression
and perfect,
perfect timing and perfect positioning.
Fuck,
that's amazing.
And again,
Shaolin,
he did it to a beast,
you know,
it wasn't like to some regular person,
he was,
um,
he was at American top team for awhile and it sucks because like all my training
partners beat me up.
I'm training with myself that he's training for an MMA fight over in Japan and
I'm training for a fight and we're going and I'm keeping it standing.
I'm defending takedowns,
I'm winning the round and Conan goes 30 seconds and I'm like,
30 seconds.
Yeah,
I've dominated this round.
Okay,
now let me be strategic.
I'm gonna take him down,
secure the round and you know,
kind of put it out there.
This is the judges that I'm not afraid of his ground game,
you know,
just kind of playing the game in my head.
I shoot a shot and on the way down he reverses me and he taps me before the
round is over,
like
was like,
this is garbage.
This is bullshit.
He,
he's ridiculously good.
Is he the best guy you ever roll with?
Absolutely.
By far.
I mean,
Matt Lindland was like,
like,
I can't do anything that I got just a gorilla.
He's so,
he's so good.
He's really good,
man.
That's interesting.
That's really good.
Like,
like I would love to see him and Omega Madoff not necessarily in a fight,
just in a wrestling,
grappling situation.
Sambo situation.
I would just love to see that.
I don't know.
I've never trained with Tomago meadow of,
I don't know how good he is.
I'm sure he's great because of what he,
I seen him do,
but I would just love to see that.
I know his wrestling is probably the best in the UFC right now,
so I'm a guy like that,
but I know some really good wrestlers that get destroyed by Marcello.
Yeah.
Like Ben ask him like we were talking about in that video was actually rolling.
Well Marcello's got that fucking insane.
Squeeze man,
the guillotine squeeze.
He's got a nasty north south squeeze.
He's got his back
takings legendary.
His is so good at that arm drag.
That arm drag is just,
and before he was pulling it off,
like the way he was doing it was really rare to see somebody that specialized on
it like that or they just specialize on hey that arm drag and getting to the
back,
hidden that arm drag to get to the back,
you know?
And then he's doing it from butterfly guard.
He was a,
it wasn't doing it like a wrestler.
Really interesting guy
and a big ass giant fucking legs.
Right.
You're not big arms like his arms are kind of normal sized big ass giant legs
like fat boy.
I mean they muscle jump over just like round dude.
They're huge.
He's all legs.
It's really interesting like that.
That is one thing that I think is like super underrated.
It kind of in all of any,
any sort of combat sports,
the size of your legs is so gigantic.
Like the power in your legs rather.
The ability that your legs have like look at Pac cow's legs,
that dude as these giant ass golf ball or a tennis ball,
calves that fucker.
Yeah,
you were looking at mellow pets.
Calves.
He can't like can't,
he can't wear like normal pay.
You can't pull it up over his cat socks.
Just ridiculous.
Yeah.
Sanchez.
Same thing.
Giant ass calves.
Like can you go back and think about Tyson?
One of the things about Tyson that was so fucking impressive is his legs.
He would leap at you and throw bombs at the same time and they're just coming up
from the ground.
I mean there's so much horsepower behind that and a lot of that was coming up
through those giant ass fucking legs.
Really.
You know,
really interesting when you think about it from Marcel,
does the query,
which guide guide the audience
would think about it with Marcella,
what's interesting is he's securing you with those legs.
Like when he's taking backs.
Like that's his big thing,
right?
And then get teens as well.
He's using those,
that incredible leg power to secure you to secure you and to get you controlled
by those lay.
Yeah.
Like you see the way control Shaolin on the ground,
the end of it.
He's a smushing everything.
It's all that power that allows him to get the chokes off better.
I think.
I feel like it's,
it's one of those things where he's,
he's figured out just how to use exactly the right amount of muscle in the right
direction to control you with his leg.
Like using his legs.
His a hand grab.
Yeah.
But like same thing with like a specialist,
like no Madoff.
Same thing with a specialist like Damien Maia.
I feel like they have that ability to change the little details and use them,
use their body the perfect way to make that specific thing work.
Yeah.
You know the other thing that's interesting about Marcel is he doesn't,
he doesn't utilize any strong person moves like you won't do Camorra's.
He thinks Camorra's are a strong person move.
He things like grabbing the Garmin Yankton behind him.
He doesn't do those or at least he didn't for a long time.
And that was his rationale.
He might've changed and went to it now,
but I know for the longest time it wasn't interested in those.
He was just interested in putting motherfuckers to sleep.
Like he's like,
hmm.
Like all the,
all you have to do is get ahold of that neck.
And if I become a specialist in squeezing next,
I'm just gonna put everybody to sleep.
I don't need to be messing up your shoulder or anything.
I'll just shut you off.
I mean,
it's the most def def,
like a guy can tap you and it's very definitive.
Right?
The guy gets you in an arm bar and Tab.
It's very definitive,
but there's something about the way climbs off shall Shaolin and challenge his
unconscious and he just scrolls him out in seconds.
It's the most definitive ending next to,
I mean obviously next to a knockout,
knockout being the most definitive.
Right.
Because it carries the most consequences.
Yeah.
But I mean,
they both,
they both put you to sleep,
devote real life.
Like you're dead.
You're dead,
you're dead.
That's no,
that's legitimate.
Like that would kill you.
Yeah.
Oh Oh,
Marcel would have to do is keep hanging on for another 30 seconds.
Second dead guy over.
No referee.
It's over.
Yeah.
I mean,
he just climbed.
And the crazy thing is he just did that to a worldclass blackbelt yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It's this,
again,
anything,
those,
those people that,
that work for Hillary Clinton,
they put the inject you to put you to sleep,
but when you're out you can go,
they can take you somewhere.
So when you get knocked out,
when you get choked unconscious,
it's like,
yeah,
you're dead.
You,
you are at their mercy.
Absolutely nothing you can do about whatever they wanted to do to you.
Why do you gotta bring in Hillary Clinton and interject and people
talking about
politics,
about the Trump thing.
And I just want,
I just wanted to put it out there that I'm against them both though.
So I don't want anybody coming after me.
I had to say first.
Yeah.
Joe Schilling.
What do you think?
You know these guys very well.
Dustin Jacola.
Simon Marcus.
Big Step up for Jacoby though,
right?
Yeah.
I think it's the biggest step up for him.
I think they already fought once.
No.
Did he rematch?
Like here we go and that way.
Yeah.
But uh,
yeah,
Dustin's not,
I don't think Dustin's who won the first fight.
I didn't even want,
I mean once the first did Simon when 71 yet.
Do you know how he won?
I don't.
There was the Brazilian guy who k owed Jacola Jacoby with a left hook.
I remember that Jacoby.
It was like,
oh.
And first he fought it two oh five with glory and lost like five or six fights.
He was fighting a long time.
Right?
Yeah.
I mean went to one at 85 and uh,
knock out two
months.
Oh,
nice.
Push Turkey.
He's definitely got a lot better as a striker since he's been concentrating
entirely on it.
Oh.
So there it is a,
there's a decision Simon Marcus wanted decision.
That was the first fight they had.
Yeah.
I would say if,
if Jacoby has a,
has a best chance of winning this fight now than there because of the high
altitude.
Uh,
and he's a a Colorado guy.
Yeah.
He lives in Colorado.
And then do you,
how much of a fact do you think Simon Mark is just losing by Kao to Jason?
Wilderness?
Is was not that long ago.
I don't think so.
It was like two months ago.
Right.
Um,
it couldn't have been more than three you don't think.
And he was out out.
He got beat up.
They stopped it,
but he got beat up.
He was fucked up.
He got hurt and he got dropped once.
He got dropped more than once that six weeks ago.
Wow.
And that was six weeks out to the socks.
He's flinching a lot of factors.
Yeah.
He doesn't look a calm,
comfortable.
And Dustin is a big,
big guy.
I feel like he's going to get knocked out.
I'll tell you what,
in the first round in the wilderness fight,
he looked like a fucking world beater.
He really did.
And Oh,
we just got tagged.
But he looked like a world beater.
When you fly you in the first round too.
I mean,
he's got a fur,
he's got a first gear that's pretty fucking sensational.
I mean,
he's a,
he's a traditional Muy Thai guy.
Some with all of his fights.
He's got 49 fights there were all Muy Thai and like where he beat me the first
two times as he's like incredibly strong and good in the clinch and we'll like
zap you and hold you and right hand clench or he just tagged on.
So um,
the,
the clinch is really the fact that it's removed from Gloria really hurts him.
Yeah.
And his,
well it forces him to have to fight.
That's really interesting.
He used to uh,
it's cardio look better because he had more time to clench.
Now when it's full,
go and throw him where a combinations,
well that's interesting too because he has to completely change his style.
Like is his cardio is sort of based on the style of being able to hold on
whenever you want to like that.
That's why he was able to get away with those explosive movements and not,
not conserve energy.
Right.
Cause he could explode like that and they could clench up when he needed that
time to clench up and he's very strong.
Right.
That's interesting.
What did you prefer this or do you prefer more Thai?
I for the glory rose really for myself.
If you got to make the ultimate roles though,
what would you,
what would you sell a Duke Gloria rules with elbows.
Ah,
they,
I like the way of thinking,
but what about the clinch?
I think in the clinch,
just like a use,
the way you see it,
the way that you liked the clench as the way that it is here.
Just don't realize it,
but if you want,
if I showed you one aside,
what if I showed you Simon and I,
his second fight where he held onto me for two minutes out of every round up
against the ropes and nothing was happening and I was just sitting there getting
squeezed and I'm talking to Steve Mazzagatti like,
hey,
nothing's happening here.
You wouldn't,
you wouldn't like it that much.
I might have broke his arm,
man.
Okay,
they're going to stop the fight.
It looks like he broke his arm like Kik.
Yup.
Yeah.
They just squoze his arm and he's a pain.
Now he's getting off the stool is left arm.
It's fucked up,
man.
What does Simon Marcus,
what is going on here?
It's not there.
The doctor's going to come over and look at this fights over.
He's got a broken arm where he keeps like,
you can't like the fight is over.
Right?
What are they gonna do?
They're gonna say,
okay,
go,
go in there.
What do they do when they're stuck in Joe?
Well he's,
he's,
he's in pain.
Right?
So here's the thing.
No,
no.
So what I'm saying,
why wouldn't they just have already started the round?
Like Simon had done some damage.
Right?
Would the idea be that either you are capable of starting at the beginning of
the round or the fights over?
No,
it's broken.
They're still deciding.
Yeah.
He's saying we've got to stop the fight.
It must be broken.
He could feel it.
It's broken.
But my question is how do you start the round and then have the guy have,
have them get checked out like that.
Like what if he can,
if he can't go on,
I'll give you,
can't continue.
You can't continue.
It seems like if he decided like I can go on two minutes later,
it's not really a foul that was committed.
It's not like he kicked him in the balls like in the Henderson Bisping fight.
Right.
There was a big deal.
Bisbing kicked Henderson the balls.
Henderson took a gang of time.
He was like,
good,
I'm gonna take a break.
And it was a smart move to do that,
but that made sense.
He deserved that.
He got kicked in the balls.
He didn't,
Simon didn't do anything wrong.
He landed kicks and he heard the dude's arm and then they're like,
well,
how bad is he hurt?
Can we Kenny go on?
Well,
if he can't go on at the beginning of the round,
then you,
you shouldn't dis,
the fight should be stopped.
Right,
right.
Yeah.
But did he ask for help?
What did he get above this dual ready to fight and then he ran for re decided to
to call the doctor.
I would have to be real clear.
I don't know.
I think when they were grabbing his arm in the corner,
I could have sworn he was telling them.
It was broken.
Uh,
and then he got up and then maybe they had informed the referee.
Maybe there was some confusion in that regard.
The referee was like,
oh,
well we go to the doctor to see this.
Right.
But you can't know ordinarily that can't happen.
Like that was the big issue with the DOL.
We're Barrow Tim Kennedy Fight,
right?
Yeah.
Tim Kennedy hurts you all.
Romero has been badly hurt.
The round ends and the Ramiro stays on a stool for a long time.
He stayed on a stool for the full minute and then stayed on his stool at the end
of the round and just stayed there and looked at John McCarthy.
They cleared out the corner and it took like a long time.
I forget like what all the shenanigans where that was going on,
but it was clear that he had been hurt and then time was of the essence and they
didn't start the route on time.
So a lot of people thought,
well,
the fight should have been stopped right there.
I was on that side of the point.
I was too.
I think it's very important,
especially when you're talking about someone being hurt.
Yeah,
right.
If you heard a guy,
it's very important that that's,
you have to allow fire to capitalize on that and it and giving some an extended
round just because they're,
they're just sitting down there borrow food.
Tj Dillashaw
what is that thing on his neck?
Somebody talked to him and to learn that.
I think that's his idea that a dog tag,
the glitter refied that her dog tag is that like,
um,
well they get those at forever 21 they're in that glass,
that glass,
a feeling,
feeling TJC.
They can get it forever 20 now he's his way class here.
If way class here.
Praise.
I'm just kidding.
It's probably super expensive.
But um,
what's that stuff they put on a deed?
Quit African art.
If you a kickbox and mentioned you got your arm broken the sec around,
you're stopping you to tell the ref mom,
I'm not telling them graph.
If I,
if I'm good to go,
I'm going,
are you good to go?
If I mean,
you would know,
right?
You will know how bad it hurts.
Well,
I mean it would,
it would,
it depend entirely upon like where it's broken.
Like what if it was broken up here?
Like when Minataro fought Frank Mir.
Yeah.
And snap the upper arm.
That's a little different than the forearm,
isn't it?
Yeah.
That's much different than the form then.
You can't even use that arm at all.
Yeah,
it's the forum.
You can at least move it out of the way and you could stand like you're gonna
throw it.
Yeah.
Like if you get hurt,
it's like your hand.
Yeah.
I don't know.
You know,
you break that upper arm,
that's a different beast to further up.
It goes.
The worse it gets for fighting man,
break your hands.
You can still fight and break your form.
You may be able to fight.
Right,
right.
You chip it or crack it.
You may be,
but you,
you started getting up here and you bicep area.
If you've ever seen Ian Mccall's hands.
Yeah.
He's broke his hand like a hundred times or even fucking broken here.
He can't make a fist and he makes a fist.
It's like this isn't,
is one knuckle is always poking out.
It doesn't close.
Right.
And he's had a bunch of operations so they're trying to figure out what had
happened.
So it was somehow it was blocking the kick
dude.
I think they isolated it.
Are they just showing you highlights here?
It looks like they're just showing highlights.
They have no idea.
Yeah.
I mean who knows?
But some of Marcus' kicks fucking heart right there.
That's probably right.
It,
that's probably it started shaking it.
Yup.
Yeah.
And the way he's holding it.
That was it.
It was that kicked.
So that was it.
They nailed it.
Yeah man.
You can't let a guy fight with a fucking broken arm if you know it's a broken
arm.
Like if you want to hide it even where you can hide it,
but they have to stop it once it gets brought to the doctor's attention.
Yeah.
Sean Yarbrough broke,
uh,
Steven Richards for forum with a body kick and there's like one lion fight,
like one of the first line flight snap just for him.
And Steven Richards went on and beat him to the,
for the decision and the final clip,
he was just kept clinching him up and like dumping him and shit.
But he broke his arm and you could see like in there holding it after the fight
and you could see like a huge debt.
Oh my God,
this is,
it's like Jamie Varner and he broke his ankle.
Yeah,
no,
that should have been stuff that should have been stopped.
And that was obvious.
He can't do anything about that.
But if he,
if that would have been his forearm,
he would've continued it.
Yeah,
he went back to his corner.
Right.
Did that happen in the first round quarterback back to his corner.
And that's when they called it.
But that happened midway through the first,
they didn't make a second.
He got knocked out.
He got knocked out,
plates.
Tweet came back out.
I'm pretty sure he came back out.
What he did get knocked out and I think it was a,
was it true Hilo?
Yeah,
able to Hilo.
Yeah.
No.
Who is that?
What does it go back up so I can see who he's fighting?
No.
Is that it?
Broken Ankle?
Nope.
I don't think this is
what I'm thinking of.
He break his ankle more than once.
What was the fight where he was in a crazy slug fest with somebody?
Yeah,
no,
that was Afro Reebok deal.
That was James Kraus.
That's who it is right there.
Yeah.
Oh,
I remember this.
Oh yeah,
that's right.
It just gave out on him.
That's right.
Now I remember.
So I think I confused that.
And his fight with able to Hilo,
his fight with able true Hilo was a slobber knocker and true Hilo wind up
winning by knockout.
That's what that was.
I can fabulous.
Did the two of them and he went down the same way that he went down right there.
Yes.
Yeah.
When he got hit with that hook,
he was making that same move.
So it looks like weird.
I had the two memories confused in my mind.
Powerful glory from Denver.
Oh yeah.
Here's able to Hylo in him.
Boom,
boom.
Right there.
Yup.
Exactly.
The same.
I,
you're,
you were fucking right.
Eve Edwards.
He figured it out,
man.
Boom.
God,
Lord,
that's a fucking perfect punch,
man.
If,
if I was
in my prime right now and I was in the UFC,
I would have to be a 45.
These dudes are so much bigger than we were 10 years ago.
How do you feel about that?
What do you,
what's your feelings about weight cutting?
My interview on you.
I'm not a journalist.
Do you,
do you approve it?
Do you think that we'd all be better off if everybody abandoned it?
Do you think that it's a smart thing?
I'm asking too many questions.
No,
I don't disapprove of it,
but I think we would all be better off in the long run as the fighters would be
lot better off in the long run,
but not having to do it.
There are some guys,
for me,
it wasn't miserable.
Um,
but there are some guys that it is,
and,
and even for me,
I think I'm still taking some burning that oil at both ends.
Um,
so I burn the candle at both ends at that point.
but it's not as hard as say some guys like leasing t bow or um,
guys that,
that are much bigger and the weight class,
you know,
I think,
uh,
in the long run you are putting a toll on your body that's going to,
you're going to have to pay the price.
You're going to have to pay that tax at some point,
but,
and that could come when you're 50 or you know,
I don't know,
whatever.
Yeah.
It seems that fighting itself is such an incredibly difficult task on your body.
Why would you want to put it through the task of massive dehydration 24 hours
before finding,
it just doesn't make any sense.
I know that everybody does it to gain a competitive advantage,
but wouldn't it be better if it was just all,
even even wait,
like honest,
like fuck this competitive advantage shit.
If everybody just,
first of all,
there should be more options,
right?
I think we all agree on,
I think that's how you solved the problem and have a one 70 than a one 85 and a
two oh five and a to 65 and expect people to not wait.
They're gonna fuck a cut weight 100% right either your,
your options are fight gorillas.
I had a to 65 or you way to 30 you know we gotta deal with fucking chain car
went on top of you or something like that and you're a two 30 pounder.
Fuck that.
You got to make that two oh five and you're going to suck it up cause there
should be a way class every 10 pounds.
And I think with fighters like what really matters,
what everybody cares about is who the best guys fight.
Like the best guys fighting the best guys.
You know,
whether Norma Grumet off and a Conor McGregor had a belt or not,
right?
If number Grumman off didn't have the 155 pound belt and Conor McGregor didn't
have the 155 pound belt,
it would be worth more to watch those two go at it.
At 155 pounds,
then it would for me to watch maybe Eddie Alvarez defended against somebody
else.
You know like I just want to see like if it was not Connor or not some high
level guy,
I'd be more interested in seeing the high level guys who don't have the belt.
But if you were to make more weight classes then you get super fights.
Yes.
It's all good,
right?
Yeah.
You,
you get the hundred and 60 pounds,
you have anniversary to 150 pound champion and it's like this is a fight that
people want to see because it's not that much of a difference.
You know,
they gave people a little bit of a break by letting fighters way in early.
Now you could weigh in between like eight and 10:00 AM and that way,
by the time the way in ceremony goes on at like 4:00 PM you're fully hydrated.
You look good.
You don't look like death anymore.
Like Conor,
when he fought Chad Mendez every that last time you made 45 you're like,
what the fuck?
Like he looks,
he looks like like a dying person.
And then he's gonna fight for a world title 24 hours from now.
That's a ridiculous practice.
It's ridiculous that,
that,
that was my thing.
I'm not,
I'm not huge fill a class,
but I was decent sized for the weight class so I could get down to like one 53
the day of the weigh in.
So I would cut to about one 53 and then get put,
put about two and a half pounds of food in my body,
food and water.
And that's why it weigh ins.
I was happy.
I was never measurable.
It was never sucking it up.
I mean sometimes you overcut and then bounce it up.
Hey,
interesting.
But I,
I was small enough to do that.
Yeah.
Usually those last three pounds,
they're like,
yeah,
I would wake up,
fight morning.
Um,
so I weigh in morning at like 158 maybe if I'm heavy,
I'm 158 most of the time to look up at 56 57.
Well,
I mean I think you were lucky in the sense that you were in that your body fit
right in there with that weight class.
If you were a little bit bigger maybe would be an issue.
Like maybe what if you were a little bit bigger but not quite big enough for one
70 you know?
Yeah.
Like a Diego Sanchez.
Diego was kind of a tweener right.
He was a guy that really struggled to make 55 I remember the first time I saw
him when he made 55 I'm pretty sure it was in England and I remember going Jesus
like he looks so drawn out at the way in.
He looked terrible and then he got it balanced out if figured out how to do it.
But I don't think ideally his weight would be 55 I think is ideal.
We would probably be like 65 or 60 you know,
somewhere in that range.
I think if they went 51 51 60 or (556) 057-0580 five I mean they could do it
that way easily.
But 10 pounds I think is like the right,
the right number.
So you think the four or five pounds of boxing is too,
too small of a weight.
It's interesting cause I think it's more of a factor in MMA than it is in boxing
and wait.
Yeah.
And boxing has more options.
It was just kind of kind of interesting in a way.
But obviously boxing is just got way more history,
you know,
it's been around way longer and people were smaller back then too.
So it's not like you can eliminate Slapsie Maxie what it was he,
is he at light heavyweight?
No,
it was Billy conn was a light heavyweight.
Right.
And I forget what you,
when they changed it,
but I mean heavyweight was 154 pounds and up way back in the day.
Really?
Yeah.
154 pounds more than one 50 volt with heavyweight like in,
in the early,
like probably like twenties and thirties whoa.
Yeah.
Well I saw,
even in California,
I think it's over 71 75 or something like that.
It's supposed to be.
Trying to think of like classic and technically boxes.
A heavyweight over one,
one 76 I think.
Wow.
That's crazy.
Remember when your Roy Jones Jr went up to heavyweight and beat John Ruiz?
Holy Shit.
I remember that.
Yeah.
You know he's still fighting.
It makes me sad.
Yeah.
I love that dude.
When I was a kid he was like,
he was superman.
Roy Jones Jr would fight rounds without getting hit.
Like nobody ever did that before.
He was,
he was so good.
You haven't heard of Willie pep?
Yes,
of course.
Oh,
you heard about?
Yeah.
He went around without actually throwing a punch.
That's awesome.
In the history of copy box.
Yeah.
He said he was going to do it and then he went and did it like he said it
between rounds.
Then he went and did it.
You just couldn't imagine anybody at that time in particular having better
footwork.
It's an amazing,
like we're boxing went because if you watch some of the old Jack Johnson stuff,
you know and you watch like how how they used to,
they used to hold their hands differently,
they threw punches differently,
you know,
and then you see some Jack Dempsey like,
oh,
okay,
well this is starting to become a little bit more like modern boxing.
This is like some savage fucking railroad Hobo Dude.
Fuck people up.
You know?
Let me,
Jack Dempsey was,
he was scary cat when you said some savage Hobo Dude,
it doesn't fuck people up by first.
My first thing in my brain that hit me with crazy horse
crazy horse would be that dude at the seven 11 that's outside that you think
he's on something but he will fuck you up.
He will fuck you up quick to crazy horse can crack a lack.
Did you see the fight?
He just had it I think is horizon one punch now.
He was a beast and still is.
He's a fun dude.
I hung out with him one night.
We'd watch k one together.
We were in the front row.
It's him and his girlfriend may and I can't remember who was with her.
I think it was Eddie Bravo and we owe,
it was Eddie Bravo and uh,
we watched k one in la.
You remember when k one came to la and they had an MMA fights and,
whoa,
there it is.
Charles Crazy Horse Bennet.
There he is.
Rather he was his special dude.
Some serious fucking power.
Had some real problems outside of the cage though.
Just uh,
was involved in quite a few altercations.
Yeah.
So this was,
uh,
was this before or after he had that brawl with Vandelay?
Oh,
this was two weeks ago.
This was that fight.
I didn't know which fight this one.
He got it and then it went crazy.
The Vandelay.
He's crazy.
For sure.
Yeah,
he's crazy.
Well,
he apparently had had a street fight with Vandelay
pride.
Marcel,
who was it?
It put him to sleep.
Cristiana Marcello put them asleep and a triangle and a street fight.
And apparently he woke up and then went over the Vandelay and knocked out cold.
I don't tell him what the fuck happened.
But uh,
and then they jumped him and beat him up and,
and Vandelay went out after he got knocked out cold and then went out and
fought.
So he fought in pride and layer.
The horse went out and fought that night.
No defaults.
I think they both fought that night.
I don't,
I don't remember where the crazy hos fought after he knocked out Vandelay but
I'm almost positive that Vandelay fought after getting code lease.
That was depending on who you're asking.
Right.
The problem with those pride stories is I definitely wasn't there,
but it's pretty much agreed upon that crazy horse in some way.
Punched Vandelay Silva in the face and it was not a good thing.
And it's pretty much been proven that Cristiana Marcello choke crazy horse out
in a triangle.
Got Them and triangle,
I've seen the video,
he puts them to sleep for sure.
So those two things we know.
One for sure happened and the other one,
it's pretty much known that they had some sort of a fist fight and they crazy
horse punched him and crazy horse keeps saying,
I'll knock you out.
Just like I did the last time,
mother fucker.
You know what happened?
Yeah.
I knock you the fuck out.
So that seems to indicate that that's what took place.
I Dunno.
But Vandelay went out and fought after that.
That's fucking crazy.
That's if he really did get knocked out.
That is fucking crazy.
Then he went out and he fought after that.
In Japan.
You can do anything.
Yeah.
This is the fight.
Jamie found that he's found the street fight.
So this is when they go after each other
and Cristiana Marcel winds up on the ground with crazy horse was trying to
fucking ground and pound him.
He never seen this Joe.
So Joe,
I've seen initially this fight in this.
Yeah,
for sure.
Yeah.
This was a proof that Jujitsu worse.
Real good man.
You got jeans on.
It's hard to get away from them.
Chines.
Oh,
well he gets free.
I think it goes right back into it.
Yup.
Looking for some more grounded pound.
This is going to be a good kickbox in fight.
We should probably watch this cause this is the final spin or fucked up.
He changed his shorts as fucking Dick.
What do you think?
Why do you think you did that?
Sponsors probably I probably smart,
but yeah,
other ones were doper saying,
well they were more flashy,
but this you could read this sponsor is better.
That's why he wore them first.
Just to be sure that they got,
they're like,
uh oh it fell down.
Who's the gentleman he's fighting again?
How do you say his name as the guy who looks like Chris Kimonti's was his
brother.
I don't know.
What's his name?
Jim Bruce Salary or somewhere a blue bell
bell.
Garu God guy.
Roy Belgo.
Roy.
Okay.
Give us a little volume so we can hear homeboys
name.
You gets paid for it.
Shots,
which is is that,
this is a
ESPN three.
Have you ever watched ESPN three before?
Nope.
I didn't know they had kickboxing on ESPN at all.
Yeah,
I did air this on Sunday afternoon to ESPN is ESPN.
Okay,
so good afternoon.
Oh,
nice.
Right hand over the top.
I'm waiting for this dude's name
bell role.
You,
I just signed this thing.
Oh yeah,
totally.
The center of the ring.
Hey Joe Shelley,
how come kickboxing is so much more popular in Europe?
Uh,
aesthetic.
The promoters promoted better I guess in the TV deals might be different there.
I don't know.
I don't really know.
Well,
isn't it kinda crazy that it just took off so big in Holland?
It's big and France big and a lot of places.
Yeah,
it's,
it is.
It's really frustrating,
but it's just way bigger over there.
All of them.
It's like they were like national sport.
The in sports in entertainment market is kind of self contained though.
Yeah.
No.
Yeah,
it is kind of right,
right.
But don't you mean,
look,
obviously we're attracted to this so I'm trying to like solve this puzzle.
If I was an investor,
which was clearly not well,
I just think it comes down to the promoter is like,
this is,
I'm enjoying them.
These fights were like that.
Everything is empty.
Is it?
Yeah.
It's like three rows of seats.
That's it.
Yeah.
Oh Wow.
Wow.
That's crazy.
It's just,
Oh my God.
It's crazy how people make
these bad decisions and they don't promote it.
And that,
as I was saying earlier,
it's like you have the,
you know,
us wanting to watch it,
you have the,
the quality isn't as good fights,
fights,
things missing.
Why isn't it taken off?
You have a TV deal.
Why?
Here's why it hasn't taken off.
I think I just figured it out.
You remember when some of those,
um,
street fight videos and Mazda doll,
we used to fight back in the day and they were saying no kicks know kicks,
right.
Yeah.
People would complain about that.
I think like,
and now people are just now starting to accept it because of MMA or whatever.
But I think boxing history in,
in,
in the u s for so long and in America been such a self contained sports and
entertainment industry.
Um,
alright,
so,
so self contained in the sports and entertainment industry that people are just,
they don't want to see kicks.
It does.
It's,
it's foreign to most Americans.
It's like it's not,
it's not what we're used to here on this side of the world for
the most part.
Think about that.
Like I think there's probably something to that.
It's probably something to that.
But what about Bruce Lee?
I mean it's cool to go watch his movie.
So it's critical as Jackie Chan movies,
but for sleep,
Ben Damn every UFC hero of all time.
Like it's not that it's just promoting.
I think it's just bad people that get these opportunities to make mistakes and
they don't do a good job doing their only job to promote it.
Well,
I think it's really hard.
I'm old man.
I don't think it's necessarily that sample.
I see what you're talking about though.
As far as like the size of this arena in particular.
When have you ever seen a glory,
uh,
advertisement?
Like a
commercial,
I don't know ever glory oil or kickboxing and America needs to do something.
Oh,
we just got tagged style.
Bender was standing in front of them just trying to move his head and he got
clipped.
He got timed and clip with the right hand.
He got hit hard.
Oh,
when you went to high,
beautiful kick.
Oh my goodness.
Belgard Belgar oh,
there we go.
We got his name.
This is awesome.
Okay.
The garlic is no joke.
He's a big tall,
skinny dude too.
Hm.
When you see a guy like semi shell,
that's when you realize how much like when utilized correctly reached plays a
factor.
He's got his timing down.
He slipped in that right hand a little often,
but he's trying to come back with that left bell.
Garu Bell Guy is,
that's how you say it,
Jamie,
but got her Guari Guari re Oui.
Like we re Gari.
Okay.
He's from Tunisia.
They probably don't even use our letters today.
They probably got some cryptic Celtic look in speech.
What does Tunisia use for language that was kind of an Asian Tunisian?
What does it look like?
It was like Russian.
I'm just guessing like rushing to me is the coolest shit ever because it's like
you're reading some forgotten scrolls,
you know?
It was like,
it's almost like it has characters.
What is it,
Jamie?
Oh,
it's Arabic.
Okay.
So they're writing is an Arabic as well.
Interesting.
Yeah.
Arabic and Hebrew.
Hebrew was another one.
That's cool looking language,
right.
Looks like speak French apparently.
Which might be where his last name.
Ah,
that makes sense.
Bed gouty
interesting.
The world is so much more diverse than the eight one eight man.
You say that.
But when I came here from Texas I was,
I mean Texas,
I thought Texas is pretty diverse in it.
It is in its own right.
But in Texas I felt like there were,
there were,
there was it in Houston specifically,
there is a part of Houston that's a Vietnamese community.
Then as a part of using that to spa Hispanic community and then then you have
black and white people,
but like you come here and it's like there's Armenians and there's Russians and
there is Vietnamese and Koreans and Chinese and Japanese and like everybody's
here.
This is really diverse compared to what it's like in.
Gotcha.
Very good.
Cracked
hope to show that
it was beautiful.
Right down.
Um,
do you feel like,
uh,
like a particular,
like you were saying about the confederate flags,
you feel like it's Houston and Texas in general still has just a little too much
old stupid shit going on there in terms of racism and mentality and,
yeah.
And it's,
it's,
it's not,
it's weird because it doesn't exist everywhere.
Right.
You know,
um,
and I'm sure it's,
it's kind of even hidden in some places,
but it's hidden everywhere at some point.
But in Houston it's
inside the city,
it's pretty diverse as far as those communities that I just mentioned,
those people are pretty well represented.
But then when you get on the outskirts of town,
and there's a lot of outskirts,
because here,
I mean,
everybody's in,
in a small area,
it's like I drive 10 miles here and it takes me 30 minutes.
But in Houston,
10 miles takes me 10 minutes.
I say there's so many more people here and it's such a smaller area.
So it also gives rural real quick.
In Texas.
Yeah,
for sure.
It gets wild pigs rural,
you know,
if,
if you,
if you get on a highway,
if you're on a highway in Texas,
any direction you start and stay,
you start in the center of Houston,
you get on a highway,
it would no traffic any direction in 30 minutes.
You're,
you know,
you're not in the city anymore.
You're,
you're,
you're aware houses are far apart and they're huge and they're,
you know,
those ranches people,
giant swaths of land with probably 45 minutes.
Wild pigs running around.
Yeah.
Texas is a trap.
It really is.
It's one of the weirdest states.
It's one of my favorite though.
Such a wild,
crazy place.
But yeah,
it's um,
it's very unique in that aspect.
Like how big it is too.
It's big.
We got 85 mile an hour.
Highway
55 was the limit.
What in the fuck was going on with people?
55 that was crazy.
That is crazy.
It was just,
so,
it's like,
come
on,
we're not talking about like a model t,
you know,
these cars are safe and competent and above speeds.
The 55 of my car says it can go one 40 it's just stupid.
I mean not that you should be gone one 40 but you know what?
That's an interesting argument about the Audubon man.
I mean,
I don't necessarily know it's a bad one either.
Like what adults do?
Whatever the fuck they want know and just have good etiquette move over when
there's a faster car coming behind you.
What's the statistics on that?
Bond is actually safer.
Bet people get the fuck out of the way.
Like this.
Some bad shit going on in any of the other ones.
So something a couple days ago,
I don't remember where I saw it.
I,
if I can find it,
I'll send it to you.
But they were talking about how people get over out of the,
the fast lane on the Autobahn.
People don't stay in the fast and they just use that lane to pass and get out of
that lane.
That's what it should be.
That's the passing lane ran.
Yeah.
It's supposed to be just La.
They're just have total disregard for that shit.
Never been to a place that has more disregard for the left lane in La are
really?
Yeah.
Nobody can sound the left lane.
And I watched people get mad.
People pull up behind people and watch them get pissed.
The fuck the fuck.
Like oh you must be new.
Because in Boston people,
first of all they have will small roads.
Like in Boston you could be on a highway and it's two lanes on each side and
there's some stupid little rinky dank highways.
They were invented pack when people wrote buggies and horses and shit.
They just paved them.
Yeah,
they just paved over those fucking things.
That's how you got to get to the Cape.
You gotta take these to get to Cape Cod.
You gotta take these stupid ass roads that are like two lanes long in some spots
are two lanes wide and soft spots.
So when someone's coming behind you,
there's no options.
Just get over,
you know?
So people usually respect that left lane.
You New York is a lot of that too,
man.
Like there's a lot of like rinky dink streets so you wouldn't believe on the way
to the airport when you leave New York and you've got to go through a what?
What is it,
queens or what is it that you got to go through?
Brooklyn?
Depends on which airport.
Right?
Laguardia and JFK.
Either way you leave Manhattan,
those towns that you have to go through,
there's sometimes you're driving on these little tiny ass fucking super narrow
roads and you're like,
this is it.
This is all these fucking people are going to the airport.
Like this is crazy,
but you can use that for oh five in la where it's just lanes on this side lanes
on that side.
I lived in Houston,
man,
I 10 in Houston in the Katy area.
There's five lanes on heading west and his five lanes.
Any east,
I think it's five and then there are two or three we have.
You don't have them here.
Feeders.
We have feeder roads in service roads in Texas,
so next to the highway.
If I wanted to drive from downtown Houston to Katy,
which is probably 15 to 20 I can do that
next to the freeway without actually getting on the freeway because I not
because,
but there are people that do this because they're afraid to drive it.
Those high speeds.
So there are stop lights at every intersection on this feeder road that's next
to the highway.
It's a 35 mile an hour street,
but it feeds right on to the highway.
There's a picture of it right there.
Yeah.
So those little roads on the side,
those roads feed onto the highway.
When you exit,
you exit off onto the side like that.
That's actually a really good idea.
I don't,
I think,
do you see how much rote that's 13 lanes of road or [inaudible] 14 lanes of
highway water?
The better,
the more the better.
I'm not in a waiting.
I think we should just make it all highway.
Why we fucking around?
Right.
We need to have floating houses and everything else is highway.
Just shoot right up to your floating house.
It's what point in time do we tell people we can't build any more houses?
Were,
were,
were
I think about things like that.
We,
if we,
if we survive,
if there are species survives for another couple of hundred years,
yeah.
There's going to be no more trees or plants or like everything is going to be
house then we have to build up.
Well there's a lot of space right now,
but there's so much more people now than there's ever been before.
Like by a long shot.
Yeah.
Think about like,
think about the uh,
the increase in people over the last just a few years over the last century.
Yeah.
I mean I think we were talking about it once where it was 1970.
There was 2 billion people on the planet.
Was that what it was?
No.
What does it,
Jamie boy,
you were talking about this the other day.
There's some people say that we could be on a decline right now to those people.
Right.
Smarter,
younger people are not having babies.
Whatever.
I've heard that argument before.
I think it's horse shit cause the dummies or having 1520 kids and makeup of
those smart people they know declines going on and it might be a d client.
Smart people in mind.
New York borough.
I've noticed in my co op there's a decrease.
Smart people having babies.
Everybody should be allowed to make one copy.
Yeah,
there's a lot of copies out there.
Have some really shitty original work.
That's a part of the problem.
Like just the sheer genetic tools that you had to work with.
We're not the best
one.
Okay.
Here it is.
Japan,
Japan.
Well Japan has a giant issue though.
They they do,
they have a weird issue.
They have a,
an issue of a lot of people that are choosing to not get married,
not have sex there.
They have people that are choosing to stay at home like,
like really as they're getting older and massive population decline.
Wow.
Don't know.
I don't want to hear the decline.
I want to know what was the,
what was the population in 1970 world world population 1970 so us was 200 200
million.
So it's 300,000,050 now,
350 million now
billion.
So 3.7 billion in 1970 so since 1970 the world has doubled.
The world doubled in the United States has gone up by 50% right.
So I guess growth is slowing.
Wait,
so the world is dealt with 50% not 50% of the world doubling.
Okay.
Right.
50% of what the United States,
why the United States was 200 million and now it's 300 million plus,
right?
That's 50% isn't it?
Yeah.
That's a lot.
But the world is doubled.
So the world went up 100% so we are,
we're at a slower pace than some of those poor fools that live in other,
other countries.
It was poor people not blessed to be American.
After this decision.
I need an audio pause so my tape doesn't stop here.
Oh,
that's something might happen with the tri caster.
I can,
something might have happened with it.
It says I'm running out of space.
What does that mean?
Well,
now I don't know if that means it's going to cut the whole Edison.
Yeah,
I don't need this space,
but,
okay,
well let's pause now.
Only like five seconds.
We'll be right back.
Is a youtube still up?
Okay.
So what's wrong with the tri caster?
So,
uh,
it says I'm running out of spaces.
There's less than two gigs of space left,
right on the tri caster and cause I record and stream at the same time just in
case something goes wrong.
So the recording is going to stop.
I don't know if the streets and stuff.
Hmm.
But you don't need that recording anyway,
right?
Yeah.
I don't know if it's going to shut the whole machine off or not though.
Oh,
I don't think it was.
That's not good.
All right.
We're good to do your best job in January was just getting ready in case
something happens.
It's
all good.
We're not talking right now.
Israel has got,
is a nice cup there.
One his trophy.
We back back up.
Okay.
So yeah,
man,
the world population has gone up double in the u s population has gone up a
hundred million at one point in time.
If you think 1973 point 7 million and now more than 7 million,
what is that going to be 50 years from now?
No,
that's not going to be double.
It's going to be double again.
Is it 14 then?
What does that mean?
What's it like with the world?
So that's billions.
Yeah.
Look with a project by 2050 they projected 9 billion.
Yeah,
the world's billions.
It's interesting.
So between 1950 and 2050 in a hundred years it goes up 7 billion.
Good Lord.
Yeah.
There's a stat that says that the whole population could
like fit in Texas.
Have you ever heard that those people are assholes?
No.
Nobody says that as an asshole.
Spots in Texas that you can't live in.
There's just heela monsters and fucking cactuses and shit.
If you had the fucking,
all the population he tried to fit them in Texas,
they want of eating each other.
It'd be no food like,
yeah.
Yeah,
you could kind of fit them physically,
but like not like resource wise.
Texas is a good place to go though.
If the shit hits the fan and it was hot,
it's hot.
But there's a lot of people that have figured out how to be off the grid or
mostly off the grid there.
You'd get a thousand square feet per person.
If we got 6.9 billion people in Texas,
which there's still 500 million people left over,
so what does that mean?
That's just a,
you could get a thousand square foot apartment.
Yeah,
but that doesn't mean that even apartment,
I think it's like literal feet on the ground.
Like,
oh,
I see.
No way everyone can fit in Texas.
Okay.
So they wouldn't be able to,
so they like the physical size of the people would not be able to fit.
There's too many people to fit.
Like we would overwhelm the entire state if we just stood there.
And there's so many fat
people there too.
I was confused as to what you're saying of space.
The land mass of taxes is (260) 800-0820 square miles.
7,494,002 oh 7 billion.
What does that,
is that even billion?
No,
that's not billion.
What does that trillion,
7 trillion,
494 billion.
271 million.
488,000 square feet.
Whoa.
Interesting.
So no close but not,
not quiet.
That's a lot of fucking people,
man.
Got To feed all those folks.
They all need food and water and a place to shit.
You know he used the rest of the continental United States for funding.
Yeah.
So everybody's just standing and then they go out to the garden.
They come back and stand.
They go out and they shit.
And the whole of death.
I'm going to go back and stand.
It.
Just have like a,
a pipe that runs through.
Everybody has their all 7 billion plus shitting into this one tube.
Uh,
out of that attitude mixes with our
terrible pollution shit.
Monster was born,
crawls out,
kills us all.
That's a,
ironically that's what did end.
There you go.
It's on.
That's one of the things that did in a lot of civilizations is their hygiene.
You know,
a lot of civilizations had serious problems with their sewage,
like figuring out how to get their shit away from everything that's going on in
India,
isn't it?
I think
so,
yeah
man,
I couldn't imagine living in a place where you could probably,
I mean like is it like Mumbai or placed at cities like that when you're not in,
I mean I guess when you're out where,
where some of the poor people of that country or city live,
they don't have indoor plumbing or no,
there's people that are living in really poor for sure.
And that's just one part of the world,
right?
I think it'd be pretty humbling if any of us ever went there and spent some time
there.
So I was thinking about this the other day when I saw,
I saw some some relief aid going to Haiti,
right?
And it's like,
yeah,
something bad just happened there.
But
there are places that are in that same situation without something bad happening
and there isn't really no aid going to them.
Like is it only a good good thing to help people when,
when an ad,
a tragedy happens?
If,
if,
if the capability is still there too.
Good point.
It's a really good point.
It's a very good point.
Yeah.
It seems like people wait until everything goes terrible for this step in to
help with those people.
I mean,
they were still suffering from a hurricane a couple of years ago.
Yeah.
You know,
it's almost like we're getting close to the point where,
you know,
when you see all these go fund me's and all these,
uh,
these,
these campaigns like that,
it seems like if someone had figured out a way to attach a purchasing app like
amazon.com or something like that and attach an option to donate to specific
charities,
like you could set that up and they would just rounded off.
Like say if you're buying something that's $3 and 50 cents,
I rounded off to $4 and just do that with everybody.
And no matter what it would be,
it would round up to the next dollar.
And you just take all that money from all these purchases.
When thinking about how many millions of dollars a day must be generated by a
purchasing APP like amazon.com and if you just rounded off to the next dollar
and donated all that money,
think about how much crazy shit could get done.
I mean,
the sheer amount of,
if everybody agreed to do that,
look,
everybody hates penny's.
Fuck Nichols.
I don't like Nichols and none in the dimes.
I though those are,
they're annoying.
They click around in your pocket,
you can't really buy shit with them.
Right.
It rounded off,
round it all off,
round everything off.
If we all just agreed as a society,
then when no matter what the money is,
it's $4 and 64 cents around that bitch off to five bucks and that money goes
into the be a good human pool.
How many orders does Amazon get per day?
36.8 million items.
Yeah,
but there isn't,
I mean there are some people that uh,
that or if they're thing costs $3 and 17 cents,
that 87 that 83 cents means a lot to them and they don't want to give it a go.
They've got to wake up,
we're all in this together.
If you can afford to buy that new toothbrush,
electric toothbrush with the Darth Vader sound,
you could afford to give that extra 30 cents to those kids in Bangladesh.
It's only we're talking pennies here.
We're literally talking sense.
I don't think they'll sense do mean a lot to the individual,
but I think they mean a lot collectively.
I think when you're looking at millions of orders,
that could be an insane force of good.
Like if,
if Amazon wanted to get people to love them again,
cause sometimes people like to hear about it.
Like the people that work at Amazon apparently is like,
it's insane.
Like if you're working in the factory,
you've got like a timer that goes off when someone's,
when someone's order gets placed.
Do you have like a clipboard,
like one of those iPad things and there's like some sort of a timer on it and
you've got to run to where the item is and get it and get it in a box quickly.
Like it's,
it's like super tight ship.
They run over there,
they get everybody to love him again.
It sounds like something you'd see that a company like that would have
automated.
So like somebody places and no one in it is the robot goes and grabs it and no,
no.
You've got to go get stuff.
Does people have written,
I mean maybe some of it's automated,
but I know that people
like a big claw arms they want to do with drones.
Really?
Yeah.
They want to sell you shit drone wrong mail shit.
How about them apples?
Yeah.
She'll be at your house with a fucking Ufo.
It's Karen,
your new boots.
How,
how,
how many people would wait with rifle hunting rifles?
It just die.
Just,
just for fun.
For Fuck.
Yeah,
for fun,
man.
I get free.
I had to get free stuff.
Well,
some people get super bummed out if people fly drones over their head,
you know,
especially if you're a young lady and you'd like to give the old tits a melanin
blast,
you know,
nobody can see and your yard and he,
this was a fence.
I'm just going to lie here and Tan my breasts in here.
He'd know like every teenager with an iPhone and fucks searching for tits,
especially in the warmth of the summer.
But I mean the warmth of the summer.
It was fucking 93 degrees today.
It was crazy hot dude.
This person was brought to,
um,
we're about seat cooks and awesome fight and we haven't even talked about it.
Niki holds skin and uh,
how do you pronounce growing hearts?
Name Martel.
Martel.
Mirth.
Towel.
Mirthful Martha,
Martha,
Martha grown heart first fight.
Super close.
Murtha wasn't that,
um,
the lady from Sam?
Uh,
no.
What?
Who did San Fred Sanford use the screenflow.
Oh,
Ethel was it?
No,
no,
no.
Well,
Elizabeth
honey.
Mirthful like what?
It was a time you need your people got mad at you were shot after he knocked out
chuck because he did that.
They did.
Yeah.
People got mad at him.
Pershad is the nicest guy in the world.
Super Cool.
When people would get bummed out about him or get shitty about him,
I'm like,
what?
Really?
I feel the same way about core Mya.
When people,
uh,
people boo call me,
I'm like freely,
but you're not seeing what I'm seeing.
How could you be that guy?
I don't get it.
I don't know.
A,
I know people don't like him.
I don't get it.
I don't get,
I just can't say it anymore.
You shop.
Amazon gives,
they already have the same thing.
Oh,
what is this?
Amazon donates 0.5% of the price of your eligible Amazon smile purchases to the
charitable organization of your choice and it was on smile is the same.
Amazon,
you know,
same product,
same prices,
same service.
Support your charitable organizations by starting your
shopping@smiledotamazon.com oh,
that's cool.
That's nice.
And so you could donate to that.
So it has a red cross there and you could select other the charities nature
conservative operation smile.
Nice.
Oh that's cool.
That's nice.
But then who is auditing those though?
Yeah man.
That's a problem.
Where,
um,
we were,
uh,
going over that one podcast,
we're trying to figure out how much of your actual donation goes to the charity
and how much goes to fees and the people that work,
they're getting paid and the rent and all the overhead,
all the overhead.
It's not a lot.
It's like there's a business of charity and the people that work for those
charities,
they get paid well,
you know,
and they should keep out.
Is it
big dude?
Yeah.
Growing heart.
Just tag Nikki holes.
Come with a couple of good shots.
Oh,
Ooh,
good.
Back Up.
Now we're back up.
Ooh.
See this to me is so much more interesting than boxing.
The way these guys are switched,
kicking each other and fucking each other with this.
Like this is like really technical striking all around,
up and down.
Like when you get to this level.
This to me is like,
there's so much more going on
and it's so much more likely to have something going on.
Then it was just boxing.
You know?
There's just way more boring rounds,
in my opinion.
At least inboxing and there isn't high level kickboxing.
We backup Jamie back up eve Edwards.
Awesome.
That's what he had him in trouble.
Yeah.
He tagged him.
He hit him.
He hit him there again.
He hit him a couple times really hard and you could see a host can taking some
big deep breaths.
It's
quite a little exchange there.
This guy is a savage.
How do you say Mike Pesan.
Yay.
How do you say his last name,
sir?
All of these tough things like Mike,
Passenger rear passengers and year
boy.
That guy trained a bunch of savages.
Oh yeah,
like I used to.
I don't,
I don't actually,
it's weird how he used to bring my Melvin out.
Yeah,
Dude.
Like on a chain,
like a dog.
I remember that Melvin,
and I think that was his idea.
Oh yeah,
he was getting unchained do Melvin was crazy back in the day.
I mean you talk about a guy who live by the sword die by the sword.
He likes started the whole Gloria,
Gloria or gladiator a shorts thing.
Yeah.
Everybody does that.
Not every chick has that every check.
Well why is it that so many Thai shorts bind up on the legs?
Like you always see Thai guys like roll in their pants up,
roll in their shorts up.
I think that happens more so like that's like their thing.
Cause in Thailand it's like 180 degrees usually have like these really cheap
like the old ties,
my nylon shorts until it becomes your habit like your take when you're pulling
your pants up like that all the time.
Oh I see.
But it's also like insanely hot and humid over there
and then that kind of becomes like your style is to pull your pant leg up or
whatever.
It just seems to me like,
particularly for MMA,
there's no benefit in wearing shorts.
I feel like tights give you way more benefit because no one's grabbing them.
Like there are moments in fights were dudes get their shorts grabbed and those
moments they pay off for the guy who grabbed the shorts.
It's happened before.
Guys have gotten takedowns they've defended takedowns to,
they maybe wouldn't have if it wasn't for a short grab.
They've controlled positions for brief moments with a short grab and then the
referee didn't see it or the referee did see it and it said,
stop grabbing the shorts.
But they had already did it.
All that can be eliminated with tights.
But then if you wearing tight and you get caught in a Komora,
how do you grab your own shorts?
You don't,
you don't go get continent.
Comodo don't get caught it.
He grabbed your Dick just reached out and fully latch on.
It's still your cup and it's Myrtle,
myrtle.
Leave Mercato on,
on her.
Um,
that's,
that's the only time we're shorts would help you though.
You were right.
Grabbing your arm to defend a,
or grabbing your pants to defend a Komora.
What's kind of weird that you can do that you can grab your own choice.
Yeah.
What the fuck is that?
You can grab your own church to defend yourself.
Yeah,
that seems weird,
doesn't it?
Nope.
I don't think she should be able to grab your shorts to choke a guy.
Like if you wrap your leg around the guy's neck,
right.
And then you reach behind like the back of his head and you almost like a Zeke,
you'll choke
your own pants and choke them with your own shorts.
Can you do that?
I don't,
I can't imagine the position,
but I don't know.
It seems like somebody should have come up with that already.
I just go and see how you get your arm,
I guess.
Well this is what I'm saying.
If somehow or another you had like your leg,
like your thigh,
like right here over the guy's neck and you went behind his head and you grabbed
a hold of your shorts and he just straighten your leg out.
You're choking that guy out.
What does and what your own shorts.
It's like an Ezekiel choke like one of those old school judo style.
Zeke you'll chokes with the collar.
I bet you it's legal.
Um,
I know one thing I've seen dudes do is they finished chokes by holding onto
their own gloves.
Yeah.
Like they've got ahold of a choke and they're,
they're literally,
they've got a handle like underneath where your tape is and you can cinch up a
choke with that handle.
And it's,
it's very effective.
Is illegal because it's your own hand.
I don't know if it's legal still.
I don't know.
It's legal.
Now I should know at Slu.
I should know this.
It's fine.
Every neuron JBC is,
is it legal to choke someone in MMA while holding onto your own glove?
Cause you definitely hold your glove if you're doing a gay teen,
like a lot of guys do a good teen like this and they clamp down on the glove and
they do it this way.
But I think the issue is in grabbing inside your glove cause then it's like
you've got a leather handle.
I mean,
if you can get all your fingers in there.
Yup.
That's a really good grip.
But yeah,
but I still don't see why it wouldn't be legal.
I guess you could get your fingers in here.
Yeah,
you could for sure.
You can get your fingers in it that way and they wouldn't even be able to see
it.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
You could have the top of your hand.
It's an interesting argument,
you know,
I just don't think you should be able to grab clothes,
period.
Like anybody you,
him,
no one grabs close.
Don't be grabbing clothes.
That'd be good to have him call his bro.
No clothes for.
We'll let them fight with a Gian.
Keep grabbing clothes and everyone's gonna be fighting tights.
Dude,
it was awesome back in the day to see boys crazy with a fucking g on go in there
and just rap guys up.
Drag him down and strangle them.
No denying it was awesome.
It was different,
that's for sure.
Fuck yeah,
it was.
I liked that because back then I was doing traditional Kung Fu.
So the first guy I wanted to see when was Jason Dilution.
Oh yeah man.
Did you ever see the street fight that they had in the Gracie Dojo war series
with dilution and hoists?
I feel like I saw that.
Yeah.
Once is grainy old VHS copy.
Dilu shows,
you know,
he knew how to fight.
He just didn't know how to defend against Jujitsu and hoist.
Mangled them.
But then that was before the UFC was it up and then they fought in the UFC and
then hoists arm barred him.
So he said already fought him in a Dojo war first and just do not just
demolished him.
Do you remember the Dojo storms
too?
Those are all real.
Those happened.
Did you ever take part in Daddy?
I didn't take part in the Dojo storm.
I took part in having to deal with guys that came over from other schools that
wanted it to like test themselves.
Like in most of them were,
there was a lot of them.
They're just delusional and crazy.
There's a lot of people that came to martial arts schools seem to be nuts.
Yeah.
Did you ever see that video?
It's a really disturbing one.
We played it a couple of weeks ago of this guy who was a karate student,
karate teacher and Connecticut,
and he was also a cop and him and his students beat the fuck out of this
homeless guy.
Like the guy they brought the guy in and the guy like was,
he was just a crazy person who was saying he knew karate and he's thrown like
crazy kicks and shit.
And so they have like essentially like a fight to the death.
The Gum?
Yes.
Yeah,
but like,
so I didn't know because I thought,
oh,
this looks ridiculous.
But then when the guy was actually trying to kill him,
he was like,
do it really well with his fucking made up shit.
Well the guy that,
he was shy as a black belt,
I mean this is cookbook.
He probably knew how to throw,
throw a few kicks here and there,
but the other guy,
I mean it wasn't long before he was on his back and the other guy was stomping
his head.
I mean,
it wasn't like a five minute fight or anything.
He,
he threw some flippy shit and some,
but eventually the guy beat the shit out of him.
But the point is that like,
that was like a crazy person.
They almost beat that guy to death when the dragging them away.
You see the blood from his head,
he like says they're dragging him away.
Yeah.
There was a lot of that going on in martial arts schools,
but that seemed,
that was older than the nineties.
That was old.
And I think that was the 80s.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
There was no MMA then.
Yeah.
But,
uh,
it was NHB but I mean there wasn't even any B then we had Hickson in and Hickson
was telling us the stories of the old [inaudible] Bray rivalries between the
Jujitsu guys and the loot delivery guys.
He would go there and there'd be guys waiting.
And it is Josh Thompson against Pat Heeley.
Yup.
Huh.
Yeah.
I remember bringing it up.
Um,
very smart,
smart way to seal up the choke if it's legal.
Um,
but a Hickson was talking about these crazy dojo wars,
if you ever listen to that podcast is a fucking,
if somebody wants to hear a good Jujitsu podcast from a master,
just having a conversation with the master,
I kicks and he's not just the master but a real pioneer,
you know,
a real pioneer of Jujitsu
and his anyways,
Dojo storm stories are fucking crazy.
It wasn't cron telling you he has a video of one of this house.
Yeah,
yeah.
He's got the Yohji Anjo video,
the Eog Anjo videos.
Legendary because Hixon this dude Yohji and Joe came over from Japan.
This is bad ass pro wrestler do to challenge Hixon Gracie and Hixon said,
yeah,
okay,
we'll do this.
This is what we're going to do.
You're going to come in here,
I'm going to film it.
And uh,
everybody else is going to wait outside.
And then,
uh,
whoever's left standing,
they'll leave.
So he takes him down,
beats his face into the,
like a tomato Stu and apparently filmed it and then they took pictures of the
guy after he left.
Like there's photos of Yohji Angelo leaving and his face is just a pulp in front
of [inaudible].
I seen those pictures,
so Hickson just beat,
beat him.
Beat Pete.
Do you remember this?
You can get them off him.
He's just mounted a beaten the shit out of him.
And then he decided to choke them unconscious.
But he tapped,
he taped his fists up with duct tape,
like Hixon on the way over there.
He was right.
He rode his bike from his house
and uh,
he wrote a test,
like a 10 speed there and on the way,
he's like fucking tape in his hands up with duck tape and he gets out and just
took him to who he was.
He was not just the best.
Right?
And that time it was like completely undisputed.
Like nobody said.
Well then there's Hickson and well the other argument is that this guy's the
best,
or maybe this guy's clothes.
There was no argument.
There's Hickson and then there was everybody else.
So this poor fool came over from Japan.
It just does completely fucked up.
And Hickson just beat his brains in these brains in its strangle them.
And then this is what the g Hixon is.
He doesn't even release the tape.
He's like,
no,
I've totally got it every now and then,
but that's my,
that's a car.
That's awesome.
He's like,
Nah,
I like looking at it.
It's mine.
Then you,
they think you just confirmed it.
Urban Legend for me cause I feel like I've heard pieces of that places.
Oh it's real.
It's real.
One of my happiest moments as a martial artist was I had dicks.
I had a dinner with Hickson and his family and crawling when he was younger.
Cron was like,
um,
I want to say it was 16,
maybe 16 or 17 at the time.
I think he's still in high school though.
I'm pretty sure Hickson was still married.
We had dinner and then we all went back to Hickson's house and watch fights.
And uh,
Hickson was just analyzing positions and talking about mistakes people are
making and talking about the right way to do things and he pushes shit aside and
is living,
really pushes the coffee table aside.
And he's like,
ah,
I'm going to get your guard,
I want to,
I want to show you some positions.
And he's like talking about positions like the,
you know,
he was talking about like mistakes that these guys in this fight tape,
they were watching.
We're watching VHS tapes and we're watching guys who'd made mistakes and this is
what's wrong and this is why Jujitsu is all you need when you have the best
Jujitsu.
Like he was,
he had this crazy,
crazy way of analyzing like positions,
you know,
it was really interesting to talk to them about like everything starts neutral.
It's like we started in neutral position,
he goes,
but once I get to one,
there's no going back to zero.
He goes,
I go from one and then I'll go to two and then to three and then check me when
there's the way he said it was like,
Oh shit.
But it was the way said and once I go to one,
we're not going back to zero.
It was just,
this is,
I mean this is the words of a man who straggled many a motherfucker.
Yeah.
Once I started setting you up,
you're done.
Yeah,
I mean he just was so just a terminally confident,
and this is when he was still thinking about fight and fader.
He hadn't fought since 2000.
He fought in 2000.
He fought for knocky who was probably one of his toughest test for knock.
He fractured his orbital,
remember that he fractured you.
Hixon dog action,
orbital with a punch and then it wound up being for knocky on top,
kicking Hickson's legs on the bottom.
And Hickson was,
uh,
trying to uptake his legs,
trying to up kick his knees and then somehow or another they had gotten to a
scramble and then Hicks and got his bag and Hanks and choked him to sleep.
What was that event?
I forget the coliseum.
Coliseum.
I used to have the poster.
I have a shitload of those fucking pollsters fan.
But um,
yeah,
so Hixon that was his last fight and that was,
you know,
that was a fight that everybody,
a lot of people had said,
like what would happen to Hicks and fought a guy like Funai.
But he was one of the examples because he had fought in Japan Valley Tuto ran
through everybody and there'd been no one that had presented any like real
serious challenges to him.
Then he fucked a Kata,
ran through Takata,
remember that?
You know,
people forget Hickson was in pride number one.
Hickson was the guy who launched pride and it was like Krs one was,
do you remember that?
It's like Pri Keres Harris,
one promotion that was the carer has pride.
It's k something.
I feel like krs sounds right to one barely watching this.
Awesome fight when takes him was fighting in pride.
They were called.
So that's the,
that's another thing they need on fight pass.
They need to put choke on there.
Oh yeah,
no doubt.
Right.
The choke documentary,
is that one of the greatest martial arts documentaries of all time?
No,
the greatest.
What's better?
Well,
that's the greatest.
It's the greatest,
you know,
details him going through that Japan Valley Tuto crowd.
Dude,
I,
when I first saw that I tried to do that stretch and I call,
he was twisted like a pretzel.
Yeah.
I've been trying to do that ever since.
I can't do it.
Well,
he can't do it anymore either.
If that makes me feel better.
So I don't think he can.
He's got quite a few injuries though from all was years of Jujitsu.
Yeah.
No,
nobody rides for free.
Yeah,
you got it.
But he was,
uh,
he was like one of the first guys to,
to,
uh,
incorporate yoga into his training.
Look at that stretch lose was doing there.
He was seriously into yoga.
He had ridiculous posture or a ridiculous,
our balance.
Rather,
he received that shitty did on balance beams.
He would walk on one leg and then lift his leg completely over his head and a
standing split.
Wasn't that on choke?
Might've been.
I think it wasn't,
it was on something else similar to it.
This a fucking good fight.
We're paying attention.
I have no idea who won.
Well,
I've been kind of paying attention.
I still can.
Here's one.
Yeah,
no clues,
right.
Ooh.
But I do now know [inaudible] story.
I know that now.
Yohji Yohji Yamamoto.
Yeah.
That's apparently a completely legit story.
It's definitely legit that he did it to him and apparently completely jet that
he has the tape.
But that's just what a gangster he is like he could sell that tape,
he can make money off that tape.
And he's like,
yeah,
it's mine,
it's mine.
He's also the guy that like,
he had a price,
like you said,
look,
I'll fight for this amount if you don't have that amount of not fighting.
And that was it.
I mean there was no negotiating this discussion.
Yeah.
I mean he,
and a lot of ways he raised the expectations at fighters had for purses.
Yeah.
Because he always had very high expectations for himself and very high
requirements,
you know?
And,
and people said that he was like pricing himself out of fights,
but he had just,
just decided,
I think like this is what I'm worth.
Right.
And is he there?
I get this or they don't want to pay me what I'm worth so I don't fight for what
I'm not worth.
Yeah.
Or for less than what I'm worth.
Is this the main event?
It was doing 20 hour podcasts here.
What the fuck this thing start at six 30 and that was the undercard remember,
I know.
We didn't know though.
I thought we were here for the fights.
Gruen hearts.
Amen.
Yeah.
Greenheart growing heart.
Do you think you won a,
I think Nikki one.
He looked a little sharper but I didn't,
I wasn't paying that close attention.
That's a real problem isn't it?
Yeah.
Bunch of fucking blabber mouth
I think.
I think it was in a fight though.
I think we talked about some important shit though.
I like stories.
Yeah,
I like story.
That's what I sounded like
I do to men.
But I did too.
Yeah,
like a Hixon Yohji on Joe's story.
And those are,
those are like legendary stories.
Like if you went back and you read about the tales of me and molten Musashi and
is all of a sword fights.
Yeah.
You,
you'd want to hear about those from someone who actually knew about them and
they could tell you about them.
Like we're,
we're so lucky because like obviously it's not the same as sword fights,
but these crazy legendary martial arts stories,
they happen in our lifetime.
So it's not like we're hearing about something from the 14 hundreds we're
hearing about some shit that happened and you know the year 95 yeah.
Kinda cool.
They'll know.
That's really cool.
I'm going to tell you something I would recommend or you might like this.
I don't know.
My son,
he just turned 13 this summer,
but,
but two or three years ago,
he was like 10 or 11 we were in Austin.
I was like,
you know what Yvonne,
we're going to do a podcast together.
So we sat down and we talked for an hour and it's just for me and,
and I'm going to leave it for him,
you know.
But we talked about a bunch of stuff and it was one of the coolest conversations
I've ever had.
You should probably do that with your girls.
Cause when it's,
when they're older and,
and if,
if you're gone when they're old or when they're your age now,
right.
They'll have to go back and listen to if they want to.
Yeah,
that's a good idea.
Yeah.
I have a little chat with them on a recording.
Yeah,
that's a really good idea,
man.
I'm going to do that with my,
I'm going to do it with my,
my daughter.
I'm doing my mom.
That's a really good idea.
I think if my dad died when I was 12,
if,
if I,
if I could,
if I had a tape of us talking,
I would,
you know what I mean?
Just imagine having that.
Yeah.
Hi everybody.
I would recommend everybody do that.
Just if you have an iPhone or whatever.
It just talk to your kid for a bit and we talked about so many things we were
talking about.
I was like,
if you could go back in time,
if you had a time machine,
what would you do?
Where would you go?
He was like,
I dunno what the 19 hundreds and I'm like,
I grew up in 1,930 [inaudible] talking to
kids.
Look at the 99.
He was like,
Oh man,
back in the fucking old day.
So like things like that.
I then somehow we got to talking about my dad and um,
about me being a kid around my dad and he was like,
if I had a time machine,
I would go back.
I would go back and meet your dad.
You know what I mean?
Right.
Like,
and that's what made me think,
no,
this is something we should do.
Because then if he decides he wants kids or if he has kids or whatever,
if they don't meet me,
they'd have that.
Yeah.
If you wanted to share it.
No,
that's,
that's important.
That's a good point.
Oh Shit.
I didn't see that.
He spun them down and hit him with a knee on the way down
or putting combinations together.
Wow.
Every time I was looking at getting a little bit,
this is a crazy fight.
So I think,
uh,
Joseph Valtellina he's saying that he came on too late.
They needed more.
We'll see.
Um,
Valtellina he had to stop fighting because of a head trauma right now.
That's what he said.
And that's what I,
that's what I heard.
Yeah.
I said he was,
uh,
having concussion syndrome.
It's been pretty open about it.
How did he,
I mean he how many times he'd been knocked down?
I don't know anything.
It's from the knock out or just sneaky holster.
John stopped him.
Probably just shots to the head shots absorbed.
Wow.
Nikki holds.
Can you got hit way more?
Hey shilling.
Do you,
do you know that there used to be roommates or people wanted to see Joe Rogan in
the octagon?
Oh my God.
Again was it wasn't like,
do you know about the room,
about you and and,
and then played Wesley Snipes?
Yeah.
I've talked about that before,
but that,
that it was actually supposed to happen.
Oh,
I didn't know that was a,
that wasn't just a rumor at the time.
I was willing to,
I just like,
I know you know what you're trying to do it all.
I was like,
what are the odds is going to keep me off of,
I just didn't,
I just didn't think that anybody who didn't know any Jujitsu could learn a
quick,
I'm like,
I was already a brown belt by then.
I was just,
I just knew what happened when a brown belt fights a white belt.
I'm like,
I just can't imagine,
and I know how to stand up.
And even if I wasn't good at striking anymore,
like as I was when I was a kid,
I'm good enough to know what to not do and where to not be.
And if I get ahold of someone who doesn't know Jujitsu,
I'm pretty sure I'm choking the fuck out of them.
And that was my thought.
I was like,
this guy really wants to do this.
I,
I know he doesn't,
he's never wrestled.
He never had a competitive martial arts match,
whether it's a kickboxing fight or karate,
fine.
I was like,
I'm going to choke the fuck out of this guy.
I'm going to get ahold of him when I was squeeze the shit out of them and
they're going to give me a lot of money and he's probably not even going to get
hurt.
That's what I thought.
And it turned out really what it was was just,
he was desperate and a real bad situation with the IRS.
And so they were trying to figure out some way to generate money.
And one of the ways they said,
look,
let's just see if we can come up with a,
a crazy paper view fight.
And they wanted to fight John Claude van Damme and some paper if you fight,
the guy they brought it to was this guy,
Campbell Mclaren,
who was one of the original producers of the UFC.
And he's like,
look,
nobody's going to pay to see you.
And John Claude van Damme fight.
I disagreed.
I pay for it.
But they said,
no one's going to pay for that.
You know,
you have to fight someone who's a w I think the word he used was current.
So he said,
would you fight Joe Rogan?
This wouldn't fear factor was on.
And he said,
Yep,
I'll do it.
Let's do it.
And so they came to me and I went,
how much money?
And then they started talking.
I said,
okay.
I'll do it.
And they,
are you serious?
I go,
yeah,
I'll,
I'll fight that guy.
I was like,
okay,
we'll see what happens.
And so,
uh,
then there was like a bunch of changes to the contract.
It was supposed to be 50,
50.
Then it changed.
And I said,
okay to that to said whatever,
let's just do it.
Let's just do it.
Come on,
let's do it.
Like,
and I was training for for quite a while.
I was training for it for a couple of months and I was fucking tired all the
time.
I was trying to,
with rob came in and I was doing Jujitsu,
so I'd be hitting pads it,
rob came and it's barn with him and sparring with some of the students and then
a good Jujitsu and I was fucking tired.
And it made me,
I always knew how hard it was to,
to be a professional MMA fighter.
I'd seen people work at it.
I'd seen guys struggle.
I'd seen guys like Connor hewn was like a young guy was coming up and the
amateur ranks and I was seeing him fight it out of legends.
So I knew the requirement of it.
But until you,
I mean the Piss ass amount of training that I was doing in comparison to what it
is to fight in the UFC or something like that.
And it just gave me way more of a,
an appreciation for just how much,
how much it takes out of your life because it's not just the amount of time that
you're spent training.
It's like when you're done training your fucking tired and you're not going to
get a lot of other things done and if you do you're going to be cranky.
Right.
Any help.
So that was the story behind it and he just decided not to do it apparently.
And when it became more obvious that they didn't want money,
they wanted to put them in jail,
they wanted to put them in jail and set an example.
I think this was all while his court case was still going on.
I don't want to talk out of school cause I don't know what the exact issue was,
but they want to putting them in jail for tax evasion because he had some guy
who apparently was advising him incorrectly about how much taxes he had to pay
or whether or not he had to pay taxes at all.
I don't know the whole story,
but uh,
that was what was going on.
He was just in desperation mode.
I thought it,
I always thought that was a rumor.
Now there was real,
I remember,
I remember you mentioning it on a broadcast who went because he wouldn't sign
the contract because it was going on for a long time.
And I was like,
what are we doing?
Like am I,
am I doing this because if I'm doing this,
I'm not doing anything else.
Like I need to know if I'm doing this.
And I was training a lot then.
So I was like,
okay,
see now you're getting pissed.
Because I was getting pissed at a certain point in time,
but I was,
that was when,
you know,
I was training Jujitsu a lot and I was training several times a week.
Who knows?
He might have fucked me up totally possible,
but I was pretty sure I was going to choke him.
It was just one of those things where it's like,
if it was like Michael Jai white or something like that,
I'd be like,
fuck that.
You know?
Mario Lopez knows how to box.
He used to wrestle.
Fuck that.
Not Interested.
Some duties.
Never done Jujitsu.
Hmm.
We just feel like it's only so much you can do,
you know like white belt,
Brown belt.
Do you remember the first time you got mauled and in like a Jujitsu class?
Yeah.
Isn't it weird?
It's like the first time you get mauled you like,
I had no idea someone could do that to me.
So easy.
Yeah.
I got choked by,
I was like 18 I got choked by a 14 year old.
I'm serious.
He was like,
I didn't know what I was doing.
Course,
there was a kid at Carlson Gracie's place that used to torture me.
I was a white belt and he was a purple belt and he was no bigger than me who's
no younger than me.
He was like my age,
my size,
and used to just rape me.
It's,
there's just no denying that this dude,
if we were in a fight,
he would be able to choke the fucking life out of me and I would only be able to
hold them off for a certain amount of time.
It was just,
I was a white belt.
I didn't know what I was doing and he wasn't nice about it either.
He was smash you,
but that guy taught me a lot of,
it taught me a lot because I wrestled in high school and I'd done a lot of a
martial arts tournaments as far as like taekwondo tournaments and had done some
of that American kickboxing and I had a totally delusional sense of how much I
could keep someone off of me.
Like in terms of grappling.
Yeah.
I really had no idea.
It was just so humiliating.
Nobody knows.
They don't know any grappling,
striking,
whatever it has like this false sense of security.
I had to tell that to a friend of mine.
I had to tell that to a friend of mine who was a grappler.
I had a buddy of mine who have really good guy,
his black belt in Jujitsu.
He's like,
am I taking them and may fight like,
okay,
like why are you going to take an MMA fight?
He's like,
wow,
you know,
it's kind of a bucket list thing.
I want to do it.
I mean,
you're to dabble in this.
Are you going to compete?
You're going to fight.
Like we had these one of these conversations like how are you going to do this?
And I'm like,
you know what you can do to a guy because he's a black belt.
Okay.
You know what you could do to a guy on the ground that doesn't know what the
fuck he's doing.
Someone could do that to you standing up and it's way worse.
It's way worse because if a guy takes you down,
strangles you,
you're done.
You tap you like you get up,
your neck is a little sore,
you're going to be fine and go to work.
The next tab,
if eve Edwards Shins you across the Dome,
that's not a fun time.
That's not a fun time and your legs turn into rubber and they give out from you
and the world's spinning and you here.
That's exactly right.
It's exactly right.
It's terrible.
It's a terrible place to be,
you know?
Yeah.
It's just one of those things that I don't think people realize until they see
it happen or until they do it to somebody like it.
Since they can't do it to somebody that I don't think they realize that someone
could do it to them.
I think everybody,
everybody should at least once every man anyway,
once in their lifetime here.
That yeah.
Feel it.
Cause that that's a different state of play.
It's just like a car accident.
Yeah.
People don't realize it when they get in the car accident.
It's same like buzz,
like when you see,
when you see those films,
if you've never experienced that,
when you see those films where as a car accident or a big hit and they,
they do that effect,
just imagine all of that,
but inside your own head,
it's really just like that for about two to three seconds as it clears up.
I remember when Tito Ortiz Body slammed Evan Tanner and k Odom with a body slam.
I remember,
uh,
just watching that,
how he got the clench on him,
hoisted him up in the air and just slammed him to the ground.
And I remember thinking like,
so few people understand that a guy like Dan can just do that to you.
Yeah.
Imagine that on the street.
Oh my God.
Right in front of a Bodega.
Just slams you on a fire hydrant like that.
Okay,
here it is right here.
He got the body clench.
Boom.
Just Kayonin with a slam.
That was when Tito was in his full prime.
I mean,
seeing that a,
it doesn't that happen more often.
That seems like the guys are better.
Yeah,
you
guys are better.
They're better at adjusting on the way down to the guys are realizing the
consequences of that head getting into play.
They're protecting themselves because a lot of it is in the body slam.
You're also getting headbutted,
you know?
Hmm.
Did you,
I don't remember who it was happen.
It was around the turn of the Millennia,
um,
Millennia.
But um,
somebody
got picked up in that body body lock and they were dumping them and they posted.
Do you remember this?
I feel like it was Jason de Lucia posted,
snapped his arm,
no posted on his foot and it's close to on his leg.
Uh,
if somebody remembers that I,
if I find it,
I'll send it to you.
But I feel like somebody's got body locked and he got picked up with that same
slam that Tito tried to hit with.
Just hit on at Hannah.
And as he tilted his feet,
let's flipped his feet over his head,
getting Sam this way,
but he reached,
reaches out with his leg,
stopped himself.
I want to serve.
Huh?
I can't remember.
I only saw it once cause I'm not looking at that again.
But it was,
yeah,
it was bad.
It was like he's dislocated his hip,
which some thought,
Jeez,
I feel like it was Jason de Lucia.
I don't remember for sure.
Now that you're bringing it up,
I have this fucking shaky memory.
That might just be you introducing a false memory into my head too.
They say the FBI does to people.
False false memories.
They can do that now.
Where are you there,
Joe Rogan?
I don't know man.
I know,
man.
You tell me,
I'm getting fucking confused.
Yeah,
we've been,
we've seen a lot of people get fucked up.
Yeah.
I think about it.
I asked my wife one time how many fight she's seen.
I can only imagine how many fights you've seen seen a lot of fights.
What's interesting is you and I have seen fights from the beginning to the,
obviously the most recent errors,
almost always the best era in every sport.
Right?
Right.
But this is the best era.
I mean the,
the,
the elite athletes of today are probably the best of all time,
right?
Yeah.
I,
I watch watch UFC broadcasts at home and I feel like I'm watching.
I didn't think I'd be watching this on television in the capacity that I'm
watching it now that I can see it in now.
Like these guys,
I see the fight,
I see these guys into the octagon and it's like I'm watching the NBA in the,
in the nineties early nineties or I'm watching the NFL and other early in the
mid nineties you know,
it's like this is,
this is becoming something that is a real sport.
It's,
it's the UFC is a league and this is a real sport that people actually respect
and this is going to be become a part of the culture.
You know,
people are going to,
their kids are gonna grow up to do these things.
For sure.
I didn't think I would see.
I didn't,
I didn't expect no who expected this at this point even,
I mean,
right.
I thought it was exciting.
I thought it was going to go somewhere,
but I didn't think he was going to be this quick.
No,
you're totally right.
It's amazing.
I mean,
and that's because the balls or the Fertittas cough up all that cash,
you know,
get $44 million in the hole and sticking with it and then eventually the
ultimate fighter finale airs and Stephan Bonner and Forrest Griffin put on that
crazy show and then it all springs from there.
It's pretty incredible that you're,
you're looking at today,
you know,
major events on
Fox.
That's giant.
I mean they're huge.
They get millions and millions of people,
giant paper views and then Connor and Rhonda,
these two huge stars that have sort of transcended the sport and they become
these pulp pulp fiction like icons,
these characters,
he's pop fiction humans.
They become like something exaggerated when when the UFC had to move,
when they got banned in New York,
I had to move the event.
You can look in the backstage reporting.
That was my first one.
Dothan,
Alabama.
I didn't know if I was going to have to fly to Buffalo,
New York or Dothan,
Alabama last minute.
It was Dothan.
That's like,
this is just a while ago and now it's like Madison Square Gardens.
Yeah.
That was 19 years ago.
Those 97 crazy.
Yeah.
Now it's in Madison Square garden with the fucking Nadine has card of assassins
that's ever been put together.
There's no better example of the fight game at a being at its highest level now
than that card.
Like that car.
I mean,
look at all the killers on that card.
It was just chaos.
The whole car.
It's just chaos from top to bottom.
That's a lot of guides you you can get by without watching a fight,
but there's not one on there that I don't add.
I want to miss.
Yeah,
no,
it's a nutty card.
It's almost like show up at a chick's house the first time you bring diamonds
and roses and chocolate and champagne.
What the fuck you going to do the second time?
Just bring your dirty deck.
She's like,
what happened?
All the fucking diamonds.
Bitch.
Where's the champagne?
Like you almost can't make this card again.
Yeah.
This card.
So the next time we're in Madison Square Garden,
people are going to be like,
what the fuck is this cat fucking cods bullshit.
Last time they were here.
We had three title fights plus Ramiro bashed his white men.
We had that guest,
Dillon Francis Cowboy.
It's going to be horrible.
It's going to be just like a girl that thinks you're tired of fucking her.
Excuse me.
The same thing.
Oh,
you think you're just going to come over now?
Huh?
You don't even have to bring diamonds.
Is that going to be like a once a year thing?
I think Madison Square Garden,
we'll for sure be a once a year thing.
The question remains,
did they decide to rub it in the face of all those corrupt cock suckers that
kept it out in New York for so long and keep generating these gigantic super
mega cards in New York.
So it shows everybody the massive amount of revenue that it brings into the
city,
not just in the actual ticket sales itself,
the taxes that are generated from the merchandise,
but then all the affecting businesses,
they're going to see a boom from all these people that are leaving,
that are going to go to bars and restaurants,
and they're going to see some of the craziest shit they've ever seen in their
life.
So when people see crazy shit like that,
they spend a lot of money,
man.
Yeah.
They start drinking and fucking eating crazy food.
It's going to be giant financially for the city.
And if they decide to just throw a mega tsunami card like this one once a year,
that would be like they've got the other mega tsunami cards.
Right?
It's usually like the July 4th cards,
usually a giant one and December 31st card is usually a giant one soup maybe.
Yeah.
Superbowl ones usually a pretty big one too.
Maybe this one too.
But this is kind of almost to to make a point.
Yeah.
19 you're fucking years of corruption.
19 years,
19 years.
It was kept out in New York.
It's a long time and,
and it's,
it's not like they didn't see the sport.
The sport wasn't broad gassing,
you have,
the split wasn't banned from the state visually.
At least you know,
so.
So it wasn't like these people don't know what they're missing the fans.
Anyway,
you started getting a homegrown group of guys coming in behind maths area.
You know,
you get those long island and the guys,
you get why men's,
you get handle as guys and these guys are local and they don't get to fight at
home because,
because you have a problem with something unit corrupt and it's got millions of
pay per view buys.
Yeah.
So if you're putting on like whether it's UFC 100 or UFC 200 or two oh two oh
one you're getting into these hundreds of millions of people all throughout the
world that are watching something that you can't have in your state.
Like what the fuck are you doing?
That's crazy.
It doesn't even make sense.
Stupid.
There's millions of fans all over the world of MMA now.
Absolutely not.
I do not want your money.
Well,
it's just keeping it out for,
you know the whole reason why the culinary union.
Yeah.
Allegedly,
allegedly until all alleged Joe Schilling I've checked out too.
I'm just still talking for some reason we just shut the fuck up and wrap this
up.
We've talked forever for the long show.
Eve Edwards,
we finally got you on,
but we got you on for a doozy.
I mean been here for the time that you've been talking about doing this podcast
now.
We got you on for five fucking hours,
so it was like five two for one.
This is a fun glory guys.
It was a fun fight companion.
We should do these for a,
for some other fights.
Maybe for some other Moy Thai fights or glory or something like that.
I was good times right.
Sounds good.
It's a good time.
All right.
I'm Joe Schilling.
Good luck on December 10th.
Don't pull out of your fight to a watch.
Badr Hari versus Rico.
Verhoeven said we fighting them like who are you fighting?
Um,
Italian guy isn't a as so I haven't figured out how to say it.
Yeah,
he's good.
He's good.
He's like a,
he's got like 60 fights are 60,
65 something like that.
It's got a ton of fights and that's taking place in Europe.
Yeah.
It's going to be in Florence,
Italy.
Oh Wow.
Boxing Florence is supposed to be the shit supposed to be beautiful over there.
I'm looking forward to it.
And then it was still on the car to the main event is Carvallo and Melvin
Manhoef rematch unless just scars on the card.
It was Kevin Ross on the card.
Beautiful.
Oxy Beautiful.
And uh,
Eve Edwards.
They can get you at a,
is it thug Jujitsu?
What does it talk Jitsu MMA.
What is your Twitter?
Thug.
Jujitsu master.
So slug,
Yeah.
And uh,
what about Instagram?
Instagram is the same with Doug Jitsu master.
Um,
easiest way to find it.
We finally got to the bottom of the name.
That's awesome.
All right.
This podcast is over.
Thank you everybody.
Bye.
Okay.